Zach galwitzer created our extremely
popular front-end web development boot
camp course now he's back with this
project-based course that will help you
solidify your understanding of a variety
of front-end web development Concepts
you'll practice HTML CSS JavaScript
typescript react and more so let's get
started hey free code Camp my name is
Zach and today I'm really excited to
share a video I've been working on for a
while where I take a tic-tac-toe game
and build it in vanilla JavaScript HTML
and CSS and then refactor that to go to
typescript and then finally typescript
plus react this is going to be a super
fun tutorial it's going to be long but I
hope that you're going to learn a ton
from this and get some practical Real
World Experience building this with me
now this is actually what I would call
kind of a sequel to another video that I
posted on this very Channel free code
Camp a couple months ago I posted a
front-end developer boot camp and since
then it has gotten over a million views
so thank you all for watching that I'm
glad that you enjoyed it this video is
meant to be a direct follow-up to that
because all the lessons that you learned
throughout are going to be applied in
this video we're going to take all of
that stuff and put it into action and
give you a project that is a little bit
more real world a bit more challenging
but a great learning experience as
always want to give a big shout out to
free code camp for allowing me to come
on the channel and giving me the
exposure to to teach a broader audience
I have a smaller Channel myself you can
check that out got a link in the
description and I will also make a note
that this video is actually three videos
squashed together so I originally posted
these three on my channel this is just
all combined so if you kind of hear me
talking about the next video or the
previous video that's why and finally
there is a GitHub repository I'll
mention this a couple times in the
description that you should check out as
it's got all of the source code that I
will be writing in this project as well
as some attribution because this was
actually originally a subscriber
refactor I react I reached out to my
subscribers and said hey submit your
code I'll review it and redo it and show
you how I would approach it so that's
how this originally started so thank you
Yvonne and Meg for submitting that their
handles are also in that GitHub
repository so without further Ado let's
jump in and build this tic-tac-toe game
in this video I'm going to walk you
through the step-by-step process of
building this tic-tac-toe game which is
mobily responsive you can play it on a
mobile device and it works across
browser tabs leveraging local storage so
that you know you can have different
players playing from different browser
tabs and it also is going to have a
bunch of different things such as some
animations going on up here you've got
some an actions menu that allows you to
reset the game and then once you get
through and start recording different
wins so you don't really have to play on
these separate tabs but you can once
someone wins you'll see a modal pop up
and gray out the entire background and
you can click play again you'll see that
that state is tracked over time and even
if we refresh the browser tab that's
going to stay there you can even reset
that and make it a new round all of the
code that I'm writing here is going to
be in this tic-tac-toe subscriber
refactor repository that is on my GitHub
and I'll drop that in the video
description
all right so this video is going to
cover all sorts of Concepts
um this is actually loaded with useful
Concepts doing anything with vanilla
JavaScript HTML and CSS really requires
you to think about things because you
don't get all of the backstops that some
libraries and Frameworks like react or
vue.js give you so it will really
require us to think a bit but it will be
fun to explore some different concepts
and patterns for example we're going to
be looking at what is a MVC
architectural pattern or model view
controller we're going to be talking
about what is State what does that
actually represent
we're going to talk a little bit about
event delegation so in other words what
that means
is when you go to this game and you
click one of these squares it's actually
registering a click listener on the
parent component and then delegating
that event so that we can find which
Square was clicked so that will be fun
to go through
mobile responsiveness as I showed you
some CSS animations that uh tic-tac-toe
grid is actually using CSS grid and then
a lot more so all of these Concepts will
be fun to go through and if you are not
familiar with HTML CSS in JavaScript I
recommend you go through my full stack
which kind of became a front-end
development roadmap and it's like over
21 hours and it's all posted on my
channel here and I'm probably going to
put this video as the next video in that
series because it is a perfect
transition from all of those Concepts
that we covered throughout that series
and applying them in a very real world
type scenario to build this game out so
this is kind of doubling as a subscriber
refactor and just a very useful project
to build and learn a bunch of cool
concepts with but you definitely have to
know HTML CSS in JavaScript at least at
a basic level to get through this video
and I recommend you watch the prior
video where I kind of walk through the
original project that this was based on
and I kind of talked through what are
some of the good things that they did
there what were some of the things that
could be improved and I'll be
referencing kind of back to that to kind
of show how we can improve on certain
things so I recommend you at least watch
the first part of that video or kind of
skim through it now I will forewarn you
I've put that this is a beginner to
intermediate level video
um because we're going to be covering a
lot of ground here this will be very
challenging to you if you are just kind
of starting out and I did this on
purpose because I think there's not a
lot of tutorials out there that really
focus on the vanilla side and vanilla
just means no extra Frameworks or
libraries involved I don't think there's
a lot tutorials out there that really
show you how to take a vanilla app and
actually put some design patterns behind
it and do it in a way that you could
extend it into the future and you can
come back to this project and understand
what's going on and have a quick
straightforward way to add new features
to the game with all that said let's get
started this is going to be a long and
fun video so I'll put some time stamps
in there and
um probably want to grab a hot drink and
get situated because this is gonna it's
gonna take a while so
um these brand or this uh repository is
the repository that I will post in the
put in the video description it has the
completed projects so you can see I have
a reactory factor that'll actually be
the next video where we take our build
from this video and we throw that into
well not throw it we rebuild it as a
react application and show you kind of
the progression of how do you go from
vanilla to react and what are some of
the commonalities and differences
between the two and it will really help
you understand why we use something like
react and why it makes our lives easier
as a developer so that's what those are
the original is the original project
just as a reference
um but what I'm going to do is actually
create a new folder
uh live vanilla build and this is where
we're going to be working out of for
this video I'll basically be recruit
recreating everything here in the
vanilla refactor and I may reference
this
um a little bit here and there just so
that we're not getting too far off from
that code so just as a forewarning the
live build that we're going to do might
have like some tiny little differences
between the final state that you see on
GitHub but overall it will go in the
same exact Direction all right so what
is the first thing that we do when we
start a new project well we're doing a
front-end project here so the natural
thing to do is create an index.html
document but before that I want to do
some administrative stuff
um with Visual Studio code I'm going to
assume that you are using visual studio
code
um and the reason is because it's an
awesome editor and most people use it so
the first thing you'll need to do is go
over to extensions and open up live
server this is an extension that
basically allows you to view HTML
documents in your browser on Port 5500
is the default so you can see that's
already running let me go ahead and
click close
so that'll dispose that
um let me get these windows
figured out here
okay so if you see I reload this it
won't reload let's go ahead and close
that
and then if you go down
get rid of my bar down there if you
click go live once this live server is
installed with Visual Studio it will
open up Port 5500 so let's go to
this and it'll show you just the
directories you're working with so it's
just replicating this right here and
what we're going to do is click on the
live vanilla build right now it's empty
so it's not going to show anything but
what we're going to do is create an
index.html file so we'll say index.html
and then we'll use vs code's built-in
emit Snippets to type HTML and then
we'll click
HTML5 to get some boilerplate built out
for us
now the second thing that I'm going to
show you is format on Save and this
should be really part of your Dev
workflow no matter where you go because
it's just useful so as you can see this
boilerplate is not indented correctly
and when I click command s on my Mac to
save you can see that it formats this
document
so the way that I got that working is
through another extension called
prettier and prettier is a code
formatter used by pretty much everyone
at this point or at least it feels like
so it's a very industry standard and
what you can do is hit command P
hit the little bracket or not bracket
whatever that carrot and type open user
settings and it's right here because
I've used it recently
don't worry about all this stuff these
are the only lines that really matter so
you'll add these two configuration lines
this is also documented uh in the
extension it'll show you right here that
you need to add those and once you've
added the added those it's going to
detect every time you save and reformat
the file
all right so that is kind of the
administrative stuff that we're dealing
with
um I don't think I missed anything so
make sure that you you get set up with
both of those things so now that I have
saved this we can go back to our live
server and we should have an empty HTML
document so if you inspect
you can see that here the elements and
let's just go ahead and change this to
vanilla Js
T3 for Tic-tac-toe and then we'll go
ahead and just put a placeholder
P tag in there so you can see something
and you can see that when we save that
it auto loads
um or it you know has hot reloading so
that all the changes are reflected
immediately in the browser alright so
the very next thing that I will always
do when I'm starting a project and this
is really kind of the starting point for
me at least for any project whether we
have a back end involved if it's full
stack or just like we're doing here
where it's just front end
I'm going to start with the UI and build
the layout for the entire application
and I actually have a video on that that
kind of explains that process in depth
in my front end course on this channel
so you can go revisit that if you need
but basically the goal here is to build
out the HTML structure and then build
out the layout with CSS now I debated
this in my head a bit of how much time I
was going to spend on this portion of
the video and I ultimately decided that
this is going to be deprioritized a
little bit so that we can focus more on
the JavaScript patterns behind all this
I have plenty of previous videos where
we go in depth like in excruciating
detail of how to build HTML and CSS how
to bring those together and design
things and if you watched my front end
course the last
um a series of videos in that course was
all about CSS grid so we're going to
leverage that we're going to use that in
a real world project here but I am not
going to be getting into every last
little detail we're going to take some
Liberty and do a little bit of copy
pasting from this
um
vanilla refactor that I've already built
um as as kind of a precursor to this
video that said we're going to take it
piece by piece so that you can at least
see how it's coming together in the
thought process behind that but I will
not be typing the HTML and CSS line by
line because we will be here for the
next 10 years if um if if I do that my
videos are already quite long and they
do not need to be longer especially when
this is not what we're focusing on so
let's go ahead and do some copy pasting
here so if we look at this index.html
this is the final HTML of this project
the one that we're going for so the
first thing I want to focus in on is the
grid so that's the hardest thing to
conceptualize with building this out and
when I say that grid we're going to
actually duplicate this tab so that we
have a reference to look at
and my
vanilla refactor will give us that
complete picture that we want and so
what we're trying to do here is build a
grid that has all of these squares here
but then as you can see there's also
these uh State variables down here I
shouldn't call them State variables but
a little scoreboard that lines up
perfectly with this grid and something a
little bit less obvious up here the
actions menu also lines up perfectly
with the grid and this player one you're
up indicator this spans kind of two
sections of the grid so really what
we've got here
and what we need to replicate is a grid
that is let's count it you've got three
columns so one two three and then the
number of rows is going to be one so
this this top kind of header section is
going to be one section of our grid then
two three four and then this five bottom
one so really what we have is a how does
this go which one goes first is it the
five by three or three by five grid
um hard hard to remember that while I'm
talking here on video but that's
basically what we're going to be
building and if I Collapse this finished
document so vs code has these code
collapse things that can really help for
to see kind of how things are structured
um so what we can do is collapse
everything until it's a lot more clear
as to what the grid items are
so you can see that my
container has a class of grid and that
grid is going to give us the display
grid so if we go to our index.css
and we go to the grid class you'll see
that that is initializing the grid
container
um and let's go back to this
HTML and then as we know if you watched
that previous series on grid is that
grid is going to have child Elements
which are called The Grid items now
these are direct descendants of its
container and as you can see we have one
two and then there's nine of these
squares and then there's three little
scoreboard squares there at the bottom
so that's the basic structure but we are
not going to start with all of these
different styles and markup you want to
start simple and the way that we're
going to do that is by creating a bunch
of divs and just starting with a basic
grid here in order to do that we need an
index.css file so if you see in the
vanilla refactor we've got some folders
for the different types of files you
don't really need that that was just an
organization thing
for this rebuild I'm just going to try
to mirror that so we'll create a CSS
folder and then a new file in there
called index.css
and then let's go ahead this is
something that I always do let's just
throw uh an all selector and then color
red
and that means every text everything is
going to be or all the text is going to
be red and the reason I do that is just
to make sure we're hooked up correctly
so let me close all these files out out
this index.html is our starter you can
see I have a placeholder here and what I
need to do is right above the title
we're going to add a link
and we're going to go down and hit enter
on the link CSS and you can see it
already knows to go grab the style.css
but that's not what we want because we
have a custom directory
so let's go to CSS and select index
save that and now if this is hooked up
correctly this should be red
so let's go right here and you can see
that it is red and it is connected up so
the very first thing that we need to do
is put in a main
HTML tag and the reason that we put the
main tag in there is because this should
represent the dominant content of the
document now if you wanted to figure
that out on your own you can just type
in mdn main so mdn Main and it'll be the
first result and it says it represents
the dominant content if you scroll down
here on the usage notes it says it
should be unique for the document
content that is repeated such as
sidebars nav links copyright should not
be within main so in our case this
tic-tac-toe board is the dominant
content of this index.html document so
we want it inside Main
furthermore we'll need a div container
which will be the grid container itself
and we want to give that a class of grid
which we will style within index.css but
if you remember let me hit command B on
my Mac to close out that sidebar
if you remember on this original we had
the grid class and then we had all these
grid items so we had one two
um nine more right here so 11 12 13 14.
if I can count basic math right but
basically we just need a bunch of divs
within here so we can make one command C
copy that all the way down and how many
is that three six nine eleven
okay we'll we'll come back to this if we
didn't get that right but anyways we've
got the skeleton of our grid and now if
we come into index.css
we can make that grid class and say
display grid another thing that we'll
want to do just to start us out is the
CSS reset this was in the original
project already
and we can just copy it over
so the CSS reset is just gonna reset
everything so that we don't have any
weird padding going on and
anything like that so let's go ahead and
put that at the top
and then we can also initialize our
fonts and colors like I said I'm not
going to spend a ton of time on this
portion of the video
um I've got prior videos that go into
more depth here but basically we're
importing uh a Google font right here
and then we are initializing our set of
colors as CSS variables on the root
selector so we'll be able to use that
with the VAR and then dash dash whatever
variable it is within our CSS so we'll
save this we'll come back to our
document here and you'll see that it's
completely empty which is kind of what
we're looking for now if you looked at
the vanilla refactor here got it zoomed
in way too much
it has this darker background so the
first thing that we can do is actually
actually get that in there and that
would be I believe the dark gray right
here so let's just copy that over we're
going to select the HTML in the body
and
give it that background color now the
reason that we have a hundred percent
height this is something that's useful
for mobile devices because there's
another strategy of 100 of the screen
height but that screen height is
different on a mobile device versus a
desktop and you'll actually get some
little padding at the bottom so I prefer
to do height of a hundred percent but
anyways the main point here is we're
giving it that background color and this
is actually kind of a mistake from the
original we should be just putting in a
CSS variable there
all right so we'll come back and it
looks like we've got our background
matching that looks good and now we can
start to initialize this grid so at the
moment you should be able to find in the
main that we have all of these grid
items they're just not showing up at all
so we need to give them some space
within the document so that we can start
to work with them so if we wanted to do
that the quickest way to come in here
and do that is to go right below the
grid and then just select any div that's
within the grid class and let's just
give it a height of 20 pixels and a
width of 20 pixels we'll get rid of this
in just a moment but oh and then we also
need to give it a background color of
let's just say red something annoying
and you can see there's our grid items
we could also give it you know a margin
of 10 pixels you can start to see that
separation so right there there are our
grid items and they obviously don't look
near what we want them to so what we
need to do is set the boundaries of this
grid rather than doing this height and
width we can actually dictate how large
these items are using the grid container
so if you look in our original
CSS that was built out
you'll see that the grid container has
template columns and template rows and
then a grid Gap
so let's start with the columns we will
copy that over and what this is going to
do when we say repeat three times 80
pixels that means that each column is
going to be 80 pixels wide so let's save
that and you can start to see that we've
got some columns going here and
immediately you can see that I've added
one too many div elements
so we can come over to the index.html
and delete those
so now we have this perfect grid right
here
and then
we can come back to the CSS and then add
our template rows now our template rows
are going to be a little bit different
so I'll explain this in a second but
we'll copy that in and what we're saying
is that the first row is going to be 50
pixels tall then we're going to have
three rows so we're repeating three
times the next three rows are going to
be 80 pixels tall so that will
correspond with our columns so we'll
have those perfect squares and then the
final row which is kind of like that
scoreboard at the bottom will be 60
pixels high so that once we save it
you'll see that expressed within the
grid here and I believe
we actually need more grid items here
I'm sorry I'm it's hard to count while
I'm teaching here but let's make three
more
and now I think we're getting what we're
looking for so we can now get rid of the
um explicit height and width of these
items
because the grid will take care of that
so now you can see that we've got the
skeleton of this grid but let's go ahead
and start isolating things so we want to
maybe style the top row as a different
color than the main grid and the
scoreboard at the bottom so this will
evolve and change but just to kind of
demonstrate the concepts I'm going to
quickly put something in there so for
the top three we're going to hit option
in click in vs code and that should
allow us to click three things at once
we'll give these first ones a class of
turn
and then we'll come down and give these
divs here
a class of square
how many is that three six and then nine
so class equals Square
and then finally at the bottom we're
going to give these a class
oops clicking too many things at once
we'll give these a class of the score
okay so now we'll come back and instead
of grid selecting all the divs all the
grid items we'll select them based on
what they are so let's get rid of this
margin also because we will have a gap
we'll go ahead and add a gap of five
pixels to every grid item so that
everything's spaced evenly and then
instead of this we're going to say
um uh what was it turn was the top row
Square was the middle one and then score
was the bottom so we'll give these
different background colors the squares
will stay red we'll make these turn ones
green and then the score will be blue at
the bottom so we'll save that and then
if we come back now we've got all of
these highlighted a little bit
differently and if you look at the final
you can see that this matches almost
perfectly but this little
turn indicator seems to take up two full
columns and in order to get that working
we can actually do this within the child
the grid item itself we can tell it how
many columns to to span at once so we
actually have to go to the HTML
and
um highlight we we can remove one of
these div items and keep that as turn
and then this will be actions
so this will be the little drop down and
then this will be the turn indicator
so let's save that and it should be all
kind of messed up now at this point but
here in red that should be our actions
menu and if we go to the CSS
let's go actions what do we call that
actions yep and then this will be a
background color of I don't know
um
let's go purple
like that
and then finally the turn is going to
stay green but we're going to say grid
column start and that's going to be one
so we're going to start the first column
and then grid column end is going to be
three so it spans two columns wide so
once we do that we should be able to go
back and now you see this green is
taking up two full columns we've got the
actions in the top right scoreboard at
the bottom and Grid in the middle so if
you compare this right here to our final
that's pretty much what's happening we
have two spaces here actions full grid
and then scoreboard at the bottom so
this is the hardest and First Step that
you'll do when building any sort of
project like this you have to nail the
layout and then we can start you know
making it look a little bit better
arranging it on the screen
so I'm going to keep it looking just
like this and we're going to continue
this process and get it centered within
the document and then also make sure
that as we resize things you know as you
see when we resize it down to this small
device it just kind of breaks out we're
going to make sure that it resizes
appropriately now if you just take a
look at the underlying HTML that we've
got going on here let's make this a
little bit larger
you can see that we've got the main
container sitting here and then the body
container so if we wanted to Center this
main container really all we would have
to do is go to the body element itself
and I believe we can just display flex
and then justify content Center and then
align items Center and you can see how
that brings everything to the middle of
the screen so that's generally what
we're going to be doing here so if we
come back to our project and then if you
look at this original so this is the
completed version and if we go to the
CSS you'll see that on the body element
what we've done is we've displayed Flex
we've set the flex Direction column so
that it's going up and down rather than
left to right and then basically
aligning everything to the to the center
so what I'll do is I'll just copy this
snippet here
from our completed CSS and we'll bring
this to the top or right under HTML and
body and then save that and now when we
refresh you should see that it looks
very similar the last thing that we need
to do as you can see we don't have a
footer at the bottom so I've added this
little attribution at the bottom which
provides some spacing so that it pushes
this grid up a little bit so we can
quickly go add that
so if we come to the final uh the final
project here I'm just going to copy this
footer markup because it's relatively
simple doesn't really add a whole lot to
this so I'm just going to copy that
verbatim and we will put that under the
main tag so remember footer is repeated
content that if we added Pages we would
probably have that on every page so it
doesn't belong in the main content of
that page
so if we save that let's see what we are
looking like
you can see that the footer has been
added down there and that's because it
doesn't look good because we haven't
added those Styles yet
so let's go back to our completed one
and I have a section at the bottom that
has the Styles just for the footer
so let's see they're all right here so I
will copy those styles
um to our current working CSS
so let's go ahead and say footer styles
copy those in and then hopefully this
will start to look a little bit better
so now we've got the workings of our
project this is pretty much the skeleton
of things and the last thing we need to
do is make sure that it resizes
appropriately when we're on a mobile
device versus a larger desktop device
so to do that we will also go to the to
the final project here
and I'll point you to where this is
happening
you can see right here I have a media
selector and so this we've talked about
in the responsive web design uh
video that I've done in the past of the
front end series and basically what
we're doing is we're saying that we want
the grid container itself to resize a
little bit differently based on what
screen we're on so what this rule is
saying is any screen that is 768 pixels
or higher so basically like a tablet or
desktop device
we want the grid to have a width an
explicit width of 490 pixels because we
know we have enough space for that and
then we want to explicitly set the
columns and rows to be a different size
than these Originals
so right now if you were to select one
of these squares it's 80 by 80. so you
can see as we hover over that it's 80 by
80. now on a desktop device we've got
some more space so we would want that to
be 150 by 150. so let's go ahead and
copy that and paste it right under the
main grid selector
so essentially this will be the mobile
Styles and this will be the desktop
styles
so once we refresh here
we're still on a mobile device in this
scenario and it looks a lot smaller and
then yes it will cut off eventually but
really no mobile devices this small so
this is about what it would look like
and then as we resize you'll see it jump
up so let me go into responsive mode so
that we can see this a little bit better
and watch this up here you'll see as we
hit 768 right here it resizes so we have
a much bigger game to work with on these
desktop devices all right at this point
we have the bulk of the
um HTML and CSS the structure of our
project in the rest of the work that we
need to do here is primarily going to be
just details of just finessing the look
and feel of this until it matches our
final product here where you can see
we've got this drop down menu that's
going to be controlled with some
JavaScript you can see when I hover over
each Square it kind of uh gets a little
bit darker we've got a pointer cursor
you can see the mouse is a little
different depending if we're on a
clickable element or not and then of
course as we take a turn watch this up
here it will do this little animation in
where it kind of Zooms in and then
slides out so these are all just little
details that we need to add and like I
said we've done a lot of in a lot of
HTML and CSS work in Prior videos and
the main focus of this one is going to
be kind of the JavaScript side so I will
walk through over the next several
minutes of how we take this right here
and turn it into this but I will
intentionally be moving a bit quicker
than normal so be sure to just pause the
video If you see something that you know
doesn't make sense and just kind of walk
through it on your own to understand you
know what's happening here I'm just
going to be basically referencing the
original CSS document in HTML and I'm
going to be progressively building this
out I'll try to walk you through the
thought process as we go but just a
heads up it's going to be a bit quicker
than usual the first thing that I want
to tackle is this green area which is
the animated turn indicator now this is
obviously going to be controlled by
JavaScript at some point but we just
want to get the animation right so in
order to do that let me close things out
this is our working CSS document and
working HTML document from here on out I
think what I'm going to do is keep the
completed CSS here on the right as well
as the completed HTML on the right and
then we'll close that out so on the left
is our working project on the right is
the reference to the final one
um and I'll I'll try to just kind of
hide this a little bit only for
reference
okay so what we're working on is this
div right here so let's go ahead and put
some placeholder content in there just
so that you see what's going on so
there's our placeholder I'm going to go
back into a larger mode here so the
first thing that we need to do is get
this all centered get the text in there
looking good so if we come to our final
project
you'll see that we have this
turn class right here so within the turn
class we're going to have some font
awesome icons
and then a turn indicator so
we'll copy that in there and if you
notice we have these classes fa solid
and fax these are being provided by
something that we have not added to the
head of the document yet so we will need
to do that
this was taken originally from the uh
the Yvonne who submitted this project
had put this font awesome uh kit in here
so if you just copy this script over
right under the style sheet that will
add these classes so that they actually
show up within the document and give you
an icon to work with so once we've added
that script these should show up and you
can see there's the little X right there
so we know that our our icons are
working and then finally we need to just
style this so as you can see in the
original we've got the turn class on
there so we need to go down and Ctrl F
to find
uh let's see where's the turn class
here it is okay so we will copy these
styles
on over we've got some of them already
looks like we've got the
um so the background color we're going
to keep
we want to actually display this as a
flex container
um with a center alignment of the items
and a gap of 20. so that's the only
thing that we need to add and then we
need to align self-center so that's
going to tell
um the grid where to align things so
really what we have here is just some
development only background colors this
tells it how to align itself when within
the grid and then this is the
specification for how the content within
this container is going to be aligned so
if we come back over you can see that
it's now looking a little bit better and
if we were to remove this background
color now you can see that things are
looking great this is exactly the
alignment and positioning of the final
one now obviously there are different
colors going on here but we're going to
be controlling a lot of that with
JavaScript so we can move on from here
at this point just for the moment I'm
going to turn this to uh let's make it
that yellow text so we can give it a
color and then use one of our variables
and you remember we had defined a
variable of yellow here at the top under
our root so we should be able to throw
that in there and get that yellow color
right here and then we need to animate
this so in order to do that this is a
little bit more intermediate level CSS
stuff but in order to do that we need to
add some keyframes
um in an animation to animate both the
icon and the text
first though you can see that we have
some selectors for the icon in selectors
for the text so I'm going to copy those
over
right under turn so we've got the
paragraph text and then the icon text
I'm going to get rid of this animation
stuff for just a second and save that so
now you can see that we've got this
looking a lot closer to what's going on
here
and now we need to do the animation
itself so when we do an animation you
have to
first specify the animation's name
on the animation
property the CSS property and you'll
give it a duration and then some
behavior that you want it to have and
then of course the reference so for the
icon itself that's what we'll start with
this is going to
um be the animation that makes it kind
of pop in and out get a little bit
bigger and then smaller so you can see
that we have referenced turn icon
animation now this is an arbitrary value
that we have actually defined as some
keyframes so this uh selector right here
matches this the need to match because
right here you were referencing to these
keyframes and what it's saying is that
at zero percent of the duration it's
going to scale to a hundred percent and
then 25 percent into the animation it
will scale to 140 percent and then once
it's finally done it will scale back
down to a hundred percent so it kind of
pops in and then comes out and when we
save this you should be able to see that
so every time we refresh you can see
that this little icon is just popping in
and out in and out every time it reloads
so that icon is going to be complete now
the same thing applies for the text
we want that text right now all it's
doing is popping in and out and then
this right here is staying in one place
but in the final you can see what
happens is that text kind of Fades from
the left and animates out so to get that
to work
um once again we need to copy in the
animation so we find our paragraph of
the turn selector and copy that in
and right now it's going to be the same
animation time as the icon just so that
they match up same type of behavior and
then turn text animation that doesn't
exist yet we need to copy that
keyframe right here so now that we've
defined our keyframes of keyframes in
the turn text animation you can see that
we're transforming it at zero percent to
negative 20 pixels so it will kind of
pull it to the left 20 pixels and then
as the animation animates it will
translate it
to go back to its original positioning
which is where the final position we
want is so once again turn text to
animation references this key right here
so when we save it now every time we
refresh you'll see that animation is
happening really nicely so we've got
this indicator done now obviously we've
gotten X it should be an O so on and so
forth but that's going to be controlled
with JavaScript and we are not quite
there yet now the next thing that we'll
do is we'll build this actions menu now
once again this is has to be controlled
with JavaScript to toggle the open and
close Behavior but what we can do for
now is just put a placeholder in here
that is styled like this and when you
click it it won't do anything
so in order to get that we'll come back
to our original
so let's come back to our original
index.html document once again this is
the completed one and you can see that
we've called this menu and we've got
some markup within here we've got a
button this is going to actually be what
is shown and then down here this is
going to be the popover that is initial
initially hidden and then as you click
the button this is going to show and
then hide every time you click
so what we can do is just copy this
markup
and I think I've named it something
differently so yeah I gave it a name of
actions right here
but we'll update that in our CSS
so let's see this is the
drop down menu turn that into a comment
this is the turn indicator
and then this
oops
deleted that
this is going to be the game board
and then finally this will be the
scoreboard
just a little bit of organization
so what I'm going to do is actually
comment out the popover just for a
minute and work on this button so if we
save this right now it's not going to
show up very well it's just showing up
just like this and when you click it
nothing happens we have the correct icon
in here and then the correct text but
now we need to actually Center this and
style it so you can see that I've given
this a menu class which in the original
index.css we'll go find this
um
I've just given the menu class a
position of relative the reason for that
is because
um we need that popover that opens to
have a relative reference so that it
knows where to open relative to in the
Dom because it's going to have absolute
positioning
so we will put this where should we put
this here so we've got our turn stuff
let's just make a different section so
this will be the menu Styles just trying
to keep this straight for everyone here
so give that a position of relative
that's not going to do anything to it
it's still going to look the same but
then once we add the menu items so if we
go back to our markup in HTML
you can see that we should have
some items those are commented out so
we're not quite ready for that
Let's see we just need to style the menu
button right now and I'll get rid of
this just for the moment that's going to
come in later as well as this data ID I
just don't want to add anything earlier
than it applies
so the only thing we don't have styled
is this menu button so let's find that
here
there's our completed style so let's
copy that in right under menu
you can see that we want it to be a
hundred percent width and height of its
container and if you remember from this
original the container that we're
working with is what's highlighted here
so this is just one grid item so if we
say it's a hundred percent of that it's
just gonna be 150 by 50.
and then we're going to display Flex so
the items within it are going to be Flex
items and we're going to give them space
around and justify them Center
so let's go ahead and
show you what that looks like for now
so you can see that we've got this
menu item that's looking a lot better
it's got the wrong Styles but we're
getting closer
so let's come down
uncomment these and here we're going to
give it a background color I believe
this was like a one-off color that
didn't fit into the color scheme so
that's why I'm defining it here without
a variable
and then we want the text to be white
we want to give it a border and then
make that border rounded a little bit so
we'll go ahead and save that save the
HTML and now you can see that our
actions menu is looking exactly the same
as this one
now the final thing that we have to do
um we can't we don't have JavaScript
functionality to this yet but we can
still uh kind of mock out what this menu
looks like so as we click this and open
the menu we can still build this even
though we don't have JavaScript so to do
that all we need to do is uncomment this
div
and at the moment we haven't styled
these classes so it's going to look very
weird you're just going to see it right
below the actions menu
but what we want to do is make this
items class and then more importantly
it's going to be hidden initially and
then our JavaScript is going to be
what's responsible for unhiding that
so here's what I'm going to do let's go
ahead and remove well no let's keep it
as is and Define the items class
so where is that search for items
all right so here are the menu items
I've actually selected the any element
with an items class that's within an uh
element with a menu class you don't
really have to do that we could just
copy in items directly because we don't
have
any additional Styles going on there so
we've got the menu button that's always
going to show and then the items are
going to be
these items that you can click once
they're expanded so there's a couple
really important things going on here
the first thing is position absolute so
because these items are within the menu
class the absolute positioning is going
to be relative to the nearest parent
element that has a relative position on
it and as you can see we've given that
menu a relative position so these items
are going to be positioned absolutely
relative to that menu
element a little bit confusing but we've
gone over that in Prior videos in the
series that I built out
so we want to give that absolute
positioning and a z index of 10 which
means that it will sit over the grid of
items you don't want that to go behind
so the top it'll be 60 pixels offset
from the button itself
so I'll show you what that looks like
let's go ahead and
just look at those Styles right there
um actually let's let's go ahead and
take out everything except for the
absolute positioning
okay so absolute position
you can see that nothing really has
happened here quite yet now once we
uncomment the rest of this stuff
um let's go ahead and
comment that out for a second and we're
just going to give it a the actual
positioning that we want
and now you're going to see that things
are looking a little bit better now the
positioning is going to be relative to
this right here so the top left corner
so if you see the total height of this
button is 50 pixels so that's why I gave
it an offset of 60 pixels from the top
so it will offset 50 pixels from this to
get it to the bottom of the button and
then another 10 pixels to give it this
little Gap that you're seeing right here
and then of course we need to give it a
background color a rounded border radius
and some padding within the container
so you'll see now it's looking a little
bit better we still haven't styled the
buttons within it
um but then finally We'll add the Z
index we just want that there to make
sure that it's O is sitting on top of
these items now the last thing we need
to do is style the buttons in there
because they don't look very good as
you'll see here they're just they're not
super well styled or anything but they
look a little bit better so in the HTML
you can see that we've got a reset
button and a new round button
these have data IDs on them I'm going to
get rid of those because we don't need
that quite yet we're just going to style
them based on uh their parent so we're
going to look for the menu and then
items within the menu and then any
button that is within that is going to
be styled like this
so
we can actually just remove the menu
it'll still work if we
do the buttons relative to items so if
we save that now you'll see that the
buttons are looking a little bit better
although you can see we don't have any
like hover effects we want the cursor to
become a pointer so that the user knows
that they can click on them
and to do that we're just going to need
some hover Styles so if you pop that in
there we're going to underline the text
and give it a cursor pointer and now you
can see that this looks a little bit
better in that regard so as you'll see
there's no border around this button in
the final until we actually click it and
once we click it it's been focused and
everything's going to have a border so
we'll have to wait on that until we have
some JavaScript but for now you can see
that everything is being aligned
correctly
and then the last thing we need to do is
just create that hidden class because as
you can see we've got the hidden class
here and then a border class these were
shared styles that we would use across
multiple elements so I put them in
shared utility classes within the CSS
file so we'll bring this to the top
we'll put it right under the body
as shared utility classes and I'm just
going to copy these in all right now so
we don't have to come back and do this
in the future
so we'll copy those in just a hidden
class that displays none and it has
important on it just to make sure that
nothing conflicts with it then we have
some shortcuts for yellow and turquoise
you don't have to do this it's just a
little bit easier once we get into
JavaScript and then just some standard
borders and shadows that we'll be
putting on different elements so once we
add those you'll see that given these
two classes we've put on this it will
hide that menu so you can go ahead and
remove that hidden right there and it
will be showing back up with the Border
but for now we just want that hidden and
then JavaScript will unhide it for us
once we Implement that all right at this
point you can see now we've got some
conflicting Styles going on over here
we'll be sure to come back to that and
handle that with some JavaScript as well
as our actions menu that we can't really
do anything with at the moment it's not
really clickable because we need some
JavaScript to enable that so we're done
with this first kind of row now these
grid squares or game board squares these
will be relatively easy to style so
let's get in and do that real quick
so uh here's our game board and then
let's go ahead and look at the reference
um the final one
you can see that I've given each of
those a square class which dictates
their Styles and then we've put a shadow
remember we just defined those shared
utility classes and I've defined a
shared Shadow class that will apply to
everything so that's just kind of
keeping the code dry making sure we're
not repeating ourselves too much
so what I can do is now add those in so
once again I'm going to hit hold down
option and click through this within vs
code to select multiple at once
and we will add that shadow class
now furthermore we're going to want to
give
we don't need the IDS quite yet that
will come when we add some JavaScript so
let's save that and then finally we can
get rid of our background red
so wherever we put our squares
we don't want that background color
anymore we want a much nicer looking one
so you can see here are our Square
colors we wanted to span 100 the width
and height of its container which as you
can see
um this is going to be the grid item
itself so we want that to span 100 and I
don't think that is actually necessary
now that I'm looking at this because the
grid will control those so let's go
ahead and just copy this gray background
I'm going to put a little rounded border
and then we're going to make sure the
content within is a it's a flex
container so that the content is
centered within and then the font size
is going to be three Rems because we
want those icons that are sitting within
to be extra large so we'll copy that
into the square class save it and now
our board just started to look a lot
better
so you can see that we've got those
Shadows that you see on the final the
only thing that we're missing here is
when we hover over them it doesn't do
anything so it doesn't feel like to the
user that you can click
so in order to cover that we need the
hover Styles so that's what this is for
the hover style for a square we'll copy
that in we want to give it a cursor
pointer and then just a 90 opacity so
now when we hover it's going to act like
it's actually clickable for now we're
going to leave the icons kind of off of
this at the moment because that's once
again going to be controlled by
JavaScript when we actually click these
um so the last thing we have is the
scoreboard down here at the bottom this
is relatively simple markup so we'll
look at the final project and you can
see we've um just got some basic HTML a
bunch of div containers with some
paragraph text and then a little styled
scoreboard where it shows how many wins
they have so I'm going to just copy all
of this stuff verbatim it's not very
complicated you can read through it on
your own so we'll put that in the
scoreboard section
we've already implemented the shadow
class in our shared Styles and I've
added an inline style here with the
color mainly because it's just easier to
read it's easier to see that within the
HTML what color it is rather than making
a different class for each of these you
could do whatever you could add this to
the index.css but I just thought this
was a little more straightforward to
read
so once again let's get rid of the data
IDs for the moment because those are
more applicable when we get to the
JavaScript
so this is our scoreboard and the last
thing we need to do is implement the
score class because if we come over here
you can see that nothing looks very good
we've got the different colors but
they're not centering the text or
styling the text or anything like that
so we need the score class implemented
which we can go find in the final
index.css
um all right so here's the score class
we're going to replace the background
color blue
oops
we need to get rid of that
okay so we're just going to display Flex
so that each uh each box is a flex
container and we're going to give it a
top to bottom Flex Direction and we're
going to justify all the content and
align all the content to the center of
it and then we're giving it a height of
60 pixels which once again I don't think
that that was probably left over
stuff because the grid should be
dictating that and then we're going to
give it a little border radius so that
it's rounded so let's save and you can
see that things show up uh okay here the
last thing we need is this text it's
obviously not styled very well yet
compared to the final you can see that
there's a little bold Style on the title
and then the number of wins is going to
be a little bit smaller
so to do that we're going to do some sub
selectors
so the paragraph text within the score
box is going to have a font size of 14
pixels and a font weight of 600 if you
scroll to the very top where we've
imported our Google fonts
you can see that we've imported a font
weight of four five in six hundred so
that's what allows us to use that font
weight if you didn't import that then
this is not going to do anything
so just a note there and then the span
element so this is where we actually
show how many wins the person has we're
going to give it a font size of 12
pixels and a little margin on top
so we'll save that and now you can see
that everything is styled correctly so
at this point
um looking between the two we pretty
much have the same exact design going
here and we're uh for the most part
completed with this HTML and CSS portion
so let's go ahead and scroll through
this final completed one and just make
sure that we've got everything uh
matched up so we've got the footer in
here that's that's perfect uh looks like
the modal we need to still do I forgot
about that so we'll get to that and then
in the main content we've got the scores
scoreboard right there we've got all the
squares for the game board we've got the
menu implemented and then the turns
implemented and then I think pretty much
everything else is done so HTML looks
good aside from this modal and then of
course we'll add the script once we get
to the JavaScript section and then from
a CSS standpoint let's go to the top
make sure we've got everything we've got
the import correct we've got our Styles
the CSS reset Global HTML and body
styles
um
uh let's see
we added this Global style that looks
like it got
put in the wrong place so let's go ahead
and add that to our shared utility
classes
um that's not really supposed to be a
utility class but that's Global so I
forgot to add that
and then the grid we've got that done
this is the responsiveness we got all
the utility classes we added the turn
along with the animations
we added the menu
looks like we covered all of this
we got the footer okay so really we have
completed everything except for the
modal and when I say modal I'm talking
about
what happens here when someone wins the
game so you can see it pops up this uh
kind of focused element and then it puts
the game in the background makes it look
as if this is the only thing that you
can click so in order to implement that
we obviously need some JavaScript but we
can implement it with just HTML and CSS
and then we will come back to it once we
have some JavaScript available to us so
the first thing that you need to do when
you're implementing a modal is give it
the HTML markup so we will copy this
over and you can notice that I'm putting
it at the very bottom under the footer
and one could argue that this might
belong in the main content
but really this is going to be hidden
initially and it's going to be
absolutely positioned or fixed
positioning I think so it doesn't really
matter where in the document it goes it
will show up correctly
so I think one could make the argument
that it goes in Maine like I said but
let's go ahead just to stay consistent
and put it at the bottom and then since
we've got this hidden class of the you
know this will do display none let's get
rid of that for the moment just because
we want to see what it looks like
and if we go back to our project you can
see that the modal is right here it's at
the very bottom it's got this P tag and
then a button that says play again
obviously this is nowhere near what we
want we want this centered and have a
little backdrop so we've got some CSS
that we need to write
um and if you see in the final we've got
all these modal Styles so I'm going to
copy all of this over at once at the
very bottom
give it its own section and then what
I'm going to do is just comment things
out so that we can progressively see
what things are doing here
okay
so we've got everything copied in here
the first thing we need to do is Target
the container so this is the div
container with the class of modal
so what we're doing here with this modal
container is we're giving a a display
property of flex and then positioning of
fixed now fixed positioning is relative
to the entire document so what that or
the the viewport I should probably say
so if we're looking at our viewport this
entire screen here is the viewport
itself so this is going to be relative
to to the entire viewport well something
like absolute positioning is relative to
the nearest relatively displayed element
so in this case since it's a full screen
takeover we want this to be a position
of fixed we want to give it a width and
height of a hundred percent
and that will work because up here at
the top we have given the HTML and body
a height of 100 and it's automatically
going to expand the width of a hundred
percent just based on how block elements
are displayed so by giving it just this
stuff
display Flex or we don't even need that
yet position fixed with 100 height 100
let's save that and now you can see up
here it has moved so now this takeover
the modal spans the entire screen as you
can see now we want to take this content
and put it right in the middle and give
it some styles
so what we need to do is uncomment
the justify content and align items and
then also the display Flex so really we
need to bring those up
just so that not for functionality just
so you can see it all together so
display flex and now you can see it's
right in the middle and then finally if
we give it a background color it's
really going to start to pop out so this
entire modal has this dark background
color
now of course we need to style the
contents of the modal to also have a
background color and that's where the
modal contents come in so if you see in
the index.html
the container within it has a class of
modal contents
and what we want to do is just uncomment
all of this stuff so I'll quickly walk
you through what's going on
um let's see
the first thing let's get rid of that
for a moment
height with okay let's get rid of these
last ones and start with this so the
first thing we're doing is giving this
container a height of 150 pixels in a
width of a hundred percent
and then a Max width of 300 pixels so in
other words what we're saying here is
that by default we want it to be 100
width but if the screen is big enough to
wear 100 width is larger than 300 pixels
then default to that Max width this is
just a little trick that I use a lot for
mobily responsive
um or mobile first CSS and that way it
will just look good on everything so
let's go ahead and save this and then go
back and you can see our our modal
content is coming together so to display
or to show you what I mean here let's go
down to a smaller device and you can see
that that's kind of resizing
as we are on the smaller device and then
as it gets to a bigger one it's going to
stop right now it's 238 pixels but once
it reaches 300 it's going to stop
getting bigger so right there it reached
300 stops getting bigger and it stays
centered
so that's what this little trick is
doing right here now we want to display
flex and basically align everything
Center so let's get rid of these
comments and now this right here should
basically Center everything so now you
can see player one wins and play again
it's all centered so that looks good and
then finally we want to give it a flex
gap of 20 pixels so that the content
within it has some spacing we want the
content to have text color of white and
then we want the whole thing to have a
margin of 10 pixels so let me comment
that out for a second here's our spacing
white text and then you'll notice on the
mobile device once it gets too small it
pushes right up against the edge so if
we just add a margin of 10 pixels you
can see it adds that little Gap there so
that's only for mobile device then the
last thing we just need to style this
button so you can see that I've targeted
any button button within the modal
contents and just giving it a padding of
10 pixels background color of turquoise
text color of something a little darker
than that and then some rounded borders
so if we save that you can see that the
button now has these nice Styles so our
modal is complete and if we just give it
that hidden class back so if we put
hidden on there it's going to be
completely gone and then we comment that
out
and it's back so you can see how our
JavaScript is basically going to take
that hidden class and it's going to
remove it add it back remove it add it
back based on when someone wins the game
and then the play again button will also
trigger a JavaScript action
all right so I know I said that I was
going to kind of gloss over a lot of the
HTML and CSS which I sort of did we did
a lot of copy pasting but hopefully that
was a good blend of you know how did we
get to this final state but not typing
every last little letter
so if you just toggle between the final
one final game right here and our
current game everything looks pretty
much the same so HTML CSS that's done
but obviously when you click anything on
this board nothing is going to happen
because we haven't hooked up JavaScript
which is going to actually control the
game
um so we want to be able to you know
make plays and reset the game and do
things like that
so at this point I would recommend if
you're watching this video to take a
little break
um because we're going to switch from uh
HTML and CSS mode to JavaScript mode
which requires a little bit different
type of thinking
so we're in the JavaScript section but
something that happened to me when I was
first starting out is I would always
just be asking this simple question of
when we're looking at JavaScript where
do you even start like what's the first
thing that you think about when you're
trying to connect up some JavaScript
functionality to a static HTML and CSS
application
so looking at this we can click stuff
but it's not going to do anything and so
the question is where do we even start
thinking about adding this these event
listeners and you know all the different
State Management that happens to make
this game work
so in asking this question I think the
next question that we need to ask is
what actions can a user take in my app
so we're building a game and there's
really three actions that a user can
take let's go back and look at the
finished game this is the the refactor
that I've done that's actually working
and if we
let's reset everything new round get
everything cleared out
and the first action that a user can
take is they can click on one of these
squares on the game board
so this is just you know a Player move
that is happening
so that is the first thing that we need
to jot down a player can make a game
move
now the second thing that they can do
once someone actually wins the game so
player one wins we play again and you
can see down here player one has one win
zero ties player two has zero wins
so the next action that they can do is
hit new round and that's going to clear
out this scoreboard down here at the
bottom
so we can say clear or actually new
round
and then finally the last thing that
they can do is if they started a game
and just want to reset it you can go to
the reset button and that will clear
things out and it won't touch the
scoreboard
so we can make a new round or reset the
current gain so I think with any
application any you know front-end
project like this that we do this is a
great first question to ask yourself
just so that you can get a better
understanding of these requirements now
of course once we have this question
answered you obviously have to start
writing code to make this happen within
your static HTML and CSS
so there's a lot of different ways to
approach that and ultimately where we're
headed by the end of this video is to
have some sort of model view controller
pattern that's going to help us organize
our code to make this stuff happen and
handle these events correctly so model
view controller is just a pretty common
architectural pattern that's commonly
used for developing user interfaces
so this is actually me from the future I
was editing this video and realizing
that I had created I had created this
diagram to kind of give an overview of
the MVC pattern and I didn't actually go
through it so this is the MVC pattern
model view controller and I wanted to
just walk through kind of the the flow
of this
so as we're building our application
there's three separate concerns
basically we have the view which as
you'll see this is um event listeners
that handle either UI only events so
like toggling a menu
as we'll see here just toggling this
actions menu
or we can manipulate the Dom and respond
to State changes and what happens is the
store over here is kind of the the model
and this is responsible for getting
State and saving State and emitting
State change events and this app in the
middle is the controller and this is
responsible for kind of orchestrating
between State and the view and making
sure that you know State updates and the
view updates all in one concise
Consolidated place so I know this
probably doesn't make a whole lot of
sense so I'll stop here but just keep
this in mind come back to it as we go
through this build and hopefully this
gives you a little visual representation
of this pattern we're using now this is
going to be a very challenging pattern
to implement straight off you know right
off the bat and it's not going to make a
whole lot of sense so what I've decided
to do is almost a contrived example
where we basically start with a more
naive approach where everything kind of
sits in one file and we don't have
really any architectural patterns behind
this and we're going to progressively
iterate on that and get to that MVC
pattern that's a little bit more stable
so we'll call this the video progression
we're going to start with you know a
naive approach all in one file
then we're going to refactor and iterate
as we go
and then finally we're going to end up
with MVC pattern that is
and this is very important it is going
to be easy or easier to debug later
and it's going to be
easier to extend and add features to
later
now these are really important parts of
building software because anytime you're
building software you're going to have
users that expect things to be improved
and fixed and extended you want to add
more features so for example in our
basic tic-tac-toe game you might want to
add some leaderboard over here to the
left side or the right side and you
might want to be able to add user logins
and you know registration and whatnot
and being able to do that is going to be
very difficult if we haven't planned out
a little bit of architecture in a little
bit of software design behind what we're
doing
in other words everything in one file is
going to quickly become unmanageable
with that said I think we can go ahead
and get started now just thinking about
this a little bit
um
let's enter this down so we got some
more room
what actions can a user take in my app
we've defined these and what I want to
kind of point out is that these pretty
directly oops did not mean to do that
these pretty directly map to event
listeners on HTML elements so in each
case when we look at this
we have individual elements so reset is
going to be some sort of button new
round is going to be a button and then
each of these squares on the game board
are going to be like a button or a div
or something like that
in every HTML element has event
listeners that you can hook up and then
when that event happens you'll put in
some JavaScript logic that will maybe
manipulate the Dom and update some sort
of persistent state in local storage or
session storage so on and so forth all
right so I think that's enough planning
for the moment we're going to kind of
come back to this whiteboard a little
bit to to plan out some more features in
the as we build this out but I want to
get started just to kind of jump in so
if we're looking at our HTML document we
have to ask the question how are we
going to add JavaScript to this
well theoretically you can put
Javascript pretty much anywhere in this
document but you will always see a best
practice of putting that JavaScript at
the end of the body tag in almost all
cases and the reason for that is because
when we are loading an HTML document in
a browser the browser has a bunch of
code that's running in the background
that actually has to read through this
HTML document and parse it and parse all
of the elements there and all the Styles
attaching those to the elements and it
has to actually paint that to the screen
now this is called the critical
rendering path and I would say this is a
more intermediate to Advanced concept
that you can kind of check out on your
own
but the point of this is to say that
when we load this HTML document in the
browser it's actually going to make a
network request to get the document you
can see that over in the network tab
you'll see this first 200 get request
let's make this a little bit larger this
is the initiator is the document and
it's a type HTML and when we click this
it's going to render the HTML here but
if we look at the raw response that
we're getting this is the HTML document
that has been sent over to the browser
and the browser has to go through and
parse that now why is this significant
well the reason being is if we have
JavaScript that happens or is placed
here at the top of the body what that
means is that before the browser can
parse any of the HTML and show that to
the user they have to run all of that
JavaScript that is sitting there at the
top of the body and if you've got a
large enough JavaScript bundle
that's going to block things and the
user's not going to see anything in the
browser until that's done so that's just
a poor user experience and that's the
reason that we'll generally put a script
tag at the bottom of the body
so once we've got the script tag here
we can run arbitrary JavaScript in it so
we can say hello world and save that and
then our live server is going to reload
go to the console and you'll see Hello
World and just a side note you'll see
this get request that's airing out on
the favicon we don't even have this in
our HTML document the browser just by
default is going to look for this
because it's kind of a standard so we
can safely ignore that but anyways you
can see we've got JavaScript running but
obviously we don't want to do all of our
JavaScript inline here because we're
going to have to write enough of it to
where this will get pretty cumbersome so
ideally what we need to do is make a
script that has a source tag and that
Source tag is going to point to a
Javascript file that we're going to add
to our directory so we'll come over here
to the live vanilla build add a new
folder called Js
it could be anywhere but we can put this
in and we'll call it app.js you can call
it whatever you want main.js index.js
any of those work
so here let's go ahead and put our
console.log
hello
world
save that and at the moment it's not
going to do anything if we refresh
well I guess we haven't saved the HTML
yet so let's save that
refresh and you're not going to see
anything you'll just see the source
attribute of script is empty and that's
because we need to populate that with a
path to our app.js Javascript file so
once we save this you should see
everything's hooked up we get Hello
World in the browser and we have our
basic Javascript file so at this point
now that we've got a basic Javascript
file set up I want to go ahead and start
on these user actions that can happen so
remember we've got these three user
actions and there's actually a fourth
one that we are going to start with
because it's probably the simplest
implementation and that one is toggle
the menu so this new round and reset
current game these are part of the menu
but we actually have to implement that
so that this menu pops open and closes
every time it's clicked and that can't
happen with just HTML and CSS at least
without something crazy going on so
that's the first thing that I want to do
because it's rather simple to implement
and then we'll start working on those
user actions and how do we track the
state of the game
so the first thing that we're going to
do is kind of scaffold out our actions
and to do that we need to identify the
elements that we are going to select
so I'll show you a better way to do this
in a couple of minutes but we're going
to start with kind of as I said the
naive approach of what you might think
to do first
so if we're looking for that menu
you're going to come to the drop down
menu section of our HTML and you'll see
that we've got a div with the class of
menu so probably the easiest way to
select this element with JavaScript is
going to be let's call it menu and we're
going to select the document which
should be globally available to us in
the browser runtime so that should be
available
and you can see vs code has already kind
of detected that this is available to us
so it's giving us all this auto complete
stuff of the browser apis
so we can say
document.queryselector and we can select
by a class and select any element that
has the menu class which we know just to
be one div element now from this menu
what we can do is add an event listener
and we want to listen for the click
event and then on that callback we're
going to get an event object which has a
Target which represents this element
right here so if we were to console.log
event dot Target
we should see when that is clicked in
the user interface we're going to see
the element itself printed to the
console and you can see that we've got
the button and if you open this up
you'll see all of these different
attributes and these are all the things
that we can read off of this element
Target now to get this to actually
toggle down that menu if you remember
from our HTML all we needed to do here
is go down I'm sorry not there
right here
this is the menu items and you can see
that we've put a hidden class on there
so if we were to go back to the browser
and select this element and go find that
div that is hidden and then we can
uncheck this hidden
CSS class you'll see that well this
actually shows the modal because we're
sharing this hidden class with that
modal as well so let me refresh and just
remove that class for a moment and
you'll see that now by default it is
showing so really all we need to do with
JavaScript is toggle that class on and
off every time that button is clicked so
this is the class we're targeting
but in order to do that we need the
ability to select this item so that we
can manipulate it so there's multiple
ways that we can do this but you can see
we've already selected this div element
that has a class of menu so we've
already got that context within
JavaScript in the menu variable
now we can use that and select any div
that has the items class within it so a
simple way to do this is to say menu
items and we can say menu dot query
selector
and then look for the items class and
from there we can then manipulate that
so when we see that the button on the
menu has been clicked we can come down
and say menu items
and we can say class list and then we
have this method available called toggle
and we can pass in a class of hidden and
that's going to toggle the hidden class
back and forth every time the button is
clicked
so let's see if that works we click this
click it again click it again and you
can see over here on the right that
hidden class is just being added and
removed each time
so the question is how did I know to do
that that's always a good good question
to ask and let's go ahead and go to mdn
which is our favorite documentation for
the web and what are we going to search
we want to look for class
let's start with element
so element is a base class it's the most
General base class from which all
element objects in document inherit in
other words what that's saying is when
we do a query selector and get an
element back then all of those are going
to have are going to inherit the
instance properties in instance methods
of the element and if you look at
instance properties you'll see that we
have a class list available to us and
from that class list if you look at the
value you can see that we have a toggle
method so the toggle method of Dom token
list removes an existing token from the
list and returns false if the token
doesn't exist it's added and the
function returns true so that's how I
would go to find that this is available
to us and that's how I knew that we had
a class list on the menu items which
basically is going to map to this right
here that's what we're dealing with in
JavaScript and then the toggle method is
just a convenience method that allows us
to add and remove this class or whatever
class we pass in as an argument
so just with a couple lines of code we
now have some functionality in our
application we can toggle this actions
menu now of course we can't click we
can't click the new round to reset and
expect it to do anything because we
haven't set click listeners on those yet
but what we do know is that we can
toggle it now there's already something
wrong here and there's nothing terribly
wrong but I'm going to start making a
list over here if we can remember where
this is
we'll say let's zoom in a little bit
make this a better font
so best practices when
developing user interfaces
all right so the first one that we're
going to talk about here is global scope
and namespaces
so if we go back to our application
there's something that's a little bit
wrong here and could cause you problems
in the future if your app gets bigger
and you start splitting this across
multiple script files and using similar
variables so let's say that we went
ahead and added another script to our
index.html so let's copy this down we'll
say second app.js
and over here we're going to add a new
file called second app.js that will
delete in just a minute
and I'm going to Define a variable
called menu and this is just going to be
some object some JavaScript object
Okay so we've got in our second app.js a
variable called menu in our in our first
app.js we also have menu but they
represent two different values so the
question becomes which one's going to
win which one's going to take precedent
or precedence so let's go in here and
click our button again and it seems to
be working okay so let's go back here
and flip the order of these scripts and
save it now let's click here and this is
no longer working and the reason being
is because we have a redeclaration of
the menu variable and so it no longer
knows what to do because we're trying to
set an event listener on a constant
object variable because they're
conflicting so as you can see this is
already a bit of a problem and the
problem here is not that we're defining
two variables of the same name that's
totally acceptable within you know
programming it's the fact that we're
declaring the same name in the same
scope furthermore we're putting it all
in the global scope so believe it or not
if we would go to this console here and
type menu
you can see that that value is an empty
object and then if we type menu items
let's see menu items will be undefined
because we're deriving That Base Time
menu but let's go ahead and flip this
script
um oops
okay so we're flipping them in the
different order so now this menu will
work okay and if we type menu it's now
back to that element and menu items is
going to be another element so you can
see that these are available in the
global scope which is usually not a
great idea so something that your o is
going to want to do when you're
developing applications is make it into
a namespace
so when I say namespace all I'm
referring to is a one variable that a
single name that we can Encompass and
store
basically put a closure over all of our
other variables so that it's not going
to expose all these different variable
names in the global scope so a way that
we can do that is just defining a
variable called app and this will just
be a basic object to start with
and within this app we're going to store
some of our selected items and then
we're also going to add an
initialization method
so the first thing we'll do let's get
these the menu and menu items on this
within this namespace and something
that's really nice to do is put a prefix
in front of that so we'll just put a
dollar sign that's a pretty standard
convention that people would use and so
this will be a property of this
namespace and this is where we're going
to put
all of our selected HTML elements okay
so right here we're going to call it
menu and we can say
document.queryselector looking for the
menu class and then we will also put
menu items but now we no longer can
derive this based on menu because at
this point in the initialization of this
object we don't have menu available to
us now you could try to do something
like app.menu in reference or sorry app
dot dollar sign
dot menu and then query selector and
then look for items so you could try
that but if we save that and go to the
document here it's going to say unclot
reference error can't access lexical
declaration app before initialization so
in other words we can't reference it
here because it hasn't initialized yet
so a quick solution to that is to just
replace this instead of deriving it
based on that element we'll just look
for it in the document there's only one
element with a class of items so that
should not conflict with anything
so we've got our selected elements we're
looking a lot better here and now if we
go back and let's go back down in our
index.html and flip the order to where
it was broken before and now if we
refresh
um it's going to say menu is not defined
where did we what are we doing here
oh I'm sorry that's because the event
listener is no longer going to work so
let's comment that out for just a second
and things should work now you're not
going to get any namespace errors this
menu is not going to conflict with this
menu because this is uh has a closure
over it with app as the namespace so
let's get rid of second app that was
just for demonstration we'll delete that
and then in the HTML we can delete that
reference so we're back to where we
started
and now what you'll see is if we go to
try to access the menu variable it's not
going to be available so I guess there's
a built-in called menu bar but menu is
not available but if we go to app
dot dollar sign dot menu that is how we
could access that element that we've
selected so now all we have is a single
namespace called app and theoretically
we could Define that same variable in a
different file and it would conflict but
it's much less likely and much easier to
track all the variables we're defining
when we only have one namespace that's
covering everything else that we're
defining so the next thing that we'll do
to make this a little bit better we
could of course uncomment this down here
and say app dot dollar sign
dot menu dot add event listener and save
that and then we come here and it's
going to say menu items is not defined
I'm sorry because I have to reference
app.dollarsign dot menu items as well
and we're going to toggle this and it'll
work just fine now there's one
Improvement we can make because right
here we're doing this in the global
scope so a better way to do this is to
make an init method within our app
namespace
so the init method is going to be where
we're going to add event listeners to
our application and just to note this is
es6 syntax this is just a shorthand way
to define a function property on an
object that we're calling app
so another way to do this would just be
a property and then you could add like
an anonymous function just like that or
you could do an anonymous function like
that so on and so forth you could even
Define a function up here and assign it
there but this is just a quick way to do
that shorthand and then what we're going
to do is move this initialization logic
into that method right here and what
that does for us is now it allows us to
control when our app is initialized and
what we can do here is if we save this
this is no longer going to work because
we haven't initialized our app but a
nice way to do this is say document dot
add event listener and we'll wait for
the document to fully load and you can
see in the documentation vs code
populates
um
actually this is not for the load event
but this is basically waiting for the
entire document to load so we know
things are safe to use and select and
then from here we can have a callback
function that we'll call app.anit so
another way of doing that we could call
it like this so app dot init and save it
and if we do this it's not going to work
and I believe the reason is this should
be window instead of document
so let's try that looks like it works
let's go ahead and look at the reference
here so mdn document
so we can look at the
um
document here and then let's look at the
events reference
so listen to these events using add
event listener on the document and it
looks like the load event is not
available there
but if we look at the window if we can
find that so let's look at window
and then events here and this is where
we're going to find the loaded event I
believe
and you can see here in the load in
unload events reference here's the load
event we're listening to and that's
fired when the whole page has loaded
including all dependent resources
such as stylesheet images
in other words this happens when all the
HTML is in the document and we can start
selecting it safely
so that's why we're listening on the
window here and basically we're just
listening for the load and then we're
initializing our application which will
select these elements and add that click
listener to our menu now a shorthand way
to refactor this rather than this syntax
we can just remove this and remove the
call and that's a more concise way to
write that and we'll have the same exact
functionality just like this all right
so we have a basic toggle menu that's
working but the next thing that we need
to do is kind of start on this game and
and working on the state of tracking the
different moves that a player can do
so let's first scaffold out kind of the
events that we're going to have to
listen to and the elements that we're
going to have to select
and then we will come back and fill in
that logic with an actual implementation
so as you know init is where we're going
to register all of these event listeners
to handle these
um user events so what we can do is
first Define the elements that we are
going to trigger those events on so
let's go back to the game and the first
two are pretty easy we need to Target
the reset button in the new round button
so one way that we could do that you can
see that we've got two buttons reset in
new round
so
there's no selectors on either of these
buttons so what you could do is just add
a class but one thing that I'm going to
show you here to refactor and we're
going to do this as we go is add a data
ID so this is a much more stable way to
select elements when you're querying
them in the Dom
so if you go to mdn and type data dash
star
you will see this attribute which is
global attributes form a class of
attributes called custom data attributes
this allows you to add proprietary
information to be exchanged between HTML
and its Dom representation in other
words we can give data ID or data
whatever we want to Define and that's
going to allow us to have a stable
selector so
let's come back
first to Excalibur uh Excalibur here
so we've got Global scope and namespaces
and now let's talk about stable
selectors
data
star attributes
okay so what do I mean by that if we go
to index.html
you know we could select these buttons
indirectly by looking for the menu div
and then looking for items and then
getting the index of the button to
select which one we want but a more
stable way to do this let's start with
menu up here is to just add a data ID
and we're going to call this menu
so let's save this document and go back
to app.js and update our query selector
here for menu so instead of selecting
the class we're going to select
something we'll put some brackets which
says we're selecting an attribute called
Data Dash ID and that will be equal to
menu so let's save that and see if
things are working okay in our app and
it looks like they are we're allowed to
select that and let's break it on
purpose so take out that U just to break
things and now it's going to say
uncaught type air app dot menu is null
so you know that this is working
and we could also call this whatever we
wanted so
data custom selector just to demonstrate
and you could update this to say custom
selector and that's going to work just
fine we'll still have that being
selected appropriately so data ID is
just a convention that Avo has used and
I think it's a good succinct one that
you can use as well so we're going to
put a data ID on each of these elements
that we want to select and the main
reason for doing this is to have
stability so if you changed the name of
this class for menu or if you rearranged
the HTML elements in the future you
don't want all of your JavaScript to all
of a sudden break because you changed a
style element of your document you don't
want to couple those two pieces together
and so this is a way to keep things a
lot more stable
so we'll come down here and add a data
ID for this of menu items
and then we'll add a data ID for this
reset button
same thing here oops
new round button okay so now we have
selectors that are a lot more stable for
all those and we're going to register
them here
so we need two more we need
a reset button
in the new round button
and we're going to just copy these query
selectors so we don't have to rewrite
that every time
and then we'll replace this with menu
Dash items is what we named it this one
we called it reset button and this one
was new round button so if we got that
right we should have all of these being
selected and we should see no errors
within the document and you don't see
any errors other than this one we know
about and this is working fine so this
has been updated correctly at this point
it should be relatively simple to add
the rest of our actions here
so we've already got the event listener
for the menu toggling now we're going to
select the reset button and add an event
listener
we want to wait for a click on that
and then open up a callback function
that receives the event
and we'll just say
reset the game
that'll be our placeholder for now
we can just copy this down almost do it
verbatim instead of reset button it will
be new round button
and we'll say
add a new round
so we've registered those click
listeners and now if we open up the
actions it'll toggle if we hit reset it
will reset the game and if we hit new
round it will add a new round so we've
got these hooked up okay and then the
last thing that we need to do is
register a click listener on each of
these squares now there's a better way
to do this than what I'm about to show
you but the way that I'm about to show
you is probably the most intuitive in
the simplest way to do it so what we
will do is let's look at the index.html
and find these game board squares that
we're trying to select
so the quickest way to do to do this is
look let's go ahead and add a data ID
and I believe we can duplicate these
data IDs so let's just call it square
and then we'll add that for all of these
properties here so I'll hold down option
and just click in vs code you can
highlight a bunch at once
and then we'll add data Dash ID equal to
Square
okay so now we have a stable selector on
all of these and what we can do here
in our selectors
is say let's say squares
and we'll say document but instead of
query selector we're going to do query
selector all so we want all of the
elements that have a data ID
of the square
and if we go to the init method and just
console.log app dot dollar sign dot
squares
and look at that in the Dom you can see
that we have the node a node list which
has all nine of those squares
represented here now the last thing we
don't have a unique ID on each of these
we of course have an index to our array
but it would be nice if we just had an
ID so that we had kind of a coordinate
to map this to
so one way we can do that is to just
click here and go down to each of these
and give it
a basic HTML ID property or attribute
okay so I'll start every all of them
with one and then we'll just go down and
replace all these
so now when we select these the node
list is going to have an ID on each of
them so we know when they're clicked
which ID that we're dealing with
so going back we can add an event
listener to all of these but since it's
a node list we need to iterate through
them so we can say app.dollarsine dot
squares and then we'll just do a four
each so for each Square this should be a
node in the Dom so we should be able to
say Square dot add event listener
and then add a click listener and then
the event that is returned from there
should give us an ID so let's go ahead
and console log
square with ID and then we'll
interpolate event dot Target dot ID
was clicked so we can remove this
console log and now what we would expect
is every time we click them we will get
the ID back of the square that was
clicked so this one should be square id1
this should be nine so we're going one
two three four five six seven eight nine
so let's click one
and you can see square with id1 was
clicked go down here square with id9 was
clicked so that's a pretty simple way to
register an event listener there for
each of those squares so now going back
to our initial question that we had
asked
let's go over to what actions can the
user take in the app we came up with
four of them a player can make a game
move new round reset current game and
toggle menu and if we now look at our
init method we have four events that are
being listened to on different Dom
elements
so one organization method that we can
use instead of putting this all in the
init method we'll leave the init method
there and Define a new one and let's
just call this register uh
register events or event listeners or
something like that
and this is just going to be an
organizational uh technique here where
we can just put all of that same type of
functionality
within that method and then we'll keep
the init method pretty clean so all
we'll say is app.register event
listeners
so now what's happening is when the
window loads the document we're going to
call init and a knit is going to
register all of those event listeners
for us and if we go back to our app we
should be able to toggle this reset the
game
new round and then click any of these
squares and get an ID returned from the
squares so at this point we have a
template for our application and we've
stubbed out some methods that we're
going to need to implement so as you can
see here we basically we've got this one
done
this is toggling the menu so we'll call
that done I'll just add some comments
here so we can track this one is going
to be a to do item
because we have not implemented what
happens when we reset the game or add a
new round
and then this bottom one is also to do
um but this is probably what we're going
to work on next but speaking of what to
work on next that is a really good
question as you're building an app like
this how do you know what comes next
well in this case we can kind of go
through the process of elimination with
these actions reset and new round those
are not going to be possible to
implement until we have a functioning
tic-tac-toe game that we can actually
reset
so let's go back to our notes here and I
want to take a minute to go off of this
point here
let me get my arrows worked out here not
super familiar with how to use this
quite yet
so we're going off of this point of
player can make a game move so the next
question we've got to ask is what is a
game move well there's a couple
considerations that we'll have to think
about here
one being how do we determine who is up
who is the player that is up next so let
me add that as a requirement here
um who is currently up
the next thing we want to know is did
the latest move cause a tie or a game
win
and then we also want to know
who won or was it a tie
and then what else can we think about
here let's go to our final refactor the
one that's actually working here up here
this is our question of whose turn is it
we need to know that so we can display
that we also need to know that so we
know which icon to display when it's
clicked and then as you see we have a
modal that pop up pops up when someone
actually wins the game so we need to
know when that happens and then at that
point when we click play again we need
to be able to reset all of the state to
a blank fresh game so those are the main
questions that we have to ask
um so who is currently up this is for
the turn
indicator icon to play
um and I think that's pretty much it so
we'll take these step by step because
um it's kind of tough to think through
all of this at once
as you get more advanced in building
these things you can probably map all
this stuff out from the beginning and
that's kind of my first step when I'm
building this is trying to map out what
does the state of this application
require and what do I need to track
um one thing I'll add here is also the
question of what state do I need to
track
so we'll talk about this concept a
little bit here in a minute but I'm
going to kind of organically talk about
this throughout the rest of the video
because it's quite challenging at times
if you're not super familiar so when I
say state I'm really just talking about
you know what does the current state of
the game look like so that might be
things like
um current player might be total wins by
player
we can also track total type here total
ties and then prior game history those
kind of things are the things that we'll
want to track and to do that we're going
to just build this you know step by step
and we'll eventually come to some sort
of model that we'll use to track that
state so not going to talk too much
about that at the moment let's dive in
and start building this out and you'll
start to see how this makes more sense
in a minute
so the first thing that I'm going to do
is try to implement a basic move so in
other words I want to display an icon in
these squares when they're clicked we're
obviously already registering event and
getting the ID of the square that was
clicked so that is useful to us but we
need to change the Dom or the UI when
that happens
and to do that the first thing I will
generally do is go to the HTML and just
mock something up so just figure out how
to statically display that for the first
time
so I believe all we're going to need to
do is put in an I tag with a class
and then that's going to be one of our
font awesome icons so let me just check
my references right here to see which
icon we're dealing with
okay so it really should just be fa
solid is the base class and then it's
going to be fax or FAO so we'll uh
simulate both of those here just to make
sure that our game board is going to
display things correctly
so fax and FAO
and you can see that we've got those
displaying correctly so this is the
right size obviously these are not the
right colors
if we were to open up our CSS if you
remember from earlier in the video we
had some of these shared classes here at
the top somewhere and in these shared
utility classes I gave us a yellow and a
turquoise class just so that things are
a little bit easier to deal with and
easier to remember so what we can do is
just pass in yellow
and then turquoise
into that class list and then our X's
and O's will be the right color now
obviously you can see we've got
mismatches just about everywhere we'll
get that worked out in just a moment
so if we're trying to do this with
JavaScript obviously we can't just
statically put in these different icons
we're going to basically build these
elements and add them as children to the
appropriate div that has been clicked so
what I'm going to do is open up app.js
again
and right down here in our event
listeners for each of the squares I'm
going to just copy over this HTML and
add it as a comment and that's just for
reference so that we can look at it and
translate it into JavaScript
so we've got fax and then FAO
these are the two that we're dealing
with
so we can get rid of those here in the
HTML
and then in app.js we know which ID was
clicked and the event itself carries a
Target which represents the individual
square that was clicked so what we could
do just to start us out
is actually derive that or not derived
but create this I tag so let's call it
an icon and we can say
document.create element is one of the
built-in browser API or Dom methods and
we just need to give that a tag of I
so we've created the element and then we
can say icon I'm sorry not redefining it
we can say icon.class list and then I
believe we can just
um add an array of tokens and what that
would be the classes themselves
so we would want to add f a solid
f a x and then let's say yellow so we're
just kind of hard coding an element
we'll hard code a yellow X in this case
and then from here we've created the
element but we need to insert it into
the Target that was clicked so really
what we could do is just say
event.target dot replace children
and then I think we can just pass in the
icon so that should work let's go ahead
and click
and you can see something's going on
it's not working so let's inspect
you can see there's some sort of content
in these div elements
and it looks like our icon class or icon
element has been added but the class
list has commas
so we need to not do it that way we're
not supposed to pass an array I guess
maybe we're just supposed to pass
um multiple arguments let's try that
okay so that's working better and now
you can see that the
content within here or where did we go
the content within the one we clicked
has the correct class list now so now
anytime we click any of these we're
going to get a yellow X
and obviously this is not useful yet
we're just filling them up with x's and
if we click them twice we also can have
problematic Behavior because
we're not checking to see if there's an
X already there we're just adding it no
matter what so that is problematic but
at least we've got something working
here
so ideally what we want to do is know
whose turn it is and then depending on
that turn we'll choose either fax or FAO
and then the yellow or turquoise color
and at this point we've finally reached
a place where we can start talking about
what state is and what state management
really represents here for us
so to do that I'm going to pop over to
the Whiteboard again and we're talking
about game moves and what state do I
need to track well I think the next
question really is
what is state
well there's really two types of state
that we can talk about so we have client
State and then we have server State and
these are very loose terms so there's a
little bit of an overlap between the two
but these are the two kind of
categorizations that I would be using so
when we're talking about client state
the way that I think about that is any
sort of
um
uh state that we have within the Dom
that does not need to change anything
that is persisted long term so I guess
that's a complicated way of saying
something like this actions menu popping
open and closed every time we open and
close this the client-side state is
changing
but we're not actually doing anything
you know to persist that change so if we
opened this actions menu up and then
refreshed the page it's going to close
every time because we're not tracking
that state across browser refreshes it's
just temporary in-memory state that
we're tracking so in other words client
state
a good example of that let's just
make an example over here
let's add some code here so let's say
client state
equal to and make this a hopefully was
going to get that a little smaller but
let's open up some brackets
so client State might be something like
is menu open and we'll start that with
false and so as you can see when we
click this menu that state variable is
going to update it's going to be either
open or closed true or false and that's
not going to persist across browser
refreshes now server State and server
again is kind of a loose term here
because we don't actually have a server
we're going to be working with local
storage to kind of emulate that but
generally server state is kind of what
you would think of as a database so it's
a snapshot in time it's a snapshot of
what the current data looks like
so this would be more conducive to
something like a game move so we could
copy this down
foreign
State could be something like a current
player
and let's just put an ID in there let's
say player one is the current player and
then we could also add things like we've
got the current player how about the
history of games so we might have an
array filled with all the different
games that we had played in the past
we could also track things like
um we can also track things like the
current game so this might be an array
of game moves that have happened and
that way we can track across browser
refreshes you know who has moved in
which Square
so these two types of State we're going
to need to track and we're going to
eventually refactor this to be a little
bit more stable but as I said in our
kind of game plan over here in this
video progression we're doing everything
in one file as a naive approach and then
we're going to refactor it to be a
little bit more stable so what that
looks like for us in terms of state I'm
just going to create a state property on
the app
okay and to start out state is not going
to be persistent across browser
refreshes because this is just a
variable and every time we refresh this
is going to be re-initialized and
reassigned so the first piece of state
that we want to track is current
player and for now I'm just going to
keep things very simple and we're going
to say that each player is represented
by a number it's going to be either one
or two so we'll say that player one is
going to always start the game so we'll
track the current player and that alone
will allow us to decide down here in our
event listener which icon that we need
to put in the Square
so obviously we need to update that
state each time a move happens so if we
were to
um
we'll leave this console log here but
every time something is clicked what
we're going to need to do is say the
current player is going to be equal to
app.state.current player now you don't
need to save that to a variable I'm just
doing that to kind of be a little more
clear here
and then we're going to say if the
current player equals one
we're going to add a certain element to
the Dom otherwise we'll just assume
there's only two players here we'll add
a different one so in this case let's
just say that player one is going to be
a yellow X so we can create the icon no
matter what because
it doesn't matter that's not styled at
all but the class list is what we're
going to use based on the player so if
it's player one we're going to have a
yellow X and if it's player 2 we're
going to have a turquoise o
so we'll put in turquoise right there
but the thing is we need to of course
update that state every time this move
happens so we'll go ahead and create
this icon add the class list and then
what we're going to do here is say app
dot state DOT currentplayer
is going to be set equal to whoever is
not playing this move so in other words
if let's say the current player is one
and has created you know this class list
so we're going to say if the app dot
state that current player equals one
then we're going to set the current
player equal to two otherwise we're
going to set it equal to one so in other
words it's sort of just a toggle on
who's playing the game and then finally
we'll take the event Target which is the
square and replace the contents of that
square with the appropriate icon and so
next time this is clicked we'll know
which player to use so I'm going to also
log this up top
we'll say the current player is and then
we'll say
app.state.current player so we can get
rid of these down here
and then there's one more important
thing as you saw earlier we can't play
in a square twice so we need to know if
the square already has some sort of
element within it let's go ahead and
just save this and see what we're
dealing with now in our game
so we'll click a square and then the
next one should be an o
and it is and that's because we've
updated the state every time we see a
new play now I think if I'm not mistaken
what's going to happen if we click this
twice
so let's say that we click this Square
again it's going to add an X to next to
the O which is obviously invalid and now
it's going to think that the O's turn is
up even though X should still be up
because they played in the wrong spot so
that's obviously a problem and the way
that we fix that is basically putting a
check within this click event and we're
just going to say is there something in
that square and if so we're going to
return early and we're not going to
allow the player to actually play
and this will prevent us from updating
the current player in state and it will
force them to replay before the next
player can go so the question is how do
we check that well we're going to
eventually do this to be
um we're going to eventually check this
in a much more stable way but for now
I'm just going to keep things simple
we're going to go to mdn and go back to
the element reference
so elements reference
oops I clicked the wrong one I just want
literally the element class
so which one is that
I think this will work so we've got
element.get attribute now we can look
through all of the different methods
that are available on
an element and there should be one to
check if there are children already
within that element I'm not finding it
here so I'm just going to search what I
know here has child nodes and we're not
finding it on element because it exists
on the base class of node
this is like the abstract Base Class pun
which many other Dom API objects are
based so basically any element as it
mentions here will inherit all the
methods of node
so we can use this has child nodes
method and this returns a Boolean value
indicating whether the given node has
child nodes or not
in other words what we can do here is
the first thing we do is say if
event.target dot has child nodes
so if there's any X or o in there we're
just going to return we're not going to
update anything we're not going to
update the state we'll just return from
that function early so by adding that I
believe we should get the desired
Behavior here so we'll click one click
two and then try to click this one again
and it's not working let's see why so I
had to pause the video to figure out
what was going wrong here and it's a
little bit tricky bad programming on my
part but basically what happened here
is when we clicked on the icon itself
you can see if I like specifically click
on one of these icons it's going to
continue adding icons now if I click
somewhere else in the Square it's going
to have the correct behavior and what's
actually happening here
is the event Target so right here is
going to represent what was actually
clicked so the element that was actually
clicked in the Dom now the square up
here is going to represent the square
that we're actually looking to Target
for this Behavior
so if I were to
console log this
let's go ahead and say
um console log
we'll say the square
and then we'll pass in the Square itself
and then we'll console log the event
Target
and then we'll pass in event dot Target
now what you're going to see is as we
click right here
the square
is going to represent that div and the
event Target represents the div because
we clicked on the same thing now if I
put the mouse in the middle of that icon
remember we now have a new HTML element
right here if I click that it's going to
register the event Target as that I tag
rather than the div so what you'll see
here is that the square and the event
Target will not match up when I click
this and we'll have that weird Behavior
so you see the square is the div and the
event Target is the actual icon to make
this Behavior more stable
and just better programming practice in
general
we should be updating the square element
itself and not relying on the event
Target because we can't control whether
the user is going to click
the icon or the square we need it to
work no matter what
so let's remove these console logs and
then instead of checking whether the
event target has child nodes we're going
to check if the square has child nodes
and then furthermore where we're
replacing the children down here we
don't want to replace the event targets
children we want to replace the square
so that will make all of this Behavior a
lot more stable and when we save this we
should be able to click in any Square as
many times as we want and you can see
our console log is going to say the
current player is one still so if I'm
clicking any of these the turn is not
changing the Turn Only changes when we
the player clicks a valid square and
then we're going to have a different
current player so we've got this working
this is kind of some boilerplate for
what we're going for we will refactor
this to be a little bit more stable some
better practices but for now this works
just fine I'm going to clean this up we
don't need these console logs anymore
um the next thing that we're going to
need to do
is if we just keep clicking these and
playing the game
you can see when the O player I think
that's player two when they win the game
nothing happens and that's because we
haven't programmed anything to happen so
we need a way to detect when this game
ends and there's going to be different
patterns that represent a winning game
and then of course we can also if we
refresh reset everything we can also end
up in a tie so I believe if we
let's see if I can even produce a tie
here
um
requires a little bit of thinking to do
that so in this case the game should be
a tie and we should be able to recognize
that now they're in the original project
that I'm I was refactoring here they had
a pretty nice way of handling this and
they'll want to highlight that
so if we open up main.js from the
original project
um what they were doing to check whether
the game was won is they had an uh
basically an array of winning patterns
and they were basically just checking
which squares were currently
um had plays in them and did they match
these winning patterns and that's how
they would determine whether the game
was a winning game so I'm going to copy
this array here and I'll show you how
we're going to use this
so let's start writing some comments
here because our method is getting a
little bit large so check if there is
already a play if so return early
because we don't want any turns to
change or anything like that
then we'll come down here and we'll get
the current player we'll create the icon
and we will add that icon to the div
right down here and then the next thing
that we need to do is let's let's
actually put a comment here
determine
which player
icon to add to the square
and then finally check if there is a
winner or tie game once again we're
going to refactor all this so I know
it's getting pretty busy in this method
we're going to refactor it I'll show you
a better way to do this for now we're
going to paste in those winning patterns
and so the question becomes how do we
know the current state of this game how
do we know what squares have been played
in and which ones have not been and
furthermore which player has played in
each of the squares now we could of
course do some elaborate check where we
basically say you know we search the
current Square we check if it has
anything in it and then we could maybe
check the class list and check if it's
an fax or an FAO and then basically Loop
through all of the squares on the board
to determine what the current state of
the game is but what's a lot easier to
do is to just track that and State as we
go so rather than doing this sort of
check we can just check the state but
first we need to Define what that state
is so what we'll say is that we need to
track an array of game moves
and those game moves are just going to
be the player that has played
so what it might look like is something
like this where we have
um I'm sorry we we need to track the
square itself too so we're going to say
the square ID is going to be 1 and then
the player is going to be one so that
move right there would represent if
player one clicks this top left Square
so we basically are just tracking a
square ID and a player ID in the moves
array so let's empty that out that's
going to be our default state is an
empty game
and then down here within this event
listener
as you can see we're updating the
current player in state
but what we also want to do is we want
to push a move to state so app.state dot
moves and then we want to push a new
move that is going to be an object with
a square ID
and let's just
um reference the square itself
or we could also say the yeah we'll just
say the square dot ID and this needs to
be a number so we'll add a little
coercion there to make that a number
type
and then the player we'll just call it
the player ID just for consistency
that's going to be equal to the current
player of the game so
we've already updated the current player
right here to be the next player so we
need to actually put this state update
right above that so that the current
player is right so we'll say
um
I don't know why we're checking this
right here we've already extracted that
there so let me refactor that real quick
and then we can put current player right
there
and then just for us to see what's going
on here I'm going to console log
app.state after those updates have
happened
at the moment this isn't going to change
any of the behavior we're just tracking
another state variable so let's click
something click another click another
and you can start to see we're building
up State we're building up an array of
moves and you can see that square id1
has a move from player id1 so the x
square 2 has a player ID of 2 an O and
square 3 has a player ID of 1 and an X
so you can see as we add moves we are
adding to that array of moves now what's
interesting about this is that we can
also derive some State here we can
simplify things a little bit so if we go
back up to our state you got to ask
yourself well who is currently up based
on the number of moves that are in that
array we actually don't need to track
the current player because we will be
able to derive that based on the moves
that have been played
so let's actually delete the current
player from State all we really need to
track is moves and I'll show you how to
derive that right here so the first
thing that we want to update
um is let's see
the current player variable right here
so
what we can do is we can say if
app.state.moves
um
that length
equals zero so if there's been no plays
at all then we're going to say the
current player is one we'll just always
say that the current player is one they
start the game every time
if it is not equal to zero then we're
going to check for the last move of the
game so the last element of that array
and then grab the player who is opposite
of that player so this is going to
require a little bit more logic than we
have right here
um so I'm going to break that out
so we'll say the last move
is
app.state.moves and then you can use a
little convenience method you could of
course check it by saying
app.state.moves
dot length minus one that's a typical
way that you could grab the last element
of the array but there's a more concise
way with JavaScript you can just say at
negative one which will grab the last
element of that array now of course we
don't know if that array has anything in
it so
that could be I believe undefined if
there's nothing in the array
so now we can come down to the current
player
we can say if the length of the array is
zero we'll go with one otherwise we're
going to grab the last move and that
move
has a player ID in it so it's going to
not be the player ID of the last move
it's actually going to be the opposite
of that so what we can say is a little
convenience method get opposite player
and we'll just pass in a player ID
and we'll say if player ID
equals one then we're going to pass in
player two otherwise one
so we'll say get opposite player of the
last move
sorry this is getting a little
complicated we'll break this out into
some helper methods later
but basically what we're doing is we're
finding the last move we've got a helper
method that gets the opposite player and
then we're checking to see if there's
any moves if there is
if there's not any moves then player one
is up because it's the beginning of the
game otherwise we're going to get the
opposite player to the last move that
was played and that will give us our
current player and that way we don't
have to track any of that state and that
should flow down to here where we're
checking and adding moves to the game so
let's save that and see if it works
you can see that we're alternating and
we can click on these as many times as
we want and it's pretty stable now
there's one more thing that we can do
now that we're tracking the game moves
we don't really need to check whether
the square has child nodes because
that's really relying on the Dom itself
it would be better
just to express what we're trying to do
to check the state of the game so let's
say
um
we need a helper method called has move
and what we're going to do is just
Define a function
that takes a square
actually a square ID so it'll be a
number and then we're going to just
basically return or we're going to say
existing move is equal to
app.state.moves and then we're going to
look for that square ID in that array so
we're going to call find
and we're going to look at the move
and check if the square ID matches the
square ID that we're passing into this
helper function and then we're going to
return the existing move does not equal
null and that's another way of saying
does not equal undefined or null so we
could also say does not equal double
equals undefined
okay and that will give us whether
there's a move so now we can replace
this with has move and then we can just
pass in the Square dot ID
and make sure that's a number so that
it's comparing the same type
I think if we got this right we should
be able to click squares multiple times
and it will not do anything which is
telling us that our check has worked
okay
so at this point
I know that we've done a lot of
refactoring and it seems like for
nothing but the goal of this is whenever
you're tracking state within an
application you want to keep it as
simple as humanly possible and the
reason being is as we've seen down here
where we're actually updating the state
to the current player which by the way
we can get rid of now because we're
deriving that information
but when we update State as we're doing
here in the moves pushing a move to the
array
every time you track something in state
you also have to update it somewhere and
the more things you track in state the
more updates you're responsible for and
therefore the more possible errors that
you're going to introduce to your
application so the goal with tracking
state is to keep it as simple as
possible so that you have the least
number of variables to keep track of
over the life cycle of your application
in this case all we're doing is tracking
an array of moves and then from that
little piece of information we're able
to then derive who is the current player
and from that we can then you know
update state to to make another move
within the game at this point we've
refactored our state and we're updating
it to just have an array of moves
which is a lot it allows us to derive
pretty much everything that we need to
know about the current game
now the next thing that we need to do
that we can now actually do with this
state is find whether someone has won
the game or if it's a tie or if it's
still in progress
so what we're going to do is actually
make a utility function for this and I'm
going to add this
just at the top and this is not going to
be the final destination of it
um actually we could even just put it
within the app but we'll probably
rearrange this in the future so what we
want to do is call it something like get
game status
and this function is going to take
an argument here so what are we going to
pass in will be an array of moves
and then we also probably need well I
think that's pretty much all we need we
just need an array of moves which is
tracked in state so with that array of
moves we should be able to give a couple
pieces of information so we'll Define
the return value of this just to start
the first thing is going to be the
status which this can either be
um we'll call it in progress
or complete
so we will put a placeholder in there
for right now but this will become
dynamic
and then we will also give a winner
which again will put a placeholder in
there but this is going to either be one
or two so player one or player two and
then also it could be null which would
represent a tie so that's kind of how
we're going to
um represent this
and based on these two pieces of
information we should be able to know
whether the game you know what to show
in the UI whether we show the modal that
pops up and gives the result or we keep
playing
so to do this the first thing we need to
do is get player one moves and the moves
array that we're going to be passing is
the entire game
so all we need to do is filter that
and then check on each move whether the
player ID
is equal to one
so that will give us player one moves
and then we can copy that down and
change the ID to get player 2 moves from
there we should be able to bring up our
winning patterns so this will now come
up in that utility method
we'll paste that right there and what we
want to do is Loop through each of these
winning patterns and check if either of
the player moves have all three of these
within their array and if all three of
them match then we know that one of the
players has actually won the game
so the way we can do that is start out
by saying the winner equals null so
we'll just assume to start that it's
there's no winner and what we'll do is
map through the winning patterns so
we'll do a loop for each Loop and we'll
call each of them a pattern because this
variable will represent one of these
arrays
and then we'll break that down into a
function that will check for this
condition so we'll say player one wins
and that is only going to be true if
every value within the pattern so we'll
just say V for value
we'll say player one moves includes
that value so again we've got player
one's moves the array of moves they've
made and then we have an individual
pattern and if there's a hundred percent
overlap between player one's moves and a
given pattern we know that they've won
so the same thing can be said about
player two so we can copy that down
again and just update that array and
that should tell us whether each of the
players have won so then we can write an
if statement and we'll say if player one
wins then we just update the winner to
be equal to one so that's their ID
um and then if player 2 wins we'll
update the winner to be equal to So in
theory this should only be one player
that can win and if we don't hit a true
condition for either of these then the
winner will stay equal to null and we'll
just assume that's a tie if the game is
complete
so we come down here and instead of hard
coding that we can just remove that and
winner will be assigned to this variable
right here so that's either going to be
null for a tie one or two and then the
status of the game is going to be in
progress if there are either no winner
or the game moves does not equal nine so
if we look at our game there's nine
squares so if all of them have a move
then we know that the game is over so
that will be our first check we'll say
if the moves dot length
is equal to nine
then
we can say that is going to be a
complete Game otherwise it will be in
progress now we of course need one more
check here so if the moves that length
equals nine or the winner does not equal
no yeah so we're checking whether the
winner does not equal null because that
would represent that someone has won
before the game reached a final state of
nine plays which would be a tie so that
will help us figure out what the status
is
so now with this utility function get
game status we can come down here
and where we're checking if there's a
winner or a tie game let's just assign
that to a variable called status so
we'll say
app.getgame status and then we will pass
in the
app.state.moves and that's going to
represent the newest array of moves that
has been played
let's console.log that status just to
see what we're dealing with
and let's play a couple moves so you can
see the status is going to print every
time so our game's in progress there's
no winner
still in progress
and then this click right here should
change the status
and you see that it doesn't and we'll
have to check out why because that
should have updated to complete and
populated a winner of player one
so let's go ahead and check that see
what is happening here just to debug
this let's go ahead and just do a
classic console log
this will be quite a few logs because
we're going to be printing on every
pattern here
so let's just console log the pattern
and then player one moves in player 2
moves
just so we can get that in one big
object
and then we'll play all these moves and
then right here this is where we should
be getting a different result than we're
getting
oh and I can already see what's
happening here
so what we did wrong what I missed
is when I was filtering the player one
moves this is just going to give me the
entire move so if we print that out
to the console
what you'll see is in this array we're
printing an object with a square ID and
a player ID and when we're comparing
that down here in the every utility
method we're actually comparing a number
which is the key of the square
to that object which will never equal
each other so what we really need to do
is actually add a map utility at the end
and we're going to map that move to be a
number value that is equal to the square
ID
of those moves so now if we print this
out into the console
player one moves this should represent
an array of numbers now as you can see
representing the coordinate
um of this of the place so this should
be one two and then one two three and
now you can see that the status is
complete and the winner is equal to
player one so our utility method seems
to be working let's reset the game and
try to tie the game
so let's mix this up here
oops I accidentally won it's kind of
hard to tie this game okay so now we've
got a tie game and you can see that the
status is complete and the winner is
null so that should tell us that it was
a tie game so now we can Implement that
logic
down in our event listener
so down here at the bottom where we're
just console logging the status what
we'll say is if the status equals
complete
then what I'm going to do is just make
an alert in the in the browser so we'll
say if the status I'm sorry this should
really be
status dot status so we should probably
rename this variable
we'll say game
and this will be game dot status
and now we'll say if the game
um
if the game has a winner
then we're going to alert
player
winner wins
otherwise we know that it's a tie
so we'll say tie
let's try this out so let's go ahead and
make player one a winner
says Winner's not defined for some
reason
and that's because I'm not referencing
it correctly
try that one more time
and there we go player one wins so kind
of small but you can see now we've got
the essential functionality hooked up
and at this point I think the next step
is to trigger that modal to open when
someone has won the game or there's a
tie but before we do that let's just
recap what this big long event listener
is doing
so first We're looping through each of
the squares on the game board and we are
adding a click listener to that square
when that square is clicked all this
code is going to run
so the first thing we'll do is check if
there's a move already present within
that square
if there is we're going to exit early
and not do anything because someone can
never play twice in the same square
once we get past that we know that there
is a valid move so we're going to check
who Moved last based on the state
we're going to then get the opposite
player
of that last move and set the current
player of the game
we will then take and create an icon
and based on the player who is up we'll
add an X or an O as an icon and then
we'll put that in the Dom and we'll add
that icon to the square we'll also push
a move a new move to the state so that
we're tracking the history of moves in
the game
we'll then check the game's status after
that move has happened and if the status
is complete we then know we can do
something and open a modal to explain
whether someone has won or if the game
was a tie and now our goal is to open
that modal and give the user an action
to actually reset the game and start
over
if you remember from our index.html
when we built this
a couple hours ago you'll see down here
with the modal we just have that hidden
class sitting on there and if we remove
that and save the file you'll see that
we get this dialog to open and it's
going to cover the screen with a play
again button so the things that we have
to do is number one we have to trigger
this to actually open and then close
when we're done with it and number two
we have to add a click listener to this
button right here so that when someone
clicks play again the game state has
reset and you know everything goes back
to the beginning so let me add this
hidden class back because that's our
default state
and as I said this is going to be
refactored at some point we've got a lot
of code all sitting in one place which
is going to be hard to follow long term
but at the moment we're just putting
everything in one method
keeping it simple so that we don't have
to refactor anything quite yet
so the way that we're going to do this
is First add a selector to this modal so
just like we've done up here with let's
see
we've given data IDs to the elements
that we're going to select and control
with JavaScript so we'll do the same
thing with this modal
let's just call it modal and then the
modal contents will also give it a data
ID
and we'll set that equal to modal
contents
and what we're going to do here
let's see or actually we're not going to
put it there because we don't really
need to control that we need to control
this text element so data ID equals
modal text
and then this will be the data ID
modal button
so you don't really need to add these
data IDs to all of them because really
you could just select the modal and then
grab those elements dynamically I'm just
being pretty explicit about it just for
clarity so let's go ahead and select
these within our app because that's kind
of what we've been doing I'm just
collecting all of these elements that
we've selected so let's copy this down
and we'll name this one modal
this data ID will be modal
and then we'll say modal text
and modal button
and as you can see we're doing a lot of
repetitive stuff here so if you're
thinking this will be refactored too to
be a little bit simpler and to eliminate
the need to write all of this boiler
played out but I'm leaving it here now
because it's it's pretty clear what's
happening
so now that we've got these three we can
pretty much control them
down here in this check on the game
status
so if the game status is complete and we
have a winner
the one thing that we know we need to do
is print to the modal who has won that
game so let's just say app dot dollar
sign because that's our namespace for
all of those elements
um
actually first we need to open the modal
I'm sorry so if the game's complete we
know that we need to open the modal
so modal and then what we're what we're
going to do is look at the class list in
toggle
the hidden class on that but to be a
little bit more explicit since we know
that we're opening it here rather than
toggling the hidden class which could
work there what we're going to do is
actually remove
what is the yeah we should be able to
say classlist.remove
that hidden class
so let's try that first let's make sure
that that's working so someone wins the
game here
and says modal.classlist is undefined so
we mess something up here oh and that
the problem is we're using query
selector all because that's what we had
for squares this should just be a basic
query selector so now I believe this
part should work
so let's win the game for someone and we
get the alert but we also get the modal
so let's remove this alert
um for the moment because it's kind of
getting in the way but now that we know
there's a game winner what we can do is
we can say that the text is going to be
equal to player and then give the
game.winner so that'll be the ID
so that's the message that we want to
put so let's call that message actually
and here our message is going to be
tie game
and then all we have to do
we can actually extract that to a
message up here
um
and then
assign that there and then no matter
what we're going to say app
dot dollar sign dot modaltext dot inner
text or is it inner HTML I can't
remember
uh it's not in or anything it's text
content is equal to the message
so let's save that and see if that works
so someone's going to win the game here
and it's player one
now let's refresh the page and this time
let's let player 2 win so player 2 wins
and you can see that dynamically will
populate
now the last thing that we need to do is
put that click listener on the play
again button
we're not going to do that in this
method because remember we're
registering our event listeners all at
the top level of this function
so let's just put that right here we'll
say app dot dollar sign dot modal button
add event listener
we're going to listen for a click event
and then with that event all we're going
to do is set set the state DOT moves
equal to an empty array because we want
to reset the game and then we also want
to close the modal if it's open so the
way that we'll do that is app.d dollar
sign dot modal and then classlist dot
actually not remove we want to add the
hidden class back so that will hide the
modal
so now that should be hooked up
and if we go through the game someone
wins and we click this button it closes
it and you can see there's still game
moves here because resetting the state
doesn't actually change the UI quite yet
we will refactor that at some point
but at the moment it does not so not
only do we have to reset the state but
we also have to Loop through each of
those squares and empty out their
contents so let's see how we would do
that is we'd say app.dollarsign squares
and then we'll say for each Square
we're going to say Square dot replace
children and just leave that empty and
that's just a shortcut to clear
everything out of the squares
so now let's go back and try it one more
time someone wins the game we click play
again and everything has cleared
so we now have a functioning tic-tac-toe
game
player one wins again see if we can get
a tie here
you have to really think about this one
to get a tie
um let's see that should work okay
there's a tie game play again clears it
out the last thing that is not working
here is this turn indicator you can see
that no matter what we play it's just
staying the same and we obviously want
to update that now a great place to do
that is going to be within this super
long event listener for each of the
square clicks where we're updating the
current player so we'll actually do that
in this if else statement but first we
have to grab those elements that we want
to update
so let's find the turn indicator
and you can see right here this is where
we're doing it and we've got an icon
that we need to update and some text
that we need to update so here what
we're going to do is add a data ID and
call that turn
so we'll now go select that in our list
of elements
so we'll say turn
and then just copy this down again
and one thing that we need to do here
that I kind of missed is we've got the
turquoise class set on the individual
icon but we want these both to match so
it would be a little bit easier
if we just put that up here on the turn
element and we also need to match things
up so the first player is player one
which we're just determining is going to
be X and that's going to be yellow so we
need to match those up let's save that
and just make sure that this is matching
now which it is so this is what we're
looking for as a starting point and now
all we need to do is just toggle this
from yellow to turquoise and back and
then we'll toggle the elements within it
to indicate the turn
so we can do that here
um
one thing we'll need to check is get a
little bit more clear on who's up next
so the current player represents who's
actually clicking right now
the next player is going to be the one
that we want to change the turn
indicator for
so you've got the current player and
then
we can say next player and reuse that
get opposite player I know we're a
little redundant here
um
but we'll go ahead and use it so this
should represent it in the ID of the
next player
now we can come down here and say the
turn label
is going to be a new element
you could have replaced the element
that's already there but I'm just going
to create a p element
and then that turn label
dot inner text
is going to be equal to
player
next player
what we determined up there
you are up
and we'll copy that down
um actually we can just put that right
there
and then from here
we can just say app.d dollar sign and
select the turn element so remember
we're just selecting this entire div and
we want to replace the contents of it
so all we need to do is say replace
children and then we can pass as it
shows here we can spread out parameters
as individual nodes so it will replace
them in order
so if we want the icon to go first we
just pass that there and then we'll pass
the turn label
when we save this let's see if we get
the correct result so I'll go here
and you can see that we're getting the
correct text but the color is not
updating and we're not getting the icon
to also be added
I believe the problem here is we're
actually adding this same icon to two
different places so we probably need to
break that out into two separate
elements
so we'll say turn icon
and then this will be the square icon
so those will be two separate elements
and down here
we'll pass the square icon
and then here we'll pass the turn icon
and we of course want the same exact
colors here I believe
or actually no these need to be opposite
because once again we have the next
player is going to be the opposite color
of the current player
so we'll say the
Square icon
and then we'll copy this down and this
will be the turn icon and this will be
the exact opposite
so this will be the o
and it will be turquoise
this will be turn icon with an X that is
yellow
once again we are going to refactor this
it's not going to be this confusing and
verbose here in the future
so hopefully this works
now we're getting a lot closer we have
everything correct except for it looks
like this text is O is yellow
and it's because we're not setting the
color of that so we need to say the turn
label
dot class list
and let's go ahead and do that down
here so turn
babel.class list
and we'll set that equal to turquoise
to match what we're making the turn icon
right here and then we'll copy that down
and make this one yellow if it's player
two
so now it looks like we're getting
everything correct so if we play in O
now X player one is up if we play an X
well we've got to play again but you can
see that that is updating correctly now
as you noticed if we end the game and
player one wins you'll see up here
player 2 has it is up next and that's
their turn
and if we click play again that's not
going to reset so we need to remember to
reset the turn and since we've coupled
all of that turn logic within this event
listener we have no easy way to do that
up here when we're resetting everything
so at this point we've reached a place
in our code where we've got a lot of
stuff going on
right in this method that we would like
to be able to reuse in different places
to like reset the state and whatnot but
right now it's very hard to do that so
the next segment of this video is going
to be taking this code and refactoring
it to look a little bit cleaner and be
more reusable and easy to follow so
we'll go through that but as of right
now we have a working game for the most
part as long as we refresh things
and we can determine who wins the game
so once again we'll refactor things then
we'll start talking about keeping this
state for the scoreboard and then moving
into the MVC pattern so as we talked
about
we've got the naive approach all in one
file that's what we're still on we've
been refactoring iterating as we go and
then we'll end up with something pretty
clean that we can reuse and extend into
the future so we've reached a point
where our code is getting a bit
confusing and if we continued to add
this functionality so if we were trying
to reset this turn indicator when the
game ends remember we've got a problem
here it doesn't reset and then we also
have to be able to reset the whole game
and reset the round track all of this
state you know the history of the games
there's a lot to do here and given our
current code it's going to be very
confusing to do because we've got all
this stuff in one method there's all
sorts of stuff we're updating State
we're updating the view all in one spot
so this is where a pattern comes in and
helps us out a bit I waited until this
point
um to mainly simulate a real life
scenario where generally you're going to
start off in one file just to understand
the logic that you need within your
application and then as you go you you
have to refactor to keep things clear in
your head and to make the code
maintainable
so at this point we understand what
patterns we actually need here and that
makes it a lot easier to introduce
something like an MVC or model view
controller pattern just as a side note
the MVC pattern is really relevant to
something like Ruby on Rails so if you
typed Ruby on Rails
and you go to the documentation you'll
start to see a lot of these patterns and
if we were I'm introducing this not
because I think you need to use Ruby on
Rails but more so because it's kind of
the Premier example of a framework that
leverages this model view controller
pattern and has gained a lot of
popularity so if we go to the docs let's
see if we go to the API Maybe
that's probably not where we want to go
so as we're scrolling through the docs
you can already see there's a header
section called models
then there's views
and then there's controllers so they
very explicitly build out this pattern
so this is just a good reference you
don't need to check this out I just
wanted to point it out
so enough Theory here let's get into
this the way that we're going to build
this model view controller pattern is
actually by breaking this single file
out into those three different
responsibilities
and that kind of brings us back to our
best practices so whether or not you're
using a model view controller pattern
there's other patterns that you could
use the main point here is that we want
to separate
um logic by
um
responsibility
in other words this is the separation of
concerns principle that is just a good
programming principle in general it's
something that you would always want to
try to aim for no matter what pattern
you're using so let's jump back over
we've obviously got quite a bit of
functionality here that we don't want to
have to completely redo a lot of this is
good stuff that we've worked out but we
do need to refactor this into a couple
files
so in our JS directory I'm going to add
a new file one called the view.js one is
going to be called store.js and this
will actually represent the model I'm
just calling it store because it kind of
represents the storage that we're using
you could call it whatever you want
um so we'll call that store
and then app.js this is really going to
be our quote unquote controller it's not
a super explicit
um adherence to the pattern but we're
getting very close and the goal of a
design pattern is to make things easier
for you so you don't need to follow it
so rigidly that everything matches up
one to one as long as it's useful it is
going to be okay so as we go and build
this out I'm going to be kind of looking
up here
um to my other screen because I've
actually as you know I've already built
this app out in preparation for this
video and I just want to make sure that
this live build that we're doing matches
up with the final code that you're going
to see in the GitHub repository that is
linked in the video description so
that's all I'm doing I'm just making
sure that I'm naming the methods the
same so on and so forth so what we need
to start with I think is going to be
um let's go ahead and do the view
because that is what most of this logic
we have in our application is pertaining
to at the moment
so let's open up View and we're going to
be jumping into some object-oriented
programming Concepts here so that's just
another way of saying we're going to be
working with some JavaScript classes and
specifically es6 syntax 4 classes I'll
try to point out some of the syntax that
I'm using and what it means but if you
are not at all familiar with classes and
what they are and how they work I would
recommend brushing up on that pausing
the video
and just reading a couple you know
overview guides just to get yourself a
little bit up to speed that said I will
try to explain things as we go and I'm
not going to assume that you have any
sort of advanced knowledge here so we'll
we'll walk through it together
so the first thing that we need to do in
our view is Define that class that we're
we're going to be using
now we can call this a class of view
and that's really all the syntax that we
need we of course will use a Constructor
this is kind of the initialization of
the class and it belongs on it's
available on any class that you use
and then furthermore we're going to
start to bring over our methods so there
are things
um that are available on the class
instances
um called class properties and that's
where we're going to store those
elements that we had defined earlier so
we'll just initialize the dollar sign to
an empty object and we'll start
populating that here in a second so the
first thing that we want to do in our
class and we'll do this in the
Constructor because we want all of these
elements to be selected when the class
is initialized so we'll go back to our
app.js and we'll take all of these
selectors that we've used
and we will assign them in the
Constructor so we'll have to update some
of the syntax here but really we'll just
click down and select a bunch at once
and what we'll say is this dot dollar
sign dot whatever the variable is
because we are basically referencing
when we say this we're referencing the
class instance itself and on that class
instance we have defined a property uh
which is the dollar sign this could be
any variable we're just using a short
name space for easy easy way to access
and so what we're doing is we're saying
the class instance
the property that we want and then the
um another nested property that will
represent the element itself so now
instead of colons we'll need to set
those to equal signs
and then we'll hit command s to format
things and save it although we've got
some
commas here at the end that we need to
get rid of first
now we can save it in a prettier we'll
format this for us remember as I
mentioned earlier in the video I've got
format on Save setup with the prettier
extension in vs code so that's why it's
saving like that and formatting
everything
so at this point we've got our basic
class and when it initializes we're
going to select all the elements in the
document but just having this alone it's
not going to actually work quite yet we
need to connect this to our app.js
furthermore we're not going to really
need this namespace anymore because
we're going to be working with
um or we we may use the namespace but
we're going to be moving pretty much all
of this code out but in order to do that
without completely breaking everything
I'm going to leave all the code intact
it's just a good way to do it when
you're refactoring something you want to
leave the original code intact and just
build the new code side by side and then
you'll replace it at the end but since
we're not going to have any of this code
here anymore what I'm going to do is
build this side by side and we're going
to just make a standalone function
called init and yes this is in the
global namespace but this should could
really be the only thing this and maybe
one other variable that we'll put in the
global scope so that should be fine
and what we'll do in the init method is
basically initialize the class itself so
we'll say the view is going to be equal
to New View
so that is going to make a class
instance of this class right here and
then what I'm going to do just to test
things is console.log view dot dollar
sign and then let's just say turn
because that was one of the elements
that we selected in other words we're
just testing to make sure that this was
initialized correctly
furthermore we want to duplicate this
event listener we will eventually remove
this once we've refactored everything
but for now we just want to use this
knit method when the the window loads so
let's save that and then go back to our
browser let me get these tabs organized
again
okay so we'll go to our browser here and
go to the console
and it's going to say uncut reference
error the view is not defined and
there's a good reason for this it's
because we have not imported that script
now obviously app.js has been imported
right here at the bottom but we would
also need to import the view.js for that
to be defined and if we come back now
you'll see that our console log worked
because that's now defined
but let's go back
and flip these let's put them in a
different order so we first load the
view and then we load the app
does it still work well the answer is
yes and I believe that's because of
hoisting that happens with JavaScript
um but what's confusing about this is
we've got these two separate files
with different variables and they kind
of reference each other but that can get
confusing when you have more and more
files so one solution to this that will
help us out quite a bit and allows us to
just import one script is to use es6
modules so instead of adding this
additional script import which gets
messy once you have five or six Scripts
we're just going to import app.js and
then we're going to set a type attribute
on the script and we're going to name it
module what this is going to do is it's
going to tell the browser that this
script is an es6 module and now in
pretty much every major browser es6
syntax is
supported as well as modules so this is
a nice way to handle imports and exports
so now in app.js rather than just
referencing this view class variable
we can import that so at the very top of
our file
what we'll do is we'll say import view
from
view.js
now right now this is not going to work
and it's not going to work because we
haven't exported anything from this
module
what we need to do is put an export
and then we want to export this as the
default export so that we can reference
it in our file just like this now if we
left out this keyword of default
we would need to put this in Brackets
in reference it just like this so if we
did that this should work if we go to
the browser you'll see that this is
being printed out which is what we're
doing here at the bottom
right here that's the console log but I
think it's a little cleaner if we just
export the default
go back to app and then remove these
brackets
save it and then we'll check to make
sure this console log is working and it
is
now another property
um or feature of using modules is that
by default they use strict so if you've
ever seen use strict in JavaScript
use strict we'll look that up
strict mode is something in JavaScript
that used to be really relevant as you
had different files that would have
different modes nowadays you'll pretty
much see strict mode on every file that
you ever write but this has a lot of
useful defaults to kind of protect your
code from all sorts of problematic
patterns so by default these es6 modules
or in strict mode which means that in
the view.js you might say well oh this
view is in the global scope but that's
not the case we haven't actually
attached it to the window so if we were
to go to our console and type view it's
going to say view is not defined the
only way that that would be possible
as if we said if we explicitly attached
it to the window like this so
window.view equals View and now we
should be able to see the class that
we've defined but this is not what we
want and I just wanted to point that out
as a feature of es6 modules by default
they're going to behave this way and
we're going to protect the global scope
that way what this also means is that
our init method if you remember from
earlier
scrolling up we had defined this app
variable as the namespace around our
entire app so that we didn't litter the
global scope with all of these variable
declarations
but now if we try to access app at all
um we're not going to be able to because
it's in an es6 module and by default
that is not exposed to the global
namespace so that's basically why I'm
okay adding this init method in the
global scope because I know that's not
going to be exposed in the in the
browser
unnecessarily so that's just a little
tidbit but let's keep moving here on our
refactor so looking through our app
let's also find other things that relate
to The View
one of those things that is very
relevant to just a view class is these
event listeners we want the event we
want the view to register event
listeners initially so we can copy all
of this over
in my final code I want to see how I
which method I put this under so in my
final code each of these event listeners
has its own method in the view so I'm
going to open up two
code Windows here and make it a little
bit smaller for us hopefully you can
still see that
and what we'll do is we'll basically
take each of these event listeners and
make it its own method within the view
class
so just to stay consistent with my
naming we will call the first one bind
game reset event
so that is the game reset and this is
actually a new pattern that we're
introducing rather than handling the
event listeners within the view we want
to do that in the controller and the
reason being is because the controller
is going to read the current state of
the application and based on that state
it may have to do different things to
the view so you don't want to leave it
just to the view itself to handle these
events so we're going to put a Handler
callback function passed as an argument
to each of these event listeners
so we'll use some es6 syntax to Define
this function and then here we're going
to actually register those event
listeners so I'll type out the first one
just so you can see it slowly and then
we'll copy things over so for example
let's look at this one
um or no that's not a good example
we'll use the reset game here
so all we're going to do is reference
these initialized selected elements that
we have
so this dot dollar sign
dot which one are we selecting here
reset button and then just like we're
doing over here we're going to add the
event listener
listening for a click event and then in
the Callback
we're going to do something but the
difference here is instead of handling
this in the view we're just going to
pass the Handler itself so we can just
pass that Handler
from here down to this event listener
and then all of that is going to be
handled in app.js so let me add the rest
of them so bind new round event
pass that Handler
and then bind Player move event with a
Handler
and here what we can do is basically
just copy this over so this is the
um
the move event
so we'll just copy this over so this is
the new round
so we just add this dot dollar sign and
that should work okay but of course we
want to handle this elsewhere so we'll
pass the Handler from the function
parameters
or arguments I mean
and then for the player move event this
is the one where We're looping through
each of the squares and adding those
listeners so at this point I don't want
to just copy everything over because
we're going to do this a little bit
differently moving forward so we're
going to start to diverge from our
original implementation and just start
to use it as a reference only not trying
to copy things verbatim
so what we want to do here is Select
those squares
and for each of those squares similar to
how we're doing it here we'll want to
bind an event listener so we'll say
Square dot add event listener
listening for a click and then we're
passing this Handler right here now
let's talk about
um event listeners that are going to be
view only things so you'll notice that I
skipped over
here on the left I skipped over this one
right here where we are clicking on the
button to reset the game although that
should probably be added here but
specifically let's look at this one
where we're just toggling something in
the UI so remember we just have this
actions menu That's opening and closing
this is not going to affect the state of
the game whatsoever it's purely a view
um client only piece of state that we're
tracking and therefore
in terms of responsibilities The View
can handle a hundred percent of that it
doesn't need to change any state or
anything so we can actually register
that in the Constructor and keep it
entirely encapsulated here so we'll call
this section UI only event listeners
and here what we're going to say is this
dot dollar sign that menu
items I'm sorry we need the modal button
for menu button menu items and then
we're just going to toggle the class
list
so we'll say menu items that add event
listener listening for a click
and then we'll go back in that callback
and we're handling this in the view
itself
so we'll say this dot dollar sign dot
menu items dot class list
that toggle hidden and we're going to
actually improve this Handler just a
little bit
for some reusability but let's start
with that and at this point I think it's
time to kind of
comment out this app that we had before
so we're going to be resetting a good
amount of functionality for the time
being
oops
so we'll just go through this whole app
here
the whole thing including the uh load
event you can comment that out
we'll keep it here for reference but
it's all commented out at this point
so all we have now is just the view so
let me collapse all that because it's
just going to be easier to see and we'll
save this and now let's see what the UI
looks like so right now I can't really
do anything I can click stuff but
nothing is going to actually happen now
the reason nothing is working is because
I actually grabbed the wrong thing here
on the right let's bring this over so we
have a full screen
um in our new view class I'm actually
actually adding a click listener on menu
items it should just be menu
because if we go back to our index.html
and look for that we want to register
register The Listener on menu
or probably more specifically we want to
add a data ID and call this menu button
so let's go back to our view
we've got the menu menu items and let's
add one more
menu button
and then we'll add the selector here
and now we're listening for a click on
the menu button and then when that
happens we're toggling the hidden class
on many items
so going back we should now be able to
toggle the menu open and closed but
that's just about it we can't do
anything clicking the reset button new
round a square it doesn't do anything
anymore
and we need to start wiring up those
events just to show you the pattern that
we'll be using you can see that we are
we have methods to bind these event
listeners but remember by default when
this class is initialized
um are instantiated these methods are
not going to run because they're just
methods of the class
someone needs to actually call these for
these event listeners to be added
so that's what we're going to do in the
apps init method so right here below the
class initialization we now have a class
instance called View
which we should be able to bind all of
these events so we'll bind the game
reset event and you can see that our
autocomplete tells us that we need to
pass a Handler in there and that Handler
is going to give us an event
so we can stub it out just like this and
we can consult that log the event
will also console.log the name so
reset event
so we'll copy this down for all of them
we just had three of them so let's see
what we call bind new round event
and then bind Player move event
so now we're actually calling those
methods that are registering the event
listeners so now when we go back to our
UI we should be able to at least click
things and see things happening so new
round event
or if I click the first Square it says
Player move event and you'll see the
click Target is
um the square with the ID of one so div
ID equals one or if we click down here
we'll see in the ID of nine now with
this pattern we want to keep our
controller logic which is in this app as
simple as possible we want this to
really just orchestrate what happens to
the state in the view but we don't want
to add a lot of logic to this file most
of the logic needs to happen in view.js
or store.js which we haven't created
quite yet
I will get to this and show you why we
have this
but let's continue with the view and
start implementing some of these methods
here I think a good place to start is to
go back to our app open up our original
implementation
and let's let's go ahead and go down
to this big event listener that we have
or no we'll start with these these
littler ones
and just so that we can see this better
I'm going to uncomment everything
and we're just not going to initialize
it so I'll uncomment the whole app but
because we're not initializing it here
we can delete that this is just going to
be a variable that's initialized it's
not going to actually do anything or
register any sort of event listeners
so this is just for reference so if we
go down and look at some of the code
that we've already written we've
implemented this toggle method over here
in view as a UI only event that doesn't
need to happen anywhere else now these
have not been implemented we have a
click listener on the modal button
which allows us to hide the modal once
the game ends we'll get to that in a
second
but really what we want to start looking
at is all of this logic because it's a
little bit messy and we could probably
create individual methods to achieve
what we're doing here
let's start by improving our menu toggle
right now in the UI what you'll see is
that it opens and closes but this little
Chevron down icon it's not going to
change and generally when you have
something like this the icon will rotate
180 degrees and go up when it's open and
down when it's closed or vice versa I
can't even remember which one is the
correct design
the correct way to do it from a design
perspective but anyways we can improve
this a little bit and we can also add
like a selected state so that there's
like a border when it's open so this
will help us to kind of ease into this
new pattern so as you can see I'm
handling this UI only event in the
Constructor and directly toggling that
hidden class but what we'll do is break
out this view into a couple sections
so this section is going to be register
all the
event listeners
then the next section is going to be
some utility methods so uh Dom helper
methods and that just means we're going
to have some methods to change the UI in
some way in the first one we'll Define
is toggle menu
and that's going to be called
we're going to move this logic
into that method and then we will just
say this dot toggle menu and call that
so we've just refactored it a little bit
and we're going to add some stuff to
this so let's make sure it works if we
click this it toggles the menu okay and
we're set but now we want to add
something a little bit better to this so
what I want to do is First add a border
when the menu is selected so we're going
to say this dot menu button because
that's what we're going to put the
border around and then let's toggle on
the class list a border which if you
remember from our styles
index.css we have the shared utility
classes and we've got this border class
so we can just toggle that to get a
border on it so now if we click you'll
see that when it's open we have a border
and when it's closed there's no border
so that's just kind of a nice addition
you could probably achieve this with CSS
but I thought it'd be
um nice to just demonstrate some
JavaScript
um and then furthermore we want that
little icon to flip up and down
depending on the open or closed state
so to do that we need to actually
um
create a different icon based on that
state and what I'll do is Define that in
a variable and from here I'm going to
let's see I'm going to grab from the
menu button so the menu button is going
to be
this right here and you can see that
I've got an icon down here at the bottom
so basically what I'm doing is I'm
selecting the button itself and then I'm
grabbing any eye tag that is within it
so we'll say query selector and we're
going to look for any I tag that we can
find which should represent that icon
and then what we're going to do is look
at the class list of that and since
we're using font awesome we can just
toggle
fa Chevron down and then also Chevron up
and this should basically just flip it
every time the menu is toggled so if we
click here you'll see this little icon
just flips every time it opens and
closes so that's just a nice addition to
polish that up but more importantly it
demonstrates in a pretty simple way how
we can Define all of these Dom helper
methods and then within our event
listeners we'll just call those to
basically change the Dom and change what
the user is seeing from A View
perspective
before we uh go to the next set of event
listeners I want to do one little
refactor here and add a utility method
for selecting elements as you can see
we're using a lot of markup here just to
select kind of basically using the same
syntax and more importantly this is the
the better reason to do this refactor
we're not entirely certain whether this
is going to result in a element being
selected we can put these
selectors in and check them over and
over again but we really have no
assurances that what we have attached to
this list of elements is going to
actually be valid selected elements so
what we can do is at the very bottom of
this class we can add a few helper
methods
what I'm going to call this is a Qs for
that's short for query selector and then
you should be able to pass in a string
selector to that method and all I'm
going to do is look for the element
and that's going to be on the document
dot query selector and then we'll pass
in that selector that was in the
parameters and then what we're going to
do is make a check so we're going to say
if there is no element that was selected
so in other words we passed the wrong
selector something went wrong
we're going to throw a new error and the
reason for that is we don't really want
to continue
um with our application and trying to
perform all the additional logic if
these selectors don't work in the first
place because that will just mess up
everything so we're going to say could
not find elements
and this will just give us as the
developer some confidence that we're
passing in the right selectors and here
we can just return the element which we
know is defined now
so there's a few improvements we'll make
to this but let's go ahead and try this
out
so with the menu we can just say this
dot Qs and then we pass in the data ID
and that should select the menu so let's
go back to the UI you can see that
there's no errors I'm going to get rid
of this for for the moment because that
was something left over from
right here so let's get rid of that so
we're not confused
but this worked and so now what we can
do is go down with the query selectors
and replace these now you'll notice
we've got a query selector all which
will not work with our utility method so
we'll leave that one alone for the time
being
so this dot Qs
and then we'll replace all of these
and save and as you'll see it all works
there's no errors let's just demonstrate
in air so let's pass an invalid selector
now you're going to see unclawed error
could not find elements we want this
error to happen so that we know that we
should go back to our code and fix it
now just a few improve improvements that
we can make with es6 class syntax the
way that you define a private class
method which is something that we don't
want to expose to the outside world of
this class
you can put a dollar sign or not a
dollar sign but a hashtag in front of
the method so let me just demonstrate
the difference here right now we have
this as a public method on the class so
if we go to app.js and we call the
instance view dot Qs you're going to see
in autocomplete on in vs code because it
thinks that this is a public method but
we really don't want to be calling this
query selector from anywhere outside of
The View
um we don't want to be doing that from
our controller so to make that private
we'll put that hashtag save it and now
when we try to grab this on The View you
won't see it as a possible method that
we can use now you could I think you can
override this I'm not sure if it's
enforced at runtime but it's just a good
practice to keep everything private that
you don't need outside that class
we can also do that for the toggle menu
so we'll put a hashtag there and we need
to Now update the calls to this so this
dot toggle menu or actually we may not
let me let me check this let's go to the
UI
yep okay we need to update that so we'll
say
#toggle menu don't know what just
happened
and then query selector so this dot
query selector
just highlighting them all
and let's grab the right one there and
then the last thing we need to do is
implement this query selector all as a
safe method so one thing I want to do
with the query selector is enable
us to add like a parent element that we
can pass
so basically this will just give us some
flexibility so we don't always have to
search on the document
so we'll say if there's a parent
argument we're going to search from the
parent
otherwise we're going to search from
the document
so just a quick little refactor there
then we're going to copy this whole
method down
we probably don't need the parent for
this one but we'll call this query
selector all
and in this one
it's going to be the same thing we're
passing a selector but now we're just
going to use a different Dom method so
if there's not an element list
we're gonna throw could not find
elements otherwise we're going to return
it so now we can replace
that query selector all with this dot
query selector all
save it and make sure we don't have any
errors which we don't and then finally
let's just make a different name space
for for
um squares because it represents a node
list well these just represent
individual elements so we'll just make
another namespace a double dollar sign
which will represent the ones that we're
picking
as a node list so we'll assign the
squares to that one just so that we have
some separation
a little bit of organization there
all right let's continue our refactor
looking at our app.js in the original
implementation here the next thing that
I want to cover and break out into a
more concise method is some of this
stuff right here so if you remember what
we're doing here is we are adding an
icon with a certain color to the square
that was clicked and we're also updating
this turn indicator up here in the top
left so I think what we can do looks
like we actually have an error here this
dollar sign squares is undefined
let's fix that before we keep going
and the problem is is we've reassigned
the squares to that double dollar sign
but we did not update that down here in
our event handler
so let's save that and we should have
that working again all right back to it
we need to update this turn indicator
and then of course when we click
something we need to turn that event
into an element in the Dom
so we can break these out into two
separate functions I think the first one
is going to be setting a turn indicator
so down here in our helper methods
let's add a method called set turn
indicator
and for right now since we're not really
we don't have the context of what player
has actually made the move
um we're just going to hard code
something and then we'll fill it in
later with something more dynamic
so the first thing that we need to do is
just look back at what what we're doing
before we were basically creating a turn
icon and a label and then giving some
inner text to the label and setting a
color on the icon so we'll do that same
logic in the set turn indicator I will
put a player
as an argument but we're not going to
leverage that just quite yet it'll just
be kind of a placeholder so what we need
to do is create an icon we can say
document dot create element
we want an i element and then we want a
label
which is going to be
a paragraph element for now let's just
assume that player is going to be either
equal to one or two
and we'll style it according to that
we're going to update that in the future
but just for now we'll assume that
so for the icon we're going to look at
the class list
and we're going to add a certain color
class based on the player so if player
equals one we're going to call that
yellow otherwise it's going to be
turquoise
that is similar to our logic here so if
the current player is one we were
calling the
I'm sorry the square icon was the yellow
and we're doing the opposite for the
turn icon but this gets a bit simpler
because right here we're tracking
basically two pieces of State we're
trying to see who was the current player
that made the move and then for the next
turn
um we're trying to decide who's the
player after that so we're mixing a lot
of things and it's a little confusing
really over here in the view we want to
be more declarative and explicit we're
just saying that player one is
associated with yellow in player 2 is
associated with turquoise
same thing goes for the label
we'll add the class list
player equals one
that's yellow otherwise turquoise now I
think in our original implementation we
weren't updating the color
of the label or were we
let's look at our HTML
you can see we have an element called
Turn which we really could just select
this and add the color class to that so
that's what we're already doing so let's
stay consistent
and do that here
so instead of setting the color based on
the player let's just say player one is
fax
and then for the message that were sent
that we're adding we need to set the
text content so let's delete that
so if it's player one fax otherwise FAO
we need to select one more element so
turn
div and I think we already have this it
should be at the top here
so right here we've selected the turn
element
so we'll say this dot dollar sign dot
turn dot class list
and we are going to add
the color based on the player now there
could be an existing color so we'll have
to do two calls here so add and remove
so we'll say if the player equals one
we're going to add a yellow color
otherwise we're going to add a turquoise
and then what we're going to remove is
if it's the player is one then we want
to remove any turquoise class
and otherwise we want to remove any
yellow class so let's just make sure
that we remove The Unwanted one and add
The Wanted class
this down here we're setting the actual
icon that we're rendering and then the
label we can set the inner text of that
and we'll basically say if it is player
one we'll say player one you're up
otherwise we will say player 2.
you're up now at this point this isn't
going to do anything because we just
kind of created these elements in memory
we actually have to commit those to the
Dom so what we need to do is select the
turn div that we had modified up here
with the classes and we need to replace
children so that will just replace the
child elements with first the icon and
then the label that we created right
here
so let's save that and right now set
turn indicator is not hooked up to
anything
but let's put that in our controller
logic
so if you remember we are binding a
Player move event right here and we're
just uh printing that to the console at
the moment but what we can do now is
reference The View
and grab that utility method that we
used now it is a private method by
default so let me check if we need to
make that public yeah let's go ahead
let's make that public for now so that
we can use it here
so we'll say set turn indicator and for
now we're just going to hard code the
player ID we're not tracking any state
yet so we're going to always say that
we're going to pass in player one
so let's save that and see what happens
if we click a square
it's not doing anything and we need to
find out why so let's inspect the HTML
if we click this Square
just looks like it's not doing anything
okay so now every time we click one of
the squares we'd expect this to update
to player one now it's already player
one so you won't see a change so let's
go back and instead of setting it to
player one we'll set it to player two
and when we click it now changes that to
an O but we're not getting the right
colors we're getting the right text
getting the right icon but not the right
Colors oh okay so our problem here is
that by default our class
of turn so this one right here is
setting the color and then we're adding
this turquoise class later which is not
getting over it's not overriding that so
a better way to probably approach this
we'll go back to our CSS
and instead of making that turn have
this initial color we will handle that
with the class so let me show you what I
mean so I'll remove that from turn in
CSS and then if we go to the HTML you'll
see I'm just passing yellow as a class
to style the initial icon and message
and so now we're not coupling the color
to the turn class so this should work
you can see player two you're up
um and it's going to set that every
single time let's refresh
so player one you're up and now we're
going to hard code that to player two
one other thing that you'll notice that
I think I've kind of messed up is this
icon has almost like italics to it
um and that's because we're not adding
the fa solid class so with font awesome
you have to add fa solid
and when we hit enter on that now it
looks a lot better so we need to
remember to add that
let's go to our view
and when we create this icon
um let's
make sure and add that class so
classlist dot add
f a solid
and what you can actually do is pass
this as two arguments so instead of
doing that twice we can just pass f a
solid and then give it a comma to do
another argument and then we'll give it
the actual icon to render
so now you see we start with that X it's
yellow it's player one and when we click
we are hard coding it to be player two
so we click and now it's an O player two
and everything is that turquoise color
so we know that our set turn indicator
method is working correctly the next
thing that we need to do is actually
populate
the square so we have to put an icon
within the square and you can see in our
original app logic somewhere right here
we are adding the square icon and doing
something pretty similar so let's go
back to the view
and this one is going to be called
handle
Player move
and for this function we're going to
pass the square element that was clicked
so the reference to that and then the
player that made the move so that we
know which icon to put in there
so this one will be rather simple we
just need to create an icon similar to
how we're doing here so we'll copy that
logic so we're creating a new icon HTML
element we are then adding a class list
which we are going to put the fa solid
remember we did that right here and then
we can use the same logic to figure out
whether it's going to be an X or an O so
depending on the player and then finally
we're going to reference the square
element so whatever Square was actually
clicked
and we're going to replace children with
that new icon that we have just set now
of course we don't have a color
specified so we can just group that here
so if it's player one it's going to be
an X and that's going to be yellow if
it's player 2 it's going to be an O and
that will be turquoise
so let's save that and now we will call
handle Player move in our controller so
now you can start to see what the
controller is supposed to be doing it's
supposed to be kind of orchestrating the
events that take place so we're going to
set the turn indicator and then we are
going to handle the player move and
let's hard code player two so those are
synced up
so now when I click this Square we would
expect that this turn indicator will
turn turquoise with an O and this Square
will
um or actually now that I'm thinking
through this we want the player move to
be player one and then the turn will be
set to the next player which will be
player two once again we will refactor
this so it's dynamic in the future we're
just trying to get our view logic to
work
so let's save that
and we'll click here and this should be
a yellow X and then this will turn to a
turquoise o
and you can see it has not done anything
and it says Dom token list add the token
cannot contain white space
so let's see what I did here okay so I
cannot do this I actually messed that
one up we need to duplicate this logic
so that
we're just doing one token per argument
so just two little just a little
refactor there and that should probably
work
so make sure we're refreshed and click
Square element replace children's not a
function because I'm just
getting tired here
um we can't just pass in that one we
need to pass in the event Target so this
will represent the square that was
clicked and so we want to pass that into
our method
and hopefully third time's a charm as
you can see it did work finally and just
going to put X's everywhere yellow X's
because we've hard-coded that in player
two Zoe is going to be up
obviously we want to make this a little
better experience so at this point
we have reached a place where we need to
address this file
store.js because we are doing some you
know view logic but right now we're hard
coding which player is up and if you
remember from the earlier implementation
we had the state variable right here
where we're tracking the moves and then
based on those moves we're getting a
game status if there's a winner and
we're also using that information to
determine you know what's the current
player and which you know icon and which
colors am I going to add looking at our
previous implementation this is kind of
a critical moment in the refactor where
we start to see things separating into
different concerns so separation of
concerns
as you can see in our event listener for
the player move we're doing multiple
things we are changing what the user is
seeing in the Dom so we're updating
classes HTML elements so on and so forth
and that's happening in logic just like
this
where we're replacing the children with
some new elements now we're also doing
something completely separate and that
is reading and updating the state of our
game
so as you can see uh sprinkled
throughout this uh listener we are doing
things like checking if the square has a
move and we're reading the state of the
application to figure that out
furthermore we're coming down here and
we're actually mutating or changing the
state of the application
right alongside the changes to the view
these two things are separate concerns
and that's why we need this store.js
file
so similar to the view.js we're going to
create a default class and Export it
so we'll copy the syntax
and this one's going to be called the
store
we of course need a Constructor
and now one new thing that I'm going to
introduce we're going to set two private
methods
we're going to add a get State method
and a Save State method
and what these are going to represent
for us is a way to get a read-only copy
of our current game State and then save
state is going to change
um and basically transition to the next
state of the application now there's
some really good articles online about
State Management one of those is the
Redux
documentation Redux
is I guess probably better to say it was
the leading State Management solution
for client-side apps for a long time now
that react has kind of refactored and
moved towards a functional component
approach with use State and stuff like
that it hasn't been used quite as much
but there are some best practices that
they have written over years of managing
state within an application and they're
very good to read through
the one that I'm going to point us to is
the Do Not mutate State best practice
so mutating state is the most common
cause of bugs in Redux applications or
in applications in general including
components failing to re-render properly
and will also break time travel
debugging in the Redux Dev tools so
that's kind of specific to Redux
um but actual mutation of State value
should be avoided and we're going to
stick to this approach because it's
generally just a good idea and reduces
the surface area for bugs to occur
if you see from our original
implementation we are directly mutating
state so we're reading it up here where
we're checking for something like the
last move and then we're directly
updating it here there's nothing
terribly wrong with this at for the size
of our application but it's just better
to make sure that we're not doing that
so what we're going to do here is
actually add a private
State variable and that's going to be
equal to an array of moves so that's
very similar to what we had up here
right here but it's going to be private
so only
this class itself can read the state and
write to it and we have to use an
intermediate method to actually retrieve
the state as I'll show in just a second
so when we get the state all we're going
to do is return this Dot
State now this is kind of a redundant
method you'll see why this is useful for
us
later in this video when we refactor
this to use a little bit more persistent
State Storage so we'll be looking into
local storage right now that's not
um needed so we're going to keep it like
this but the get State method will just
return this private State variable
or property and then the save state is
going to set it so we'll say this dot
hashtag State and then that's going to
be equal to whatever new state is passed
in
now something that's very useful when
you have a Save State method is being
able to reference the prior state within
that method so rather than just passing
a hard-coded object
as new state I'm going to make a
parameter called state or function
and this can be passed as one of two
things you can pass just a raw object or
you can pass a callback function that we
are going to give the previous value of
state to so let me just walk through
this it's a little bit confusing if
you're not familiar but this will really
help us out later
so we'll say the previous state is equal
to this dot get state
so that's the previous state we're
dealing with that's reading here
and then we need to check what kind of
argument that we're actually dealing
with so we'll say let new state
that's going to be just a
variable that we're going to initialize
but not assign yet and now we're going
to say switch
on the type of state or function
so we've got a switch statement and
we're going to look for a function type
and we'll break from that or a object
type because our state is an object and
we'll break from that and then the
default is going to be throw a new error
invalid param or invalid argument passed
to save state
because we only want to handle these two
cases
so it's pretty simple from here if it's
a function all we're going to do is say
the new state is equal to the state or
function which we know is a function
here and then we're going to pass in the
previous state so that whoever calls
this has access to that
now if it's an object we're just going
to set the new state is equal to the
um not the previous state
but the state or function so in this
case we've just passed a literal object
and we just want to assign that to state
then from here all we're going to do is
basically later we'll save this to local
storage but for now it's all good
we'll just say this dot state
is equal to the new state that we had
just assigned right here
so let's save that now we've got our get
State and save State functions
implemented and now we need to actually
initialize this so we'll have a default
value that we're passing into this store
and this default value
is going to
we'll just call it initial value and
we'll set that equal to moves and that
will be an empty array so as you can see
we've initialized it right there but
really we can just refactor that to say
initial value once again I know this is
a bit contrived we're doing a little bit
of indirect stuff but you'll see later
why this makes sense once we start
getting into local storage
at this point if you're paying attention
you'll probably notice that everything
that we've defined here is a private
method or property and therefore this
class is not very useful so what we want
to do is expose a getter method that
allows us to read the state and then our
application can take that state that
we've read and do something with it so
if you'll see in app.js one of the
things that we had defined was get game
status and we just passed in the moves
that was you know in state and that's
going to give us things like the status
of the game if it's complete or in
progress and then if there's a winner it
will Define that so this is something
that we'll need and we can Define that
in the store now something I like to use
when we're just reading a read-only
value from a class is to add a getter
method so if we add the get keyword
followed by something like game and then
we Define a method this is going to be
evaluated at runtime and basically what
we can do here
where we initialize the store which we
still need to do so store equals new
store
and that should have Auto imported
things for us so import store from
store.js
so when we initialize that now
store.game is a property that is
available
so let's just console.log store.game
right now
and we'll just return dummy value
so let's go back to our UI and you can
see that it prints dummy value now just
to demonstrate if we remove that getter
it's going to break we're just going to
get a function called game so we would
need to go over here and actually call
that as a function to get the dummy
value that we're looking for so that's
why I like to just use a getter because
you don't have to call anything you can
just add that get keyword and then this
acts as a property on the class instance
so as you can see in our Handler for a
Player move we are hard coding right now
the player that is up so we obviously
want to get that from the state of our
game or from the store
so to do that we're going to update this
class property
to basically derive some state so the
goal with saving State as we talked
about earlier is to keep it as simple as
humanly possible and then we're going to
derive as much as we can at runtime from
that so that just makes it so that we
only have to update a small piece of
state and then we can just dynamically
get the rest
so I'm going to basically take this
method that we had defined earlier
get game status and I'm going to kind of
refactor this make it a little bit
simpler and the first thing that I'll do
here is Define our list of players this
is going to make things a lot easier for
us and I'm just going to copy in from
the completed app so we don't have to
type things out and then I'll explain
what we're doing here
so down here I think at this point I'm
going to collapse
our app because we're once again not
using this we're just using it as a
reference
so here we're going to define the
players of the game how I've decided to
represent these players is just a tuple
or an array of players and we'll just
know that the zero index is player one
and the one index is player two
now what we're doing is basically adding
some configuration here so this is a
configuration array that's saying we
have got two players this is the name of
player one they are going to be the X
icon and they're going to have a color
class of turquoise likewise player 2 O
in color of yellow so this is going to
help us with our internal logic quite a
bit and I'll show you what I mean uh
here in a second so before we even touch
the store anymore let me just pass in uh
players and then the first index so that
would represent player two obviously
this is going to break that method
because we're not expecting an object so
if we click stuff it's just not going to
work correctly
but if we go to The View
and go down to that method that we had
defined so set turn indicator
this player now represents that object
so now that we're passing an object as
the player this logic here gets a bit
simpler but the problem is if you look
at our index.html we're defining the
color on that top level which means we
have to add and remove classes so really
we would need to pass in player and then
opponent and then here what we would do
is say player dot let's see color class
and then this one would be opponent
dot color class so we're adding the
players the current players color class
and then we're removing the opponent's
color class now a bit simpler way to
handle this I know I'm kind of going
back and forth here
um but let's go back to index.html and
remove the color property from this
outer div and instead let's just
initialize the color property of this
each element Within
so to start the game out we're going to
have a yellow X for player one because
that will be o is the first player so
let's save that and then here in the
view that means that we no longer have
to remove classes
and instead of looking at the turn we
can just directly add these to the icon
so icon.class list
dot add and then we'll say player dot
color class and then label dot
um class list
will also be color class
we can remove the opponent here
and then if we come down here let's just
kind of group these icon classes
together this is where we're defining
which icon it is and rather than doing
this switch here we can just say player
dot icon class so remember we defined an
icon class and a color class on each
player so here we're adding the color
class here we're adding the icon class
and since we're doing the doing this to
the same icon we can actually combine
all of this
so we'll say f a solid
then a color class
and then an icon class and we can delete
this line so this will pass to all three
of those
then finally the label gets a color
class and then we need to update the
label inner text but instead of these
static strings once again we've made it
easy for ourselves in our configuration
so we can just say player.name
as you can see right here we've defined
a player name so we can just add some
string interpolation here
and we'll say player one
you're up
and then finally we're getting the
container and we're replacing it with
the icon in the label so now that we've
done that we should be able to uh see
this working so we don't need to pass
that opponent anymore just the player so
let's go back and click something so
this should be turquoise not yellow so
let's see what's happening here
we're passing in players index of one so
we're basically passing this object
we'll bring that over to The View
just so that we have a reference
to see what we're passing
so that's the object that is being
passed in this case
and we are grabbing the color class
which is defined as yellow and the icon
class which is O so that's our problem
our configuration object is actually
different
let's check the final implementation so
the vanilla refactor
you can see that the x is turquoise and
the O is yellow so I actually had things
backwards this whole time I apologize
the O should be yellow and the X should
be turquoise
so I think this is intended Behavior
let's delete that
and then instead of player two we'll
pass in player one
and let's see that is working a little
bit better
we've got a blue X and then if we load
by default we need to update that as
well
so this should start as turquoise
this should start is turquoise so player
one you're up
a turquoise X is that the same thing we
get here let's reset yep we get a
turquoise X so we're starting in the
right State and then as we click
something
we should be getting that to change so
let's
click for player two
and there we go we've got a yellow o
with player two text added in there
and then the last thing we can kind of
re-factor here is the handle Player move
instead of just hard coding in one we
can hard code in players at one
so we'll go back to handle Player move
and this player is now an object
so we can replace this here with player
dot icon class
and then player.color class
save that make sure our icons are going
in correctly and it looks like they are
so that is refactored that makes things
a little bit easier for us to handle and
now we can go to the store and start
defining this read-only game State
variable right now we're just returning
a dummy value which is not useful to us
but the purpose of this getter method
is to basically take the raw State
object which is just an array of game
moves and calculate all sorts of useful
information from that
you can already see we've done that
um with our get game stats right here or
get game status so the the things that
we're really doing here is checking for
a winner and then also at some point
we're going to have to figure out who's
the current move
um or who's up to play so we can
Encompass all of that within a single
method here and we're going to build
this uh kind of piece by piece until we
have something to read from so that we
can determine down here in our
controller method where we're setting
the turn indicator and handling the
player move that way we can just pass in
that derived state so that these methods
know what to actually do with the UI
so let's start out by getting the
current player so we will First grab
state
which can be read
with the get State method so this is
just a assignment we could just read
this directly but nice to have a
variable to work with here
so that is the first step and then we're
going to derive the current player with
a little trick and I believe the
original
creators of this game that I'm
refactoring here already had this little
trick and they were using it but we can
use the modulus operator to basically
determine the current player so what
that looks like is we'll say the current
player is equal to
um the list of players which we do not
have access to here but really just a
list of players and then we can grab the
index of that based on
um how many moves have been made within
the game but like I said we don't have
the list of players so one thing that we
need to do is pass that to the store so
that it has access to that
so we'll pass that array of players and
then we'll set a player's
property on the class and so that way we
can access it right here and then grab
whichever player we want so we'll put in
zero for now as a hard-coded value let's
go back to app and where we initialize
the store
since we have the list of players right
here we can just pass that array down to
the store via the Constructor so at this
point what we can do is we can say State
DOT moves dot length so that will tell
us how many moves are in this current
game
and we can use the modulus operator and
use it modulo 2 which will basically
give us either a 1 or a zero based on
the the number of moves so if we just
open up a terminal here and open up a
little playground with node.js
you can see that if we have let's say an
array of moves and let's just say it's
one two one two just to fill it up so we
currently have a moves.length of four So
based on this if player one is the
starting player then we know that player
one made this move player two made this
move one made this move and two made
this move so who's up next
well the way that we can determine that
is basically just doing moves.linked
modulo 2. and that will give us a zero
and since our players array is just two
objects the zero index is going to be
player one and the one index is going to
be player two so if we were to push a
new move to that array so let's say
player one moves now if we do
moves.length modulo two we get one which
is the index of player two so you can
see how based on the length of this
array we can quickly determine who the
current move belongs to so we'll go to
the store and we will do this operation
to get the current player and then from
there we can also derive the next player
in the game so we'll say but we actually
might not need that let's hold off on
that one for the moment
so let's go ahead and return the current
player as part of an object so we now
have that as part of our game state
and then we can come down here to the
set turn indicator and we're going to
reverse this because first we need to
actually handle the player move and I'm
going to make a variable to keep things
clear
we will say that the clicked square is
equal to the event.target because that's
what that actually represents if you go
back to the view where we are binding
that move we're just looping through the
squares and adding that event listener
listener which is going to pass the
individual Square to that Handler that
was clicked so that's what that
represents and just for clarity we can
pass it like that and then for the
current player that we want to move now
we have some game state so we can say
store Dot Game Dot currentplayer
and that should satisfy the stub of this
method so we are now passing the current
player in and at this point we need to
update some of our state because we of
course have made a move by this player
and now we want to set the turn
indicator but we don't want to set that
for the current player because they have
just moved we want to do it for the next
player so we need a way to update the
state to advance it to the next play
so the way we can do that is make a
method in store a public method called
let's see what I called it in the final
project I think I just called it Player
move and what we're doing here is
passing a square ID so that's one
through nine based on which one was
clicked and to follow our Convention of
not mutating State directly we first
need to grab state from the getter
method that we've defined right here so
we're returning that private variable
then we need to make a clone of it so
we're going to go ahead and
call that state clone and there's a
built-in method to browsers called
structured clone which you can pass an
array an object pretty much anything and
it will give you a clone of that object
so we're no longer referencing we're no
longer passing a value by reference
where we've got a completely different
object that we're able to mutate here
so from this point we can go ahead and
take the state clone and push a new move
to this array
um actually we don't want to push it
directly there because the the state
object has an array of moves but that is
a property so what we're really saying
is State clone dot moves dot push and
then we need to pass in the Square ID
right here and then also the player ID
so or not the ID we'll just pass in the
player that is currently up so that
would be state or not state but this Dot
Game remember we just derived that up
here so we can actually access that
property within the class
and we can pass it the current player so
when we call Player move it's going to
take the square ID that was clicked and
the current player that was up and push
that as a move to the state object so
that's going to actually update our
state for us
um but the last step we need to call is
this dot Save State in this case our
state object's pretty simple so we can
just pass in that literal object rather
than a callback function but we'll come
back and refactor this as we develop our
state handling a little bit further
later on so let's save that and then
back in app.js all we need to do now is
call store dot Player move
in here we just need to pass the click
square but we need to pass an ID so
really what that is is going to be dot
ID and we need to cast that to a number
because uh the event ID or the event
targets ID will come as a string by
default so we're passing in a number ID
and we're updating state so at this
point we're allowed to Now set the turn
indicator to the current player because
that has been updated with this method
so we can go back to the store.game dot
currentplayer and set the turn indicator
now the important thing to notice here
is that this store.game.current player
is a different player than this
store.game.current player and that is
because we have made a state change
happen in between the two and every time
that state changes that getter value
that we've defined right here is going
to automatically re-evaluate and update
so if all worked when we click a square
it should update things dynamically so
it says player one you're up and we
click
and now we've played with player one
with that X and you can see player 2 is
now up now we should be able to click
and we get an O and now player one is up
so now we have this working again but if
you remember from the original
implementation we had one big problem
and that's if you click twice on a
square so we need to make sure that we
are not updating a square twice and that
should be relatively simple to handle so
let me comment some things in here we
will say
um
place an icon of the current player in a
square
advance to the next state by pushing a
move to the moves array
and then
set the next players turn indicator
now up here at the top this is where we
need to check whether there's an
existing move
so you can see in our original
implementation what we did here was we
made a little helper method that says
whether a square ID has an existing move
and then we checked if that current
Target matched that and if it did we
returned early
so we can actually we could make a
helper method to do this
within the store or we could just check
it inline I'm going to go ahead and just
check this inline as you'll see in just
a second
so let's collapse the app
and let's say the existing move is going
to be equal to the store dot game
that moves dot find and so we're looking
for a specific move that has a square ID
equal to the clicked Square dot ID and
we need to make sure that that is a
number
so we're comparing the same thing
so if there's an existing move
if that's not undefined basically we're
going to return early and we're not
going to handle that Player move
save the state or set the turn indicator
let's save that and now let's play and
it looks like we've got a problem and
you can see that we're getting an error
here by reading the
store.game.moves it says that it is
undefined and that makes sense because
we have not actually added that to our
getter so let's go back to the store and
remember game is only returning the
current player so it would be nice if we
also just gave it uh the moves array
just so we have access to that
so we'll save that and now things should
work a lot better so now if we click
something twice it's actually still
messing up and I believe this is because
of the same reason we ran into earlier
that I failed to recognize once again
when we're binding to this Player move
event if you look in the view
we are basically just passing
um the event
uh to the Handler and that event could
have been an icon that was clicked so
instead of just blindly passing the
Handler right here what we really need
to do is break this out into a function
and pass the square itself that we are
setting the event listener on rather
than the event Target which was the
default that was passed
so let's update that go back and see if
that fixed things for us
Square element is undefined
we just need to make one adjustment here
it is no longer an event that's being
passed it's a square reference so this
is actually more expressive anyways so
we will check
Square
and then update these references
and hopefully finally this will work
so we're clicking clicking click it
again and it does not do anything as we
expected so now we've got a lot more
stable behavior and we're almost back to
where we started but of course we've got
a tic-tac-toe in two places and the game
has not recognized that yet and that's
because we need to once again build up
our
derived state which is in this method
right here the last piece of state that
we need to derive in this game property
or getter is who has won the game we've
already done this in our previous
implementation
we did this right here where we were
checking the player moves the winning
patterns and then checking the player
moves against those winning patterns
we were then deriving it as a status and
a winner so I'm going to do something
similar to this but we're going to
simplify just a little bit in this new
derived State method
so the first thing we'll do is copy in
those winning patterns because those are
just static and then we'll initialize
the winner to be equal to null
just to get a variable in place
and then what we're going to say is four
we're going to do a for Loop
we're going to Loop through each player
so for player of this dot players so
remember we initialized the list of
players which is just two people in the
Constructor so we can Loop through each
player and then within that Loop we can
get the selected Square IDs of that
player so we'll say this
dot game
dot moves
and remember this is just the current
state of the game so this.game.moves
or I'm sorry we should probably not do
that because we're referencing this
method from itself
so what we need to reference is this
state uh
variable right here where we're getting
the raw state so we'll say state DOT
moves and we're going to filter those
moves to only be the moves of the
current player
that we are looking at
so just walking through this logic a
little bit we've got the array of raw
state of moves and we're going to filter
out
any player that does not match the
current player in our Loop furthermore
we're going to map that resulting array
and just grab the square ID off of the
individual move so if you remember we're
pushing a square ID and a player to that
moves array so that's basically what
we're reading
off of this right here so we've got a
list of selected Square IDs for the
current user and now we're going to do
an inner loop
and we're going to say for pattern of
winning patterns
now we're going to check check if the
pattern
matches every one of those selected
Square IDs
or actually I should probably say if the
square IDs has every element of the
pattern so we'll say selected Square IDs
includes that value
and so this will check if there is a
winning pattern and if that's the case
we're going to set that winner variable
that we initialized up here to whatever
player we're in during that Loop in
other words we're going to go through
this Loop and if no winning patterns are
found the winner is going to be left
equal to null which is going to tell us
that this was a tie game
along with the status of the game so
we'll come down here and add a status
property
and we're going to say is the game
complete this is going to be true if the
winner does not equal null so if the if
there is a winner populated we know the
game's complete or if the
state.moves.length is equal to nine
because we know that that's the maximum
number of moves that can be be played in
a given game
and then finally we'll pass the winner
variable right here which will either be
null or set equal to some player
so now we have some derived State and
I'll just remind you that we are
deriving all of this information
the current player the status whether
it's complete whether there's a winner
we're driving all that off of one simple
array of game moves so that's going
along with our pattern of trying to keep
State as simple as possible and then
deriving what we need to know from it
later on dynamically now that we have
this information populated we should be
able to come back to our app.js or our
controller and this is where we will
check whether there's a winner and if
there is we're going to open up some
sort of modal
to show that status to the user if you
remember from our first implementation
we had
um let me collapse some of this stuff
we're not using
so if you remember from here at the very
bottom this is where we're checking the
game status and if the game is complete
we're going to remove the hidden class
on that modal so that it opens up
and then we're going to set a message so
we can make some utility classes or some
Dom helper methods within our view class
to achieve this so let's go back to the
view class and hook up some of those
methods we can put them pretty much
anywhere I'll just put them at the top
here the first one that we'll want is an
open modal method and we're going to
pass in a message
and what we'll do with that is select
the modal itself
and that's going to be the one that we
removed the class from
so there's the modal in our index.html
that is this entire div that's got
hidden on it so let's remove that real
quick and you can see how it pops that
up
so really what we're trying to do is
just toggle that class
in the way we'll do that
so we'll come down to our helper method
and we'll look at the class list and we
will remove
the hidden class
so very similar to what we were doing
before
so let's just try this little
um
helper out right now to make sure that
it's working and then we'll come back
and improve it with
an actual message that we can show
so we're coming down here we've set the
turn indicator for the next player
and now it's probably time to check
whether someone has won the game
so really we need to do this before we
set the turn indicator because this will
update that text up here and if the
game's over we don't really want that to
change
so here's where we check that state
we're going to say if the store dot game
dot status is complete
this is where we're going to perform
this logic and we're going to add a
return statement here because if it's
complete we know we don't want to run
this logic so we always want to return
at this point we'll call View
Dot openmodal and that should open
things up for us so let's go to the game
and play it
and see if it recognizes this winning
pattern
and it does so we see player one wins if
we click play again it's not going to do
anything because we haven't updated that
event listener
so let's refresh the game start over
and at this point we need to pass in
some a message to say who won the game
and we can go ahead and derive that
so we'll put in a variable here
or actually we should probably not do
that yet
we want to say if the store.game
dot status
dot is complete or no we already know
that dot winner
if there is a winner then we want to say
store.game.status.winner dot name
because that's a player that we're
referring to
and then we'll say wins otherwise it's
going to be Thai
so that should be the correct Logic for
opening the message in the modal
we still don't have any listener for
resetting the game but player one wins
let's reset real quick in this case
let's make sure that player 2 wins
and it's still saying that player one
has won the game so we've got a little
bit of a problem here and it's actually
not a problem I'm just getting tired and
forgetting things in our view when we're
opening the modal we have to actually
update the text within it so this dot
modal text
dot inner text is going to be equal to
the message
so let's try that again
let's make sure player 2 wins
so here we go we got player two wins
refresh and then if we have player one
wins that'll show up there so the last
thing we need to do is register an event
listener on this play again button which
will reset the game State since we're
resetting the state we need to do this
event listener outside of the view this
bind game reset event is meant to be
um
a Handler for whenever we click this
reset button but we can also overlap and
use it for when the game is complete so
not only do we want to register that on
the reset uh button we also want to
register that on the modal button
because that is going to also reset the
game and do the same exact thing
so we'll pass in the same event and the
same Handler and make sure that's hooked
up
then when we go back to app
and we go to the bind game reset event
this is what we need to now fill in
so whenever this pops up
and we have
an end State when we click this we want
everything to close and reset so one
thing we need to implement is the close
modal helper method
so right next to open modal
we'll make one that says close modal
and this will be very simple
we will just add the hidden class
this time so let's go ahead and call
that
close modal
and see if that works so we should be
bound to this button here and when we
click it it should now close the modal
which it does but you can see the state
has not reset which we want to have
happen so this is a job for the store
class
and we need to just Implement a method
let's put it under Player move and I
think I called this just reset in the
final implementation so we'll say reset
within this method we're basically going
to read
or we're going to just set the state to
be empty so we can
just call Save State and we'll set it to
the initial value
so initial value is referencing this
right here so this is basically
resetting the game now if you'll notice
we're not saving any history of past
games we'll eventually add that but for
right now we just want to get things to
reset correctly so over in app.js we are
closing the modal and then we're calling
from the store we want to reset the game
and then the one last thing we need to
do just to make sure that player one is
going to be up at the beginning of the
next game is say view dot set turn
indicator and you remember we can just
pass a player there
so we should be able to just pass
players zero because that represents
player one and we always want to reset
to player one
now another way to do this is we know
that the after we've reset the state we
know that if we access
store.game.current player
that's going to also give us player one
so that's probably a more semantic way
to do that
so let's command s to save so we're
going to close the modal reset the state
and set the next turn indicator so
everything should be cleared out at that
point the only thing that we're probably
missing is we don't have a method to
clear the game board so we're resetting
this state itself but we're not clearing
the game board so let's go to the view
and we'll say clear moves
and what we're going to do is just
look at these squares
how did I access this hold on yep so I'm
just accessing it like this so for each
Square
I just want to clear things out so
Square dot replace
children and leave that empty to
basically just clear everything out
so we need to clear the moves
after we've reset the store so view dot
clear moves and then we'll set the turn
indicator and this should pretty
sufficiently clear everything from the
state and The View
so let's refresh and play the game
player one wins and when we click play
again everything clears and player one
is going to be up
so if we do the same thing for player
two player two wins you can see player
two is up but that will reset to player
one you are up at the end
but obviously at this point we have a
working game but if we started to play
then we refresh the browser it's going
to reset
if we play and player one wins and we
click play again none of this stuff is
being tracked down here we have no
history of games of the past so if we
wanted to implement that that's going to
basically be the next phase of this
video and it's going to get into some
really cool concepts with local storage
and finally we will kind of refactor
this to be a little bit more declarative
so that we can just kind of react to all
of these State changes and render
whatever UI should be based on that
current state one last thing I wanted to
test let's make a move on the game board
and I believe we should be able to click
reset
and everything resets okay
now this does not close which we're
going to want to implement but just
wanted to show you that because we
actually indirectly implemented this
reset method when we were working on
handling a winning game and how we did
that remember when we binded to the game
reset event that is actually linked to
both the reset button and the modal
reset button so it's running the same
Handler regardless now as you saw that
doesn't close everything so in app.js
where we are closing the modal let's
refactor this to not do closed modal but
close all
and we need to implement that method
we'll put that right under close modal
and we'll say close all
and this is basically going to
um
call the close modal so we're going to
close the modal and then we want to
close the menu we currently have a
toggle menu method but we also want to
have a close menu method so this is
going to look pretty similar to this
method we're just going to say this dot
dollar sign dot menu items
and then on that class list we're going
to add hidden to make sure that it's
closed we're going to also remove the
Border
so remove the border on the menu button
because when that's closed we know that
should not be there
and then we'll reselect the icon because
we always want to make sure that that is
going to be the icon that points down
so let's just copy these two
and instead of toggle we're going to add
this one and remove this one so when we
call close menu it's just going to make
sure that everything is in its closed
state
and then we'll add that to
the close all method and at this point
we can make this close menu a private
method because that's only being called
here
we can also make closed modal it's put
that down here and make that a private
method because it's only being called
here
so now we have a helper method close all
that is being called when the game is
reset and that should clear all the
state so if we make a move open this
actions and reset
it's going to say closed modal is not a
function
and that's because we are not
referencing it from its private
declaration so now that should work
so make a move
reset that closes this resets game board
is cleared and everything is working
great so as I mentioned we're not
tracking down here the history of all
the games that have been played and we
also don't have anything happening here
when we click new round
so in order to track that we need to
update our state object
so right now this is the initial value
we're just tracking an array of moves
but really what we need to be doing is
tracking an array of moves and a history
object that has the current round gains
and that should be an array and then all
games which is just basically all the
history from
you know all the time so with this
information right here we should be able
to calculate some statistics of how many
wins each player has so just for clarity
I'm going to also update update this to
current
um or current game moves
so this will still represent the same
thing we just need to update
our references to here so current game
moves
current game moves do we have it
anywhere else
okay I think that's it so if that worked
um we should be
able to see the same functionality
things should still be working
and it looks like it is
and so now all we need to do to start
tracking this is when we reset the game
instead of just saving the state back to
the initial value we should update the
state to basically take that finished
game that we just completed push that to
the history and then start a new game
so what does that look like so to start
tracking the history here let's just
refactor a little bit right up here so
we don't really need two variables let's
just pass
get State into structured clone
and we'll just call this one state clone
so that's for the player move
and that should remain the same the
reset method is where we're really going
to do some updating in the reset method
we're going to have to check for a very
specific condition
and that is if this dot game so we're
reading that getter up here that we've
defined
um dot status is complete
if it's complete we want to push this
game that we're resetting to the history
object or the history array
and if it's not complete then we just
want to reset it totally because
remember
in the view we're adding this reset to
two different places we're adding it to
this drop down right here which could
reset the game even if it's incomplete
we're also adding it to this button
right here when the game is complete so
we need to make sure that we're checking
that before we push an incomplete game
to the history
so all we need to do is check for
um the moves we can destructure that
from this Dot Game really we should just
destructure all of this stuff
so we'll say status moves and then I
think that's it
so now we can reference status that is
complete
and we should also make a state clone
because we're not going to mutate State
directly
so in here we'll say state
clone and then remember our state now
looks like this so we can grab the
history and then current round games
array is where we want to Target this
so State clone dot history dot current
round games
and we're going to push the final game
here so I believe that would just look
like
um let's see
we probably just want to push the moves
in the status
we don't want to just push the moves
because we want a easy way to Loop
through all the history of games and see
the status on those which is that
derived state right here so we want to
kind of archive that as well now after
we get past this block this is where
we're going to look at the state clone
and set the current game moves equal to
an empty array because we want to reset
that and then instead of saving it to
the initial value we're going to State
save it to the state clone that we've
just mutated here in these two places so
at this point if we've done everything
correctly here we should be able to add
a new getter so we've got the current
game and then let's also make a stat
skidder so this will be responsible for
getting us the total number of wins by
player
and to start us off let's just console
log this Dot
um
get state
so we'll go back to our game let's play
at least one round
and reset and so right there that should
have pushed
um a few or it should have pushed a game
to history and since we're not actually
calling this anywhere it's not showing
up
um so we need to call that somewhere
we'll just call it at the end of the
game reset so console log store dot
stats
we'll remove that in just a second but
let's play one more game so I think
player one should have two wins at this
point when we reset so you can see in
history we have current round games is
an array
of one and it shows all the moves from
that game and then the status
showing that the winner was player one
and if we play this again I'm hoping
things will update correctly
yep so now in history we have two games
in history so if we keep playing these
that's basically what's going to happen
so at this point player one has won
three games and you can retrieve all of
those in history right here
so now our job is to go back to the
stats method on our store class and
actually derive some useful state that
we can use to update those that
scoreboard down here at the bottom so
what I want to return from this it
should be pretty simple so player with
stats
um what I'm going to do here is map
through the players array which remember
we initialized the Constructor with
players and then assigned that as a
property of the class
so we have that and we can map through
and look at each player
and then all we're going to do is add
whether they have a win
or add how many wins they have so we'll
calculate wins by looking at the current
state so this Dot Game or I'm sorry not
this dot game but we will look at the
history so we need to grab
the current state which is this Dot
oops
get state
so we'll say state DOT history we're
looking in the history of the current
round games
and we're going to filter that
and we're going to look at the game
and check for the status
of that and see if there's a winner and
if there's a winner we'll use a
an operator here that JavaScript has
available to basically coalesce any
undefined values uh when we're accessing
this property
so we can pass ID and check if that's
equal to the current player.id so we're
checking the player we're mapping
through against the game status of the
current game we're mapping and at the
end of that we should be able to get the
length of that array so that will give
us the number of wins that this player
has we will then from this map
function we will then spread the player
object
to this object and then we'll pass the
number of wins so essentially this is
giving us a list of players where it has
this additional property called wins
that will tell tell us later how many
wins that player has
furthermore we then have ties and that
one's pretty easy we'll just look
through the history again
and this time we're going to filter it
for games where the game.status dot
winner is equal to null so that will
tell us when we have a tie if there's no
winner
and we'll give it the length there as
well so now when we read the stats
object we should be getting a much
different picture so let's go ahead and
play another game
and now we've got the stats object we've
got player with stats and you can see
that's an array of two players and if we
open up those players we get all of
their attributes of course and then we
also get how many wins that they've had
so far in history we get the ties is
equal to zero and you can all already
see that we can basically take this
information and just update the HTML to
show that in these three boxes down here
so populating these will be relatively
quick I think
we just need to go to view
and make one more helper method I'll
just keep putting it here at the top
let's go ahead and say update scoreboard
is the method that we're going to use
and I think we might need to put a data
ID on some of these
yep so I'm going to put a data ID
and we're going to call this one uh
player one
scoreboard
or let's let's actually just make it
shorter P1 wins
so we'll copy that one down
to player two so P2 wins and then we
already have a data ID because I guess I
forgot to pull that out during our HTML
build so that's already there for ties
so if we go to our view
we just need to select these elements
um
we could just do it in this method we
really could do all this in that method
I just like to consolidate stuff up here
so we're going to select the player one
wins and this is going to be selected
P1 wins let's make sure that's right
okay
then let's copy that down
player two wins
and then ties
and then now we have these three
elements to work with
so we can update the scoreboard by
saying this dot dollar sign that player
one wins
and we'll set the inner text
equal to
and then we'll get the number there and
we'll say that number of wins
so that'll be this dot game I'm sorry
this dot stats
nope never mind we are in the view I was
gotta gotta be careful where you're
putting stuff we don't have access to
that information yet so we're just going
to pass that information directly to the
method so player one wins player two
wins and ties
so we'll just pass that in and then
we'll take care of actually getting
these values into this method later
okay so that method should update the
scoreboard
we just need to call it
from somewhere
so just checking looks good so we just
need to call that from somewhere and I
think the best place to do that at the
moment is to do it in the game reset
event because that's the only place that
we are actually
cataloging the end of the game
so after we have set the turn indicator
we're going to call from The View
to update the scoreboard and at this
point we're going to pass in store dot
stats Dot
player with stats
we're going to select the first player
and pass the number of wins
we'll do the same thing
for player two
and then finally
with the ties
we can get rid of this console log
and hopefully if that worked correctly
this will update things and our game
will be sort of done
we've gotten error it says it cannot
find elements and that's because we did
not save the index.html
so now it's finding it
and you can see player one has one win
player two to win one
there's a win and then if we can somehow
get a tie going here
um
I guess that one's not gonna work
ah I can't get a tie going so we got
player two with three wins player one
with one win so that is the current
history now the very last thing that we
need to do
um when we reset right here it's not
going to clear any of this the only
thing that's going to clear this
scoreboard is the new round so we need
to implement that method
and let's go ahead and do that in the
store first because
that's pretty close to the reset
so we'll say new round
and what we want to do with the new
round is basically take all of the games
that are in the current round games and
push them to this all games array and
we're basically going to clear out this
one and clear this one so one way that
we can do that
since we know that a new round is going
to also be a reset
what we can first do is call this dot
reset so that will take any completed
games put them into the current round
games in clear everything out
and after we've reset we need a state
clone because we can't update State
directly just to best practice as we
talked about
and what we're going to do is take the
state clone
grab the history
and we're going to populate the all
games
um
with the most recent current round games
so one quick way that we can do this
because this is going to be an array is
we can spread that out to the push
method so State clone dot history dot
current round games so that will just
push that to all games and then at last
we will take
that current round games and set that to
an empty array
and then finally we will save the state
pass in that state clone that we have
modified
now there's one thing that's going to be
messed up
and it's probably not super apparent so
if we go through and play some games
and then we go and reset everything
let me see
and at this point we really just need to
hook this up
to the view so we have bound the new
round event
and in app.js we just have a placeholder
here
so what we need to do is basically call
the store
call for a new round and then I think
we'll want to clear everything so
similar to the the reset we'll want to
close everything
we will want to clear the moves so this
is the UI not the store
we'll want to set the turn indicator
and then we'll want to update the
scoreboard
so this call actually needs to go first
so that the state is updated and then
all of these will read from that state
to appropriately populate the um the UI
so let's go try this
we've got so far
um let's populate some state
so player one has two wins if we click
something and reset it'll just clear the
board but keep this if we go and hit new
round you can see that it clears
everything and now the scoreboard is
also cleared
so at this point we have a fully
functioning game and everything works
everything's being updated
the last thing that we're going to look
at here is persisting State across
refreshes as you can see if we play a
game
and you get player one having one win
and then you refresh the page this is
all cleared out and ideally we would
want to be able to refresh the page and
still keep a record of the games in
history and the only way that we can
really do that is by using local storage
now to make our game more persistent
across browser refreshes and
additionally to allow two users to
basically play at the same time in
different browser tabs we can use local
storage so if we go to the documentation
for local storage
you can see that it is a property of the
window interface allows you to access a
storage object for the document's origin
so it's similar to session storage
except that while local storage data has
no expiration session storage data gets
cleared when the page session ends that
is when the page is closed local storage
does not do that so you can actually
close the page entirely and reopen it it
will still be there so it's just a
little bit more persistent and it's also
available across browser tabs so if we
go to the event reference let me see if
I can find that
let's click on storage Maybe
and then look at storage event alright
so this is what we're looking for in
Wool eventually implement this but the
storage event is implemented by or the
storage event interface is implemented
by the storage event which is
sent to a window when a storage area the
window has access to is changed within
the context of another document
that is a long way of saying that
basically you can add an event listener
on the window for this storage event and
if you have one tab sitting open
with our tic-tac-toe game and a player
is clicking in it then that's going to
trigger this event and you can have
another tab listening for this event and
it will recognize when that player has
played in a different tab so that will
allow us to sync the two tabs together
and allow us to basically have two
players in simulate a more realistic
game so we're going to implement local
storage but as we know with local
storage you need a key so we will
Implement that but first let's get rid
of our previous app we can finally hit
the delete button on that because
everything's working in our refactor
everything's a lot cleaner
and now it's time to go over to the
store
and in the Constructor to this store
rather than just passing players we're
going to also pass a key
and this key is going to represent the
key of local storage that we're going to
actually keep the data so if we go to
storage and we go to the local storage
right there you'll see I've already
populated this because it's happening in
the the finished game over here
but the key is what's going to be
referenced to get it and save it and
then here's all the game state that
we're tracking so let's go ahead and go
back to our app and we will give this a
special key so in app.js where we
initialize
the store right here we'll say live
um
tic-tac-toe so T3
storage key it could literally be
anything
so we're passing that key and now what
we need to do is save that so we'll say
this dot storage key is equal to key
and then this dot players is equal to
players so that should be working and
then the last thing that we need to
actually do is go down to our get get
State and save State and now instead of
saving this in memory on a property of
the class instance we're going to
replace this with local storage
so that's why as I was talking about
earlier this seemed a little redundant
why would we access this through another
method well it's so that we can refactor
it to this a lot easier so we'll get rid
of that instance property and in the get
State this is where we're going to
retrieve from local storage but as we
know uh if the local storage is empty
it's going to give us undefined so
remember at the top we have this initial
value and that's go that's what will
return if there's nothing found within
local storage for that key
so what we'll do is we'll first try to
grab an item and we'll say window dot
local storage
dot get item that's a built-in method
and then we will pass the storage key
that we initialized in the Constructor
of this class
so this is going to return us either
undefined or the string representation
of this value so basically what we're
going to return here is we're going to
say if we have found an item that is
defined we're going to parse it
because it's a string
otherwise we're going to return the
initial value as a JavaScript object so
in other words we're going to return the
same type we're just falling back to
this value so that's the get State
implementation
and then for the Save State we'll
replace this call down here and we will
say
window.localstorage that's set item
and this is going to
um
be the storage key
and then we need to actually do the
opposite of
json.parse and we need to stringify our
object so you can see here this is where
we're storing the new state after we've
saved it so we can just pass that raw
object right here
and that should persist things to local
storage just fine
let's go back to our game and see if
things are working better
so we'll play the game
player one wins
you can see it's tracked down here in
the scoreboard let's get player 2 to win
a game
that's tracked down here and now for the
the big tell all let's refresh the
browser
when we refresh the browser it looks
like there's zero wins but in reality
we're actually tracking this state we
just have one big problem here and that
problem is that on the initialization of
the page
so let's go to our app at the bottom
when we were waiting for the load event
we are not actually updating the Dom
with the latest state so you can see in
the reset we the reset and the new round
we're calling all of these changes to
the view well we really need to call
this on the first load of the page as
well and as you can see we're repeating
things quite a lot so it would be best
to put this in a little helper method
so we'll say init View
we can put that right there
and basically when we init The View
let's make sure everything's closed
let's clear all the moves
let's set the turn indicator to whatever
the current player is in state and that
state value is now coming from local
storage so we have
we have some
things that we need to update in
addition to this in a second
so last we'll update the scoreboard to
be the current stats
and now we can basically call this down
here in the reset
so we can get rid of all this
and a knit View
after we've reset the store
so that's just a little helper method
for us let's check to make sure we
didn't break anything
so we'll play in the game someone wins
and we reset so it looks like everything
worked now we've got two wins for player
one one win for player two and if we
refresh the page still nothing is going
to happen but if we go down to
[Music]
um
basically if we call this a knit View
from the scope of the init method then
that's going to populate things because
we're doing that on page load so now the
next time we refresh we're gonna stick
with those two wins and one wins we can
refresh it as many times as we want it's
O is going to end up in the same thing
but we have one last problem to to
Really solve here and that is what
happens if there's like three moves on
the game board when we refresh the page
it's going to clear that but you can see
in state player 2 is up not player one
so we need a way to actually reconstruct
the moves that have been made on the
game board on the initialization of the
page so if you remember from our view we
had some helper methods and one of those
helper methods was handle a Player move
and what that does is creates an icon
and it replaces the square that that
belongs in and all you have to do is
pass it the square element that you want
to replace
so one thing that we could do is we
could Loop through all the squares and
basically update it in state so we
really need to implement this method
so initialize
moves
and what we're going to be doing is
calling this
dot squares
so let's take a look at a previous
implementation
so we're clearing the moves here so
let's let's move this
up closer to that because it kind of
relates
so when we're clearing the moves we're
just replacing children like that but
when we're adding the moves
we need to go through each Square
and we basically need to check if
there's an existing move in state so
this needs to pass a moves array of the
current game moves and then what we'll
do is we'll check moves dot find
and we'll look on that move for a square
ID
that is equal to the square dot ID
which is what We're looping through
right here
and if there is an existing move
we're going to call this dot handle
Player move and now we can pass in the
square and then we can pass in the
player that made the move which is going
to be the existing move dot player
so that should initialize the moves
let's go back to our app and right after
we init The View
um we want to call view dot initialize
moves and these seem pretty similar but
um when we init the view in the reset we
don't want to
actually it should be okay because the
state would be cleared so let's go ahead
and put that as as the last
method here
so we'll reinitialize the moves and
since we've cleared the moves right here
um or I'm sorry not not because of that
but in the reset event we're resetting
the store or new round on the store so
that should clear all the current moves
and this will basically be an empty call
because it's not going to find any
existing elements
so let's go ahead and save that
and let's refresh the page
looks like we've broken something
moves is undefined
oh because I haven't passed in the
current state
so we cannot just call this with an
empty
function call we need to pass in the
store.game
dot moves and now you can see that it's
initialized so no matter how how many
times we refresh it's always going to
reconstruct the latest moves of the game
let's reset that so it resets up here
and now we refresh and it's empty let's
put a play down here
refresh keeps that there and you can see
how we can just
recreate the state every single time so
let's set this to a new round which
clears everything including the
scoreboard and just play through one
more time player one wins
player 2 wins got one win on each side
and then Place something there refresh
reset
refresh everything looks like it's
working great now the real test as I
talked about earlier is we should be
able to play this in two separate tabs
so let me copy this URL and paste it
here so we are now looking at the same
exact game running
but if we update in this tab and put an
X there and then go to this tab you will
not see it update and that's going to
cause all sorts of problems because when
we click here
it's really going to be out of sync with
the other Tab and you don't really have
a way to play this game
we have a pretty quick way to fix this
as I mentioned with this storage event
we just need to go to the app.js and in
our initialization we can just listen
for that event
so let's go ahead
let's find a good spot for that
so right here this is where we're
listening for The View events we're
knitting initializing The View here
let's put this at the very top
or actually let's put it right here next
to a net View
so we'll say window dot add event
listener
and we're listening for the storage
event
so this is when the other tab updates
it's not when the current tab updates
where the other tab updates we'll put a
console log in here we'll say State
changed from another tab
let's just see what that looks like
first
okay so we
click and go to the other Tab and you
can see the state change from another
tab we'll click here and then see that
state change from another tab over here
so basically every time the opposite tab
changes you'll get this event fired
we'll leave that there and what we
basically need to do is when that
happens we need to initialize the view
again
so we're initializing The View on the
first page load and we're initializing
The View when the storage changes
let's go back refresh the page and like
reset everything
so we'll make a move let's first look at
this board this is empty this tab is
empty and if we make a move in the top
left corner what I would expect now is
that we'll get a console log on this tab
and we'll also see this x recreated
and you can see when I clicked there we
got it let's put an o in the bottom
right
and you'll see when I clicked over to
this tab it showed up here and we got
that console log so that's just a cool
little trick so that you can play in
multiple tabs now the last thing that I
want to do before we
go into the optional typescript refactor
that's totally optional this has been
obviously a long enough video at this
point but hopefully you've learned a lot
and maybe give a subscribe to the
channel or something
um but if you're still here we're going
to now kind of connect some dots
if you have not used react you've
probably heard of it and react is what
they call a reactive UI framework
although that is only partially true if
you really look under the hood
but the idea the overarching idea is
that in react you program declaratively
I have a blog post on my website so
let's go to my website
and go search for some Concepts
and I've written about imperative versus
declarative programming and if you come
down to the middle of this you'll see a
section called react declarative versus
jQuery imperative
so far what we have done is been
programming imperatively in other words
what that means you can go ahead and
read over these examples but I'm about
to explain it here in this video
when we program imperatively that means
that we are saying okay here's the
outcome that I want and here are the
seven different steps that you have to
take to get to that outcome now
declarative programming
is basically saying here's the outcome I
want go figure out how to make that
happen and I think I have an example in
this blog post about building a house
imperatively versus declaratively so if
you're doing this imperatively you're
going to specify the steps you build the
foundation you put in the framework
install the utilities add the walls
finishing touches so on and so forth
if you're building a house declaratively
the only step is basically saying I
don't care how you build it but I want a
nice fireplace a Lakefront View and a
big kitchen so these are the outcomes
that you are declaring that you want and
you let the Builder of that house
determine the best way to make that
happen
so the same thing happens with the react
Library some people would call it a
framework even
react is basically looking at the state
of your application and based on that
state and based on The View that you
have defined that links that state it's
going to figure out how to render the
page to the screen
and if we look back at our program
we have a lot of imperative stuff going
on
so we are binding to all of these
different clicks so when when these
buttons are clicked we have a lot of
very explicit steps written out of how
we want the UI and this state to
actually update now we can do a rather
small it's not going to be huge refactor
where we can basically take all of these
individual steps and we can wrap them in
a render method from there then the idea
is that the render method is all that
you need to call on The View and then
you need to pass the state of the
application so remember the store
gives us that state of the game
um the game right here and then the
stats so that's basically our state and
all we need to do is pass all of that
information to the Views render method
and then we can basically Define all
those steps to figure out how to show
the page to the user
so let's try to do that I think this
will be
um a really nice way to clean this thing
up for once and for all and will kind of
get us to our final state of this
application finally believe it or not
this init view method actually
represents a lot of what we're trying to
do
so we will be copying a lot of this
stuff so let's make this a little
smaller open up the view over here to
the right
actually we'll make it a little bigger
that's kind of tough to see so now that
I've you know talked about all this
stuff in the render method basically
what we can do at this point is we can
put a hashtag in front of pretty much
all of these methods because they're all
going to be called from within the
render method
so these are all internal implementation
details of our view class and nobody
needs to know about them except for the
view itself
so you can think of all of these methods
as basically just Dom helpers that we're
going to call from the main render
method so these event listeners are
going to be public methods that can be
called from the app or the controller
and then we will have one render method
here at the top
so we're going to call that render
nothing significant about this name
necessarily other than convention this
is generally what you would call it in
when react was using class-based
components that was the method that you
had to put all of your jsx into and
whatnot so this is more of a convention
naming convention than anything
so what we're going to pass into this is
the store itself
in that store as we know has those
getter methods on it
but I'm going to be more explicit
actually I want to pass the game and the
stats you could pass the entire store
object and I think maybe in the final
implementation that's what I've done but
we'll be explicit with this so that we
know exactly what we're dealing with so
in other words the game and the stats
are represented by this method stats in
this method the game and based on this
information we should be able to build
our UI entirely so let's start building
this up the first thing that we know
needs to happen no matter what no matter
what the state of this application we
know that we want to populate this
scoreboard based on the current state of
the game
so that'll be the first thing we'll do
we'll call this dot update scoreboard
and we have to pass in player one wins
player two wins and number of ties and
as we know we have all of that state
available to the render method so we'll
come back to app.js and you can see this
is where we're extracting that stuff
but we can actually do some
destructuring to make this a little
easier to deal with
so from the stats
we can grab the
player with stats
and the ties and then from the game what
can we grab we can grab
let's take a look
we can grab moves the current player
and the status which we can also
destructure that is complete
and the winner property so that's from
the game
so all of these this is just
destructuring with es6 to get these
variable references so we don't have to
Define all of them or have this you know
nested
object property access going on
so with the update scoreboard let's go
back to our app and see how we did that
we basically basically just looked at
the stats
dot player with stats so this will be
the first player
and we're finding the first player's
number of wins
player with stats one so that would be
the second player their wins and then
the ties will pass straight into that
so right there we are rendering
rendering the scoreboard and we can go
ahead and start pulling all of this
initialize functionality out of this
method
so we can remove this
or actually we're going to replace a
knit View
with view.render
and this is where we're going to pass
the store dot game in store.stats
we will also pass this right here to
that storage event listener
and now we can
also pass it down here
in these event listeners
so let's save that
and let's go back to our app
and refresh the page and you can see
that at least the scoreboard has been
updated because we implemented that one
method within render so the next thing
that we need to do
um let's see is probably reconstruct the
game board
we can really just follow this init view
so
we're updating the scoreboard we need to
close everything and clear the moves so
let's let's actually put that right
above this
so this
Dot close all
this dot clear
all the moves we're going to update the
scoreboard
then we're going to initialize the moves
so that's going to cover a lot of ground
just there
we need to set the turn indicator I
missed that one
so that one will come right here
and that one takes a player so we need
to pass in the current player that we're
grabbing from the state
so that will grab the current player and
set that
so now if we refresh and go back
we should see a good amount of stuff
being updated
I don't think we'll be able to play
quite yet and we've got a moves is
undefined and once again I've forgotten
to pass the correct data to this
so we need to pass the moves
from here down to the initialize method
let's make sure we're not missing
anything here
okay we'll save that
and right now we can't click anything
because we have removed all of the
functionality from the main app but we
can get rid of this
we'll keep this event listener because
that's going to listen for changes on a
different tab
this is our initialization where on the
first page load it's going to render The
View
then on each of our
reset and new round events we're going
to update the store and then render the
new view
our last thing to handle is that click
event that happens on each Square so I
think this logic can stay because this
is just a check
against the state and it's going to
return early if it finds there's an
existing move on the Square so that's
not view related at all
but right here we are handling the
player move
which
um
this should be covered every time we
call render
because all we have to do now is update
the state and then the render method
will then figure out how to recreate the
moves that the next state represents
so we can actually comment this out we
can also comment out the player move
I believe or I'm sorry we should not do
that this is where we are updating State
this is very important we need to update
state with that Player move so that the
render method gets the latest version of
the state to actually recreate the game
with
so we can remove this view.handle Player
move
this is fine
then we check if the game is complete
and if it is we'll open the modal but we
can actually do this check within the
render method
so let's see where's the best place to
do that though so we've we're closing
everything clear and move send the turn
indicator
update the scoreboard so we can really
just do this at the end so we're really
just checking to see if the status
Let's see we can just grab that Inc is
complete
variable that we've destructured so if
everything is complete the game's
complete we will call this
dot open modal
and then from there we will grab the
winner and check if there's a winner and
if there is we will pass in this string
otherwise we will pass in a tie
so this check right here basically takes
care of all of this
right here and then at the end we're
setting the turn indicator so maybe we
should bring this one down to the very
end of this render method because we
don't want to set the turn indicator
until
um we know that the game is
not complete so we're going to return
early if we see that the game is
complete okay so I think we can remove
all of this
from our method so at this point the
player move event is really just
checking State and updating it so we're
checking for an existing move if we find
it we're not going to do anything with
the UI we're not going to re-render it
if that doesn't if there is not an
existing move that means it's a valid
play
and we're going to update state by
making a Player move and then once we
have updated State we can render The
View with the new state
that we have retrieved
let's go back to our game
it says this dot handle Player move is
not a function so let's figure out where
we're trying to call that
I believe that's happening in the
initialize moves
yep so right here we just need since we
made this a private method we just need
to add that hashtag so that it can
handle the player move just like this
let's go back see if we got any errors
and it looks like things are being
populated so let's try to play
again
all right so when it detected a win it
says the store is not defined
so we're referencing something here in
incorrectly
oh okay so over here
in the render method you can see I'm
grabbing the winner name from the store
except that's not available to us we
really just need to grab this value
right here so we can get rid of all this
and just grab winner.name
and so now we don't have any invalid
references
and it looks like player one wins so we
can play again and it clears things
to play through the game once more
and you can see player one is racking up
the wins here we can reset to a new
round
that works
we can reset the game board that seems
to work
and I think we should see everything
populating across these two tabs which
appears to be the case so that is also
working
I know it's been a complete Marathon
here
um but we just have two more things to
improve on this application and I think
they're just really cool additions to
this app
um the first one is somewhat easy to
grasp the second one is maybe not so
easy so you can feel free to kind of
skip over
either of these but I wanted to add them
in as a supplement to this video
as you can see in our app.js
we are calling view.render
in a lot of different places
so you can see we're calling this like
what five six times five times
there's probably an easier way to do
this and one thing that we can do is go
back to our store class
and make one little update to this and
it will make our lives a lot easier and
automate a lot
so right now this is just a plain es6
class
but if we put the keyword extends we can
extend an event Target
so if we go and look on mdn
for event Target
you can look and see that this is an
interface that's implemented by objects
that can receive events and may have
listeners for them in other words any
Target of events implements the three
methods associated with this interface
and if you look at the instance methods
we have add event listener remove event
listener and dispatch event
this is basically what we've been doing
with all of our elements and by default
all of these Dom elements are going to
inherit
this class from this class so
we can also create a store that extends
this in that way we can send a custom
event every time that store changes
so
the first thing we need to do
is
and I'm sorry I think I extended The
View which is I'm getting tired here
let's remove this from The View and
instead we're putting this on store
so this becomes an event Target and then
at the top of the Constructor we just
need to call Super and super is the
keyword that will basically allow us to
inherit from this event Target so this
is kind of some object-oriented
programming Concepts but in other words
once we add super we should be able to
get access to those three methods so
let's comment out super and go to app.js
and go to store
um let's see
it says that we can add event add an
event listener but I think that's
probably just
confused let's reload
oh I'm sorry that's because we we called
super there but we need to remove this
so if we remove this for one second and
then go to store you're going to see
that we these are the available
properties in methods and you don't see
ad event listener anywhere because vs
code has not detected that as part of
the interface
but the second we add this back and
extend the event Target
and then call Super
we will now have access to an event
listener and we want to listen to a
specific event
and this event we're going to Define as
a state change
so we'll say State change is the custom
event we're going to be listening for
and then in the Callback to that
we're going to render The View
so we'll render The View with the
store.game and store.stats
and that will allow us to basically
remove the view.render from pretty much
all of these
so we can remove it from here because
when we call store.reset that's going to
trigger this event and it's going to
call view.render
we can remove it from here same thing
we're updating the store so it's going
to trigger this event
and then finally down here we are
updating the store so it will trigger
that event
as we stand right now it's not going to
do anything because we haven't actually
dispatched any sort of event but since
we've Consolidated everything into the
Save State method we know that this is
the only place in the entire class where
state is actually being updated
so if we come down to the set item call
for local storage all we have to do is
call this which represents the store
which extends an event emitter which has
these properties available
we can dispatch an event
and what we can do is pass a new event
so event right here is just
let's go to the reference
let me just type this in mdn event
so the event interface represents an
event which takes place in the Dom an
event can be triggered by the user
action clicking the mouse blah blah blah
and you can basically customize this
with whatever method you want so let's
look at the Constructor
the event Constructor creates a new
event object and you can pass a type to
it which is a string with the name of
the event so that's what we're doing and
we're calling it State change
so when state has changed we're going to
dispatch this new event
and therefore our event listener for the
state change key is going to be fired
and we're going to render The View
now of course we need to keep
view.render in this event listener
because that's not going to be fired
here these are two very separate events
this one is when the current tab State
changes
and this is when a different tab
State changes
and then finally this one
is the first
load of the document
so let's save this and see if things are
working correctly
so we refresh it looks like we've got a
problem
[Music]
I don't know what happened it looks like
our live server timed out or something
so let's refresh that page
reset the game and you can see on all of
these actions that we're clicking
it's re-rendering the page so clicking
all these actions player one wins we
play again it resets we get a scoreboard
update
and let's keep playing player one wins
again and now we can reset the game
we can reset the round and then if we
click here we can see that populated in
the other tab actually we cannot
says must call Super Constructor before
using this in the derived class
Constructor
let's see what that's all about
okay I think that might have just been
old
I just needed to refresh
yeah okay that was just old that was
from when live server cut out so now
things are being kept in sync and we can
play from multiple tabs
so let's win the game from this tab
player 2 wins and we should see over in
this tab the same message
when we reset
this is reset as well so at this point
everything is pretty much complete
um there's just one helper method that
we can refactor that will make things a
little more performant and I'm going to
just plug this in and you can kind of
study it on your own time
so let's go ahead and look at the view
so I'm going back to the view here and
at the very bottom
I'm going to add something called
delegate
now this is a pattern that I did not
come up with on my own this kind of a
well-known pattern when you're working
with the Dom and the purpose of this
helper method is so that we don't have
to do what we're doing up here and that
is looping through each of the squares
um not that not those specifically
but right here where we're binding an
event listener to every single Square
element
this results in a lot of event listeners
and it's a little bit more performant
and efficient to just register an event
listener on the parent element and then
we can kind of match match up which
child element was clicked on that event
and figure out which Square we're
dealing with for this so if we look at
the index.html you can see that we have
this entire grid
and then we have these squares so
wouldn't it be nice if we could just
register an event listener on this grid
and then we can basically figure out
which element was clicked within it
um based on that you know helper method
so we can go back to view and instead of
doing this dot squares for each
we can just call this dot delegate
and the element that we pass is going to
be this dot dollar sign dot grid
let's see if we've selected that
it looks like we have not
so we'll say this dot dollar sign dot
grid
and we will select
the data ID of grid let's make sure that
we add that right here
so now we're adding the event listener
to this parent div
the selector that we're looking for
is going to be a class called Square or
a data ID called Square so this will be
a little bit more stable
so we'll use that
so we'll just grab an example here
and then pass this as a square
and then the event that we're listening
to is a click event in the Handler is
going to be
handled by the controller
so instead of looping through all of
them adding an event listener to each
we're just going to do it once with the
delegate method
and I believe this should work for us
let's go back to app.js
and just get a sense of what's being
passed here
so console log Square
and when we click
it's going to give us a div with an ID
equal to the square that we have clicked
so as we're clicking through this
everything works just the same and that
little refactor just made things a
little bit more performant and we're
using kind of a pattern that you'll see
quite often is kind of the main reason I
wanted to expose it here is you'll see
this out in the wild and it's just good
to know kind of what it's trying to
achieve all right so there you have it
we've got a tic-tac-toe game that is
working and most importantly we learned
a lot along the way so if you're looking
for some next steps
um to kind of continue Connecting the
Dots here I'm going to be creating a
couple more videos that kind of play
along from this original build so put in
the work to get this built and now I
promised what we would do at the end of
this video is refactor this with
typescript which is a pretty popular
superset of JavaScript that a lot of
employers are looking for at the moment
here in early 2023
but I realized that this is kind of a
diverging concept from what we've just
worked on so I thought it deserved its
own Standalone video so I will link in
the description to that video and then
after that we will actually do a
refactor to react so how do we take this
vanilla game and make it into a react
app and then the last video there I'm
hoping to do the same thing and take the
vanilla react app and make it into
typescript so I made a video where I
refactored subscribers code and we
worked on this tic-tac-toe game and we
built this in vanilla JavaScript it took
us quite a while because I went through
a lot of uh different concepts and
patterns to build this out but now it's
time to refactor this to typescript and
the question is why am I doing this what
is the point of using typescript in the
first place so this video is going to be
a refactor where we take a vanilla
JavaScript tic-tac-toe game and we
refactor it to use typescript and along
the way I'm going to explain and point
out why typescript is so helpful and why
so many employers look for this skill in
developers let me start by saying that
this video is specifically Geared for
people who either have not used
typescript and are trying to understand
what the hype is about or are just a
beginner developer you're looking to
land a job and you're trying to
understand what that path to getting
that job looks like and I can assure you
there are many companies out there using
typescript today I write it in my
day-to-day job and it's an awesome thing
if you learn how to use it correctly so
with that said we're going to just jump
into this video I recommend that if you
want the most out of this video you
should probably watch the original build
so like I said we built or we refactored
some subscriber code and built this
tic-tac-toe game and took several hours
so I know it's it's a bit of a pain to
go re-watch all of that but this is
going to be a much clearer video if you
have that background and you understand
the steps that we took to get here at
the very very least be sure to go to my
GitHub repository I've linked to it in
the video description
um but let me just show you the one that
I'm talking about here
um so let's go nope that's not the right
one
so tic-tac-toe subscriber refactor at
the very very least you need to go
through and open up this vanilla
refactor and then read through all of
the code here okay and we have a second
branch called typescript which this is
the final version of the video that I'm
doing right now so we're going to head
towards this right here and we're going
to start with the vanilla JavaScript
so without further Ado let's jump in and
get this refactored to typescript all
right so the first thing I'm going to do
is just copy this entire folder
um so let's see
paste
all right and then we're going to call
this a uh typescript
actually let's say live
TS refactor
okay so here forget about this for one
second we'll get to that that's very
important for this refactor it was just
in my git ignore so just to overview
we've got an index.html file that's got
some Styles and it has this script down
here that connects to these the App
Store and Views so the MVC pattern that
we talked about in that prior video once
again Linked In the video description
and here's the CSS file nothing crazy
going on here like I said you need to be
familiar with this application because
I'm not going to explain uh it in any
detail here so the question is if you
want to move towards a typescript code
base and you've got a vanilla JS code
base to start with how do you go about
migrating it if you are dealing with a
very large vanilla JavaScript code base
this is not the video to teach you how
to migrate that this video is basically
going to walk you through the the most
simple steps the initial setup of a
typescript app
so the first thing that we need to do
and to understand is that when we're
writing typescript we will now need
developer dependencies so talking about
like a package.json if you notice in our
original build we don't have a package
Json or node modules or anything like
that because we don't need them we can
just write uh vanilla JavaScript es6
syntax and run that directly in the
browser so there's no developer
dependencies there's no build steps
transpiling any of that stuff
so the biggest thing you need to
understand to start out is that we need
some dependencies and the dependency we
need is typescript
um itself as well as the typescript
compiler now I'll be honest I don't set
up uh blank typescript projects from
scratch every day it's not a very common
thing because once you get your stuff
set up you don't really think about it
so I'm going to imagine that you know
you're starting from scratch trying to
figure out how to get this started and
we're going to just use documentation to
get ourselves there so let's go to the
typescript documentation this is the
first place that you would obviously go
to figure this out
so there's a get started a handbook and
a reference these are going to come in
once you're kind of well into things the
get started is where we want to start
so let's go ahead and look maybe
typescript Tooling in five minutes looks
like a good starting place so if we look
at this page it's going to tell us how
to get started so we can install
typescript in two main ways through npm
or yarn or pnpm or whatever we're using
or by installing the visual studio
plugins now I believe this is talking
about Visual Studio the full on IDE not
necessarily Visual Studio code I think
there's a there's a big difference
between those two we'll get to that
though and it says you can install it
just like this
but what I want to find out vs code
typescript let's see how it pairs with
Visual Studio code which is what we are
using here
it says you know typescript is a
superset of JavaScript blah blah
and it says it comes with the language
support but it does not come with the
TSC or typescript compiler so just
zooming out for a second remember
typescript is a superset of JavaScript
it does not natively run in any browser
in other words you have a build step
um or not not necessarily a build step
but a compile step where you have to
transpile that typescript syntax to
plain JavaScript and once it's compiled
to plain JavaScript then it can run in a
browser so that's kind of our goal here
and to do that we need the typescript
compiler or TSC
so here it's telling us to do the same
thing as over here so if we go back to
visual studio code I am using the yarn
package manager you can also use npm but
we'll just say yarn Global add this is
the same as npm G or npm install Dash G
and I'm going to add typescript and I
already have it installed but it will
install the latest version and there's
the compiler and then the TS server as
well now Visual Studio code I believe
comes with this server so if you hit
command p and you hit the little carrot
and then type
typescript let's see
uh it's not going to show up quite yet
because we don't have a typescript file
open so let's just try something here
Okay so we've created a TS file and just
I've added a basic type just to fill
something up and what you'll see down
here in the the bottom right is that vs
code has detected that we're using
typescript and it's kind of kicked off
the TS server I believe that's how it
works uh leave a comment if I'm wrong on
that but if we hit command p and then
type a little carrot you can see that we
can search for typescript and restart
the TS server or reload the project so
just know that in the background
typescript vs code is working and
actively looking through your code and
recognizing the different types that are
added so let's go back to the
documentation it says building your
first typescript file
and it's giving you basic typescript and
then it's saying you can compile it by
passing the file name to the typescript
compiler
and then I think it just goes through
some like basic introduction to
typescript which this tutorial is not
going to be necessarily an introduction
to typescript but more of a like why
would I need typescript and what does it
solve for me so it'll be a light
introduction but we're not going to
really get into the meat of of
typescript
so let's go back and clear the terminal
here and with our index.ts let's just
Define some variable equal to 20 and
then
um
let's give it a custom object type okay
so we'll we'll say that some variable
is a number another variable is a string
and then if we assign this type
to our object now typescript is going to
kick in and it's going to start telling
you
um you know that you've missed certain
typings so we've got these red
squigglies because vs code has detected
that you are typing this object as a
custom object type which has these two
properties so we need to actually fill
these in with their matching types
so if we put these in just like that and
then finish off the object now this is
matching the type that we've assigned it
and if we tried to add an extra prop
it's going to yell at us because that
does not exist in the type that we gave
it so anyways the point of this is to
just give a Bare Bones introduction to
what typescript is doing and we'll see
how this kind of plays out to benefit us
in the refactor for right now I'm just
going to compile this so we've got the
TSC or the typescript compiler installed
globally
let's go ahead and check so we'll pass
the version it gives us 4.9.5 and now
let's go and call for help so this will
basically give you all the options which
is pretty
overwhelming to start with but you can
see that
if we just run TSC it compiles the
current project
so let's pass this file to it so TSC
uh app or I'm sorry JS and then
no we need to get into our live TS
refactor first
now we'll say TSC Js index.ts
and you can see that we ran that command
and now we have an index.js sitting over
here which is the compiled version of
index.ts so let's open up the two files
next to each other and what you're going
to see here is typescript in action over
on the left is our DOT TS file this is
what we're writing our source code in
and we're able to use custom typings and
assigning those typings to a variable
now looks like something is going wrong
here
and it looks like the two files are
actually conflicting so let's uh name
this let's put something at the end
there and it will solve this error for
us so just know that because they're in
the same directory and vs code is pretty
smart it's detecting that we have two
variables that are the same name now
this is not going to happen in our final
code because we're going to configure it
not to but just know that that's what's
happening here but anyways the point is
that we've got a type here which is
actually not valid JavaScript code you
can't run that in a browser or node.js
or any JavaScript or runtime so what the
typescript compiler does is it removes
this type and it removes this type
annotation right here and it gets us to
this just vanilla JavaScript object that
can actually run in the browser so
there's really two questions that come
out of this number one why would we want
to do this this what is the purpose of
adding these types and then number two
how do we get more control over how this
compiles to this because there's going
to be different
um options that we can use to make that
transformation happen and furthermore
you know we don't want them going in the
same directory because obviously that
screws things up with you know variable
declarations happening twice and so on
and so forth so there's some
configuration that we can do to make
this better for us so let's go back to
Excalibur here
and come down here and say
benefits of typescript
so you could definitely go through a
laundry list of things that typescript
helps with and you know there's plenty
of people that go and do that but I'm
going to keep it simple here and just
give one or two reasons why it is
beneficial for your code base the first
one is just
um
code checking in general so in other
words it's going to if you're using
visual studio code and you're using
typescript visual studio code is
basically walking through all of your
code base and making sure that
everything talks to each other
appropriately so we will see this in
action as we start to refactor but if we
go back to our original application let
me delete this index.ts file
um and then the index.js
if we go back to our original project
which once again if you haven't seen
this already if you didn't watch the
prior video at least make sure that
you've skimmed over the code and know
what's there if we go to app.js
um and let's try to find a good example
of this
so here's a good one when we are calling
view dot render and we are passing in
all of our state of the application
these State objects have a certain type
and as you can see Visual Studio code is
giving you some you know suggestions as
to what types these are already even
though we're not using typescript and
it's just inferring this from the
function definitions over here in store
so it can read through the functions and
it can see you know what we are
returning so the return type here and
then it kind of infers okay what
properties are on this object that was
returned so on and so forth but if we go
back to app.js it doesn't really know
what type anything really is it can
figure out the Boolean type but the
moves in the current player in the
winner these are all any types because
because it can't really figure that out
with plain vanilla JavaScript and what's
Difficult about this and hard to
maintain as your project grows is as
you're typing things
um quite literally as you're like typing
on the keyboard and passing variables
around in your application it's very
useful to know are you passing something
valid into a function and typescript
allows you to do this very easily you'll
really start to see this benefit as we
start to refactor so the second benefit
that I've personally found with
typescript is refactoring so very soon
you know for this video since we're
refactoring stuff but if you have a big
code base and you're trying to go
through and refactor an entire feature
it is extremely difficult to do so if
you just have vanilla JavaScript and you
don't have any strong typings throughout
your application
with typescript it's a lot easier
because as you change things you know
Visual Studio code or your editor that
runs the typescript server is going to
be able to tell hey did you move things
around correctly and are you passing you
know is your refactor going to break the
compilation of the code
but enough talk let's get started
um so the first thing that we need to do
now that we've got typescript installed
and we kind of understand the general
concept of what's going on is get it set
up for this specific application
so I know we've got it installed
globally if you use TSC and you know
type the version that's that binary is
installed on our computer globally but
it's always a good practice to install
it as a developer dependency within your
project and the reason being is you know
the the global version is going to be
different on each developer's computer
so if you're collaborating on a project
it's good to pin that typescript version
for the application so that you have
predictable builds in compiles when you
when you compile that code to plain
JavaScript so to do that I'm going to
type yarn init
and pass the dash Y flag just to say yes
to all the options and just get a
package.json file created so here's our
package Json and we've got live TS
refactor blah blah and the first thing
we'll do is
um yarn add and then patch a dash dash D
for developer dependency and then I want
to install typescript
so now you can see dev dependencies has
typescript now why is this a developer
dependency and not a regular dependency
well this is super important and the
reason being is because as we talked
about typescript is only going to happen
before you deploy your application so
you write all your code in typescript
but obviously that's not correct or it
is correct it's not valid for running in
the browser or a node.js runtime so
before you deploy your application you
know out on some server like AWS or
render or digitalocean what what have
you you need to First build it to the
appropriate runtime that you're using
which is probably going to be common JS
or es6 so the point of having this as a
Dev dependency is to express the fact
that you're not going to need this to
actually run the application you just
need it to to build the application to
the point where then it can run
the next thing that we need to do is
initialize a TS config so this file is
going to be a special file that sits in
the root directory of your project and
it tells this compiler so remember TSC
is the compiler we don't want to use the
global version anymore so in this case
we can run yarn TSC to grab it
specifically from the project and then
just run that and it's going to try to
compile stuff but it doesn't find any
typescript files to actually compile so
anyways we need to set up a TS config to
tell it how to compile things so how we
do that is we say
yarn TSC I think init is the right thing
so let's go to help
and let's read through the options okay
so here's the start of the options and
you can see TSC dash dash init creates a
tsconfig.json with the recommended
settings in the working directory so
that is what we want to do so we'll run
yarn TSC dash dash init
and you can see that it created a nuke
tsconfig.json which we can open up up
here and this these are the options that
it gave it by default so let's go read
through this
and right off the bat you can see that
there's quite a lot going on so by
default it's going to have everything
commented out
and we're going to get rid of all this
these are just kind of all the different
options and you can go to this link here
to view the reference for this so the TS
config and it basically just takes you
through all the different compiler
options you can click on these links to
to figure out what they do
but most of these options are not going
to be relevant starting out
especially for a beginner these are more
of just options to control you know your
developer experience as you're building
in a typescript code base and also of
course how it actually builds and
compiles the typescript to JavaScript so
let's go ahead and get rid of all the
comments just to see what it gave us so
these are the defaults that you're going
to get and we'll go from the kind of
least important to most starting from
the bottom skip lib check this just
tells uh typescript to ignore kind of
the node modules dot d dot TS files
um that's not super relevant here strict
true this is always going to be a good
thing to turn on because as you go
through your code and write typescript
the intellisense that's provided by
Visual Studio code will make sure that
everything
checks out and all the types are
consistent so this is always good to
have on these two options are just
related to some maintenance of your code
base so forces you know file naming
consistency this allows you to
um
have interoperability between common JS
modules and es6 modules so I actually
wrote a whole post on this if you go to
my site
scripts versus common JS versus UMD AMD
and es6 modules so this is a mouthful
but this kind of explains what that is
talking about
and then most importantly is the Target
and the module options so this is
telling the typescript compiler
what kind of code that needs to be
output into you know code that can
actually run within a browser and that's
our goal is to get our typescript files
to run regular JavaScript files so that
we can just write our code and
typescript and then the compiler deals
with getting that to a place where it
can run in the browser so let's go to
the reference
um we'll go to the the reference guide
here so we'll start with the first one
which is the target
now I believe this is going to be in the
um let's see where is this so just to
orient ourselves it's in this is the
compiler options uh field so if you
you'll notice all this is defined in
compiler options and here in the
language and environment section you'll
find Target right here
let's click on that it'll scroll down
and it says modern browsers support all
es6 features as we've been talking about
and we wrote our original project in so
es6 is a good choice you might choose to
set a lower Target if your code is
deployed to older environments or a
higher Target if your code is guaranteed
to run in newer ones so in other words
what Target represents is the end state
of the code that is going to be compiled
so we are going to Target es6 because
that is going to mirror what we did the
original refactor the Vino the vanilla
JS one
um so you can see we've already got that
es2016
um you can pass a couple different
options I think it yeah it gives you all
the options right here
um but es6 es2015 yes 2016
um all the way up to es next so let's
just grab es6 because we know that
that's available in all browsers
um I'm not sure why they did es
2016 when they say es6 is a good choice
kind of mismatching their defaults but
anyways this is what the code compiles
to the next one is module so let's go
look at that we'll go back to the top
and if you see modules you will find the
module property
this sets the module system for the
program
and
um see the modules reference you very
likely want common JS for node projects
so not to backtrack at all but going
back to that post
that I wrote here scripts common JS es6
modules this really talks about these
different module systems but basically
if we look at let me do a sample file
so sample.ts basically if we look at you
know this syntax import something from
some uh Library this is what we would
consider es6 module syntax now if we did
something like this const
something equals require
some lib this is going to be common JS
syntax so the require syntax and then
also module dot exports
at the bottom of your file this is all
going to be common JS syntax now if we
do es6 once again it's import something
from some web and then you can come down
and you can export
um you know some object or export
default and this will export things from
your file which is uh one to one with a
module so that's what that is talking
about and you'll see that it defaults to
Common JS which again is a little bit of
a mismatch it says the default is common
JS if the target is ES3 or es5 es6
otherwise I'm not really sure given this
documentation and the fact that we're on
the latest version of typescript
why it defaulted to that but we really
want to just have es6
because we want to deal with that nice
module syntax
um that es6 comes with and then going
down the list es module interoperability
as I said is the ability to basically
combine the syntax that we just went
through and have files from multiple
module systems being able to compile
together this is going to be important
especially if you have certain you know
libraries that still use old common JS
module systems or newer ones that you
know use es6 modules and don't support
common JS so having that
interoperability is really nice
especially in larger projects
so at this point we've gone through most
of this and once again you can read
through the documentation if you have
questions on any other properties but
for now I want to build a sample project
just to get our our bearings here so
let's make a folder called test
TS and this is just going to have a test
TS file just something to work with and
in this file we're going to just you
know
Define a sample type
and the sample type is going to have a
name which is a string and an age which
is a number and then we will say let's
actually
call this a person type and then we'll
say const person is a variable and this
will be of person type and then we will
just give it a string so Bob and then
age
so something like that so this is our
basic TS file let's save our TS config
and now we should be able to compile
some things so the first question is
well how does it know where to look how
does it know that we want to compile
that test.ts file well let's go ahead
and try it so yarn TSC and run it
and it says done in 0.73 seconds and it
obviously found the correct file to
compile so the question is how did it
actually know that well let's go to the
documentation and look outside of the
compiler options at the top level
options
let's go to include
and this is an array that specifies an
array of file names or patterns to
include in the program and then over
here in the default the array if files
is specified all otherwise so as you can
see in our code base we ran the TSC
compiler and it automatically just
looked for any dot TS file in the entire
folder and compiled it and that's
because it's got this default glob that
is including everything
so given that behavior I think we're
fine now the um the problem with
compiling your TS files in the same
directory as where they're written is it
just starts to get really messy and then
furthermore you really want to Output
them into their own build folder now
there's a lot more to this subject in
general like uh creating a bundle and
that involves things like webpack or
parcel or whatever have you whatever now
there's a lot more to this specific
subject we could talk all day about you
know how things are compiled where
they're stored all that kind of stuff
this gets into bundling and code
splitting and you know build tools like
webpack or roll up or parcel or whatever
we're not going to get into that because
we don't need it for this simple of a
project our goal is to basically take
all of our TS files and put them in one
spot and then that will be imported to
the index.html and it will run just like
our vanilla project would so to do that
we have a option that we can specify
and let's see where it is so
looking under a mitt
this is probably where we want to look
and yes here's the out directory
this is if it's specified
dot JS files will be emitted into this
directory the directory structure of the
original source files is preserved see
root directory if the computed root is
not what you intended so that's probably
not going to apply for us
um but you can see it gives an example
where it outputs to a dist directory or
distribution which is a very common
directory to Output compiled files so
that's what we're going to do
we'll come back to compiler options and
give it a out directory you can see vs
code knows all these options gives you
some autocomplete so if we specify out
directory gives us the documentation
which is very useful
and we're going to say that we want to
put this to the dist folder
so we're getting some errors here and
that's because we need a comma
and once we save this and we rerun the
compilation now it's going to Output
everything into dist and there's our
test.js file so you can see use strict
is put in there and we've got a person
compiled you'll notice that from earlier
in the video this is a different syntax
than we saw earlier earlier we saw this
was a VAR and there wasn't any use
strict going on at the top and that's
because we didn't have a TS config we
didn't have all of these targets and
modules that were specifying how we
wanted things to be output
so anyways this is the basics of
compiling a typescript project now our
next order of business here is to look
in our JS directory from our original
refactor and convert these files to
typescript so I'll leave this test TS
folder for us let me get rid of the dot
JS compiled file because that's now
going to be over in dist
um one thing that you would want to do
here
before we get too far is add a git
ignore if you're working with Git and
put the dist directory
as well as node modules because we've
added both of those neither of those
need to be uploaded to Source control
because node modules obviously can be
installed by yarn and then the dist
directory is the build itself which is
going to be created with yarn TSC so
let's close out TS config and let's
start in the app.js file so now that
we're working with typescript we can
just rename this to dot TS and now vs
code is going to automatically recognize
that this is a typescript file and it's
going to start underlining things and
it's going to yell at us for all sorts
of stuff because nothing is typed here
now there are some strategies that you
can use to migrate a JS project to
typescript but in our case things are
small enough that the best strategy here
is to just rename all of these to TS so
that we're dealing with typescript
across the board
now if we were to go through and
just try to compile this right now it's
going to throw all sorts of errors and
the reason that it does that is kind of
the whole purpose of typescript and that
is it's going to check the types and
make sure that they're all compatible
across all the files with the Imports
exports you know function calls
parameters all of that stuff and that's
a good thing that's what you want but
when we first start out and everything
has these red squiggly underlines and
typescript is really mad at us it's not
so fun
but I'm going to work through this it's
not as
um it's not as intimidating as you'll
think
um and we'll get this thing worked out
shortly so just as a reminder
um the current project is no longer
going to work because in index.html
we are importing app.js and that does
not exist any longer we have app.ts if
we tried to replace this it's just not
going to work because typescript is not
valid in our JS runtimes so what we
really need to adjust here I'm just
going to do this right off the bat so
that we don't forget is now that
everything's being compiled to the dist
directory we need to now specify instead
of JS we're going to look in the dist
directory and import
app.js
so same thing as the original project
it's just going and looking in a
different directory instead of the
source code that you know in our prior
refactor was able to run in the browser
now we have to use the compiled code and
you can see in dist it's going to
maintain that folder structure so we
actually need to say dist slash JS slash
app.js
and you can see that it will you know
this this has been compiled
um it through a bunch of errors but it
still compiled it so we could probably
get this to work actually let's just see
real quick
the way that we'll do this
is we already have live server running
just I had this before the video so it's
on Port 5500
and we're looking in dist Js app.js
so let's go to
the vanilla refactor and instead we'll
go to the live TS or let's just go to
let's go to localhost localhost 5500
live TS refactor and let's see it seems
to be working
so even though there was all those type
errors
um it still compiled the JavaScript and
this makes sense because typescript is
just a superset of JavaScript so while
not all typescript is valid JavaScript
all JavaScript is valid typescript so in
other words when we went to compile
these vanilla JS files just in a
different form it still knew how to do
it it just was complaining about all the
types so in this case where we're
migrating an existing vanilla JS project
this behavior is actually good because
we can you know gradually migrate our
code over and not break everything from
the start so there are some options
though once we get to a more final state
if we go to the documentation let's
close some things out here
if we go back to this reference there
should be some sort of configuration
property that allows us to basically
fail the build if there are any errors
so we ran yarn TSC
and it it's going to give us all of
these errors if we just look through
them
um but it's going to still compile all
those files to our output directory but
just to demonstrate how you can change
this behavior I'm going to get rid of
the test TS directory now just so that
that's not clouding anything up and then
I'm going to completely delete the dist
directory
so that's okay because remember we can
just run yarn TSC and it's going to
create the disk directory interestingly
enough now that we deleted that other
directory that had typescript this Now
does not maintain the JS directory
structure so before I forget I'm sure
there's an option to change that but
before I forget let's go and remove that
path
and if we go back to our browser
um let me get rid of this
let's refresh and we can still play our
game
so this is looking at the live TS
refactor
so it's still working but if we go to
the options reference there should be
some options in the emit so if we're
scrolling through there's this option
called No emit on air
and I think that's
um
what we want let's just scroll through a
few more things okay so let's click on
no omit on air
this says do not emit compiler output
files like JavaScript source code Source
Maps or declarations if any errors were
reported this defaults to false making
it easier to work with typescript in a
watch-like environment where you may
want to see results of changes to your
code in another environment before
making sure all errors are resolved so
let's just take this property no emit on
air
we'll open up our TS config
and we'll throw this at the end so no
emit on air
and this defaults to false but we're
going to say true
now let's once again delete the dist
directory
and let's try the yarn TSC to compile
our typescript files
and now you'll see that even though we
ran this there's no dist directory
because we've said if there are errors
do not emit any you know output files
now once again we don't really want this
because when we are converting our
project over we want the ability to you
know just compile the typescript files
with errors so that we get a build
output and then in a final State you
might you know once you've converted
your project over you might add that
back or have other sort of build checks
to make sure that you know you get a
clean build before you deploy your
application so now that we have
everything set up and we've got the app
working with this disk directory we will
just jump into this JS folder it's
probably you know not the best name for
it anymore JS but technically typescript
is a superset of JavaScript so it's
somewhat valid
but what we'll do is we will start
um I think rather than starting an app
which kind of consumes both the store
and The View
let's just start with the store because
um it's always good to Define the types
of your state at the beginning that just
kind of helps you inform you know the
rest of the files in the project design
in general so this is just in general a
good place to start now in this folder
I'm also going to make a new file called
types dot TS and this is going to be a
module that exports a bunch of types
that the rest of our files are going to
consume and pass around
to keep things more clear in our heads
and to also satisfy the compiler so let
me just reference
um my final to make sure I'm getting the
right types here okay so let's close
this out our types will go on the left
and then we'll put our store on the
right so the first thing that we'll see
as we're going through aside from all
the red squigglies is this initial state
so this is the
um the shape of the object that we're
storing in local storage as you can see
here so if we open up our app and
inspect and we go over to storage and
local storage
you'll see that I've already played the
game and you can see this updates on
every move
and if we open this up you can see the
parsed value so we've got the current
game moves the history all games current
round games and then you can go through
and just see all the moves that have
been made by the different players so
that is the shape of that object that
we're storing in state now the benefit
of typescript is to just have confidence
over you know the types we're passing
around so it would be a great idea to
Define that state so in typescript you
define a typing with either the type
keyword or the interface keyword the
difference between the two is a
discussion for another day I generally
prefer types
um but you know some people will get
very in you know heated with a
discussion about which one is better in
which situation
but we'll start with just a type
and I'm going to call this the game
state so game state is an arbitrary name
I'm giving this type similar to how we
would you know Define a variable name
and the type is defined using you know
basic object syntax so I'm just going to
match this so let me copy this shape
over and get rid of this comment
so right now this is not really a valid
type
um it's not really complaining about
anything but this is not a valid type
let's go ahead and give this a type of
let's see current game moves
let's just say it's any for right now
and it's going to be an array so it's
going to be an array that has objects
that are have any shape so this is just
our starting point now we need to Define
all of these types right here so this is
kind of our final thing that we need to
get to but we need to decompose our
types into you know smaller units so
that we can pass them around our files a
little bit easier
so the first thing I want to do is
Define a player so you can see that
we've got squiggly lines under the
players param or argument that we're
passing into the class Constructor and
if we were to open up the app.ts
you can see the player's array that
we've defined so let's give a type to
these objects you can see that they have
the same exact object shape so we can
give this a representation of player
and a player is going to have an ID a
name an icon class and a color class now
these are the actual values
but we want to give these a type so a 1
is going to be a number type
player one is going to be a string type
the icon class is also a string type and
the color class is a string type so here
we have defined a player type now you'll
notice that all of these just have
regular you know primitive typings
and they don't have anything crazy going
on here now with typescript you can make
a property optional by adding a little
question mark after the property or I
guess not sure if you'd call that a
property but you put this question mark
here and now the color class would be an
optional property so you can hover over
it and it says it's either string a
string or undefined and if we remove
that it is just going to be a string for
our game since this is a configuration
property we want this to be all required
properties so this is the correct shape
so now what we can do is go back to
stored.ts and move on to the next type
that we'll need
this does not satisfy anything that
we've got going on here but it will be a
building block for us to work from so
the first thing I want to do is Define
the current game moves so what is a move
in our game if you we scroll down to
Player move you can see that what we're
pushing to state is a property with a
square ID and a player so we just
defined the player interface or type but
what is square ID well this is just
going to be a number and we can Define
this as a move so let's call it a move
and it's going to have a square ID which
is a number and then a player which will
basically be this type right here so if
we hover over move you can see that this
is the type that we've given it we can
now take this move type and replace the
any type in the current game moves with
move so now the current gave game moves
is an array of moves and that lines up
with what we've done here where we are
pushing a move to the array of current
game moves which is our state now to
figure out what we're going to type the
history object with we need to go down
into the store class and figure out what
we're doing
so in the reset method
what we are doing is pushing games to
the history object under the current
round games property
so this is the type that we're looking
for we are pushing an object
that has a moves property and a status
property now it's pretty clear what
moves represents moves is going to be
what we just defined an array of moves
so we can start with that and we're
going to call this a game
so a game is going to be represented by
an array of moves and then we have a
status property
we don't really know what that is yet so
let's give it a type of any to start
with and now we can kind of go look
through our code base and Define what
that type is so if we track backwards
and look at status it's coming from a
destructured property off of this Dot
Game and if we look what this dot game
is
that is a getter method on the class and
the return type of that getter method is
all of this stuff so we have a moves
array we have a current player and we
have a status
this object right here the status is
what we are trying to Define so let's
make one more type called game status
and that's going to be an object with an
is complete property which is going to
be a Boolean value value as you can see
and then the winner is going to be a
player so the winner is going to be
represented by a player which we defined
right up here so now we can take this
game status
and this is going to be the
representation of status within the game
type
so once again we're coming down here and
this is where we're pushing a game to
the history of current round games we've
got a moves property which is now
represented by an array of moves and we
have a status property which is now
represented by a game status which has
this type and now we're finally ready to
replace some things here so we have a
game and a game status
let's put game right here for current
round games now the last thing we have
to fill in is the all games we have to
figure out what type of array that is
and I'll just save us some pain of
looking through this and just say it's
going to be the same thing so the
current round games in all games going
to have the same exact type
at this point we have defined all of
these supporting types for our game and
in this case we had just looked at our
reference code our JavaScript and we're
basically just looking at you know what
kind of objects are we passing around
what are we returning from our different
functions and we're just looking and
analyzing our code to see that
information
if you're starting this project from
scratch and you intended to use
typescript all the way through
this is actually a great exercise to go
through before you even write any code
defining the types of your game is a
great way to define the functionality
behind it without writing any code it's
actually one of the first things that I
will do when I'm building a new feature
is just map out the different types that
I'm going to be dealing with and then
I'll figure out what functions do I need
what types are going to be accepted as
arguments to each of these functions
what are the return types of these
functions so on and so forth so as you
can see
typescript is already making us think a
lot more clearly about what types of
objects we're passing you know objects
arrays so on and so forth what types
were passing through our code and it
makes us a lot more explicit about that
and more organized so if we go back to
our Excalibur where I was briefly
listing out the benefits of typescript
um I think one of the other benefits is
makes you think more clearly and
explicitly about your code
so that's what we just experienced we're
we're having to explicitly type out our
game now at this point we still have
squiggly lines and that is because we
have not assigned these types to
anything here
so I will keep both of these open I'm
going to just collapse this a little bit
and let's just start working from the
top of our file
so the first thing let's look at is the
Constructor with typescript we can add
types to things by adding a colon and
then giving it a type in in this case
the key is our local storage key and
that's just a primitive string type so
we can just pass that in directly we
don't need to do anything over in our
types file because you know we don't
need to redefine a string now players is
going to be an array of players so we'll
give it a colon and then we will say
player and then array so that is going
to be the type we're dealing with now
you can see that it figured out that
type already even though we didn't
import it now this is not always going
to be the case it works works okay here
but generally what you'd want to do is
import that type explicitly so with es6
modules what we can do is import a type
and then that type will be called player
and that type will come from the types
file so types.ts is what we're looking
for now you're going to see an import
path cannot end with a TS extension
consider importing types.js instead
let's Google this it's probably some
configuration property that we missed
this person is just saying that we can
just remove the extension let's just try
that I don't think that worked now it's
saying that types.ts is not a module oh
I actually know what's going on here I'm
sorry I messed this up so these are all
just scoped to the types.ts file and
it's also not saved so that that would
be a big problem that we cannot import
that so the first thing we do is save
this file that will help us out quite a
bit it will not solve this error because
we have not exported any of these from
the file so to use them throughout our
code we need to export them just like we
would export you know if we had some
variable equals 20 and then we export
some variable or
export default something like that or we
could just export it like this
and it would do the same thing and now
we can you know import some variable
from
the types file
so that's just a regular JavaScript
variable I will get rid of this and
let's keep exporting all of these Okay
so we've exported all of our types let's
save it
and now we should not get so much uh
grief from the typescript server now
there's no red squigglies we've got the
player type and you can see we can hover
over it and you can see that type which
is really nice to just be able to hover
over this you can also hover over it
down here and now we have a strongly
typed Constructor and it knows exactly
what's being passed in but at this point
we get these problems storage key and
players these are instance properties of
the store class
and since we have not explicitly typed
those it's complaining now one way that
we could do this is come up here at the
top
and say that storage
key
is a string and that will satisfy it
because we're passing in this key and
then in the Constructor we are assigning
this to a string so there's actually a
shortcut to doing this a more concise
way to do it and instead of calling this
key and then this storage key and having
that mismatch there we can short circuit
this delete that
rename this to storage key
and so far it's not going to do anything
so if we tried to assign this dot
storage key equal to storage key it's
not going to work
we can remove that entirely now this is
not going to work but if we say this is
a read-only property of the class it
will Define it so that we can access it
later in the class so if we go to the
bottom where we are saving the state you
can see we're accessing this dot storage
key in these two places and if we hover
over that it's going to know that it's a
string now if we come to the top and we
get rid of that read only
and just leave it to storage key
it will complain about that because it
says it does not exist on the type store
so all we need to do is give it a
read-only and you can also give it
either a public
or private just to define whether it's
accessible in from outside the class or
not we'll call it private because only
the internal methods of this class can
access this and then same goes with
players so once again we can delete all
of this
and this can just become a private
read-only array of players and so right
here this is basically the shortcut for
passing in these
um parameters and then assigning it to
the class all in one step and you can
see if we look for this dot players it
knows that it's of type player all right
so we're getting closer we're seeing a
lot less little squiggly red lines
we just have a few more things to work
out in this file
um let's go ahead and start here at the
bottom this is pretty isolated so this
state or function has an implicit any
type which basically means typescript is
yelling at us because we haven't defined
any type one thing that we could do
if we really wanted to as we are
refactoring this and migrating our code
base if we change strict to false
and save that
and then restart the TS server you'll
see that this no longer complains about
this at all we can Define this as an any
type and typescript's not going to be
mad about it this of course comes with
the detriment that now you don't have
any red squiggly lines to tell you where
you've messed up that is why most people
would encourage you to put on strict
mode
restart the TS server here
but I just wanted to show you that just
so you can see now let's start at the
bottom Here Again State or function this
is a great use case for typescript this
is where your life becomes a lot easier
and that is because in this case we are
allowing
um
someone that is using this function to
pass either an object that represents
state or a function that we will pass
the previous state to and then it
returns a new state so two different
types of parameters that you can expect
here and so we can type this a lot
better now that we know or now that
we're using typescript so saving the
state we are going to be passing game
state so that is the type that we're
looking to pass in there so we'll say
game state
and it's going to complain about this
because it cannot find that name
let's go to the top
and let's import game state from our
types so we're importing that type
now it's not complaining anymore
but it complains right here because it
thinks this function thinks that state
or function is just an object that is
represented by game State and right here
we are trying to call it as a function
so the problem here is that we've only
defined one of the possible types so
here we can define a typescript union
let's go to the documentation and
briefly look at this
so let me make a new tab and typescript
docs let's start over
and let's go to either the reference or
the handbook I'm a little surprised that
we don't see unions
um starting out but let's go to the
basics
that's not what we're looking for
let's just search the docs so Union
typescript unions uh looks like
typescript for functional programmers is
where we found that one
um but anyways in typescript Union types
are untagged in other words they're not
discriminated unions like data and
Haskell I I don't use Haskell so I don't
know what that means
um but what this is trying to basically
say is that if you put this little pipe
character that means that the type can
be you know either this or that so it's
kind of like an or
um an or operator but for types so you
can read more about that but let me just
show you what this looks like it's going
to be game state or and then this is
where we Define our function that we're
looking for so the function is going to
be a separate type and I'm going to
actually add this to
um let's add it to the top of the file
so since we're in typescript we can just
add types within our files so we'll say
Save State
CB for callback
and to define a function there's a
couple ways you can do it but one quick
way is to basically just give it an
arrow function and tell it what it needs
to return so in this case we want to
return the game State and we're going to
pass the previous state which is going
to be a game state so basically I talked
about this in the previous video when we
did this build but it's always nice in
your Save State function to be able to
access the previous state so that you
can derive that next state so that's why
we're passing this but this is the type
that we can Define and if we took this
key right here the type
and we passed it right here Save State
callback you'll see that there's no more
complaints from the typescript server
compiler because state or function
matches the type that we gave in
previous state
um is not typed yet but it satisfies
that constraint so I can actually take
this to be a little more concise and
copy that type itself
and just pass it in right here and then
you need to put some parentheses around
it
and that should work just fine now we
can get rid of this
I just wanted to break it out so that it
was more clear now everything's working
here but if we hover over previous state
that's going to have an any type which
no one's complaining about this here
with typescript but it would be nice to
know what that is
one way that we can do this and this is
a little bit tricky with typescript it's
um not super obvious but when we do
local storage dot get item and set item
it's not going to return a type so get
item is going to by default return in
any type
um or actually sorry a string or null
and the Json parse method
this is where it's going to return in
any type so what we want to do if we
want to actually give this a strong
typing is we will cast the type
so we can say
json.parse item and then this is going
to be as game
state
so now get state is going to have a
return type of game State and you can
actually explicitly Define that
on the function itself and if we remove
this now
um and we say as string or something
like that it's going to yell at us
because we're not returning the correct
type that this function was declared as
now that's for a whole nother day we're
not going to be typing all of our
functions
explicitly with return types some
programmers really like that to be
explicit about typing all the functions
this is just a refactor and I just want
to get this working so for the moment
I'm not going to worry about that
but just know that you can Define the
return Types on your functions
so now that we have done this we can
come back here in previous state will be
a type of game State and it still works
to pass it into state or function the
game State can go into state or function
because that is what we typed it as
all right
let's keep scrolling up I think we have
one or two more errors
the square ID this should be very easy
let's just give this a number that's the
expected type now if we hover over
current game moves we would expect that
to have the
um move type but it does not it has an
any type and I believe we can fix that
where would we fix that one thing we can
do is give this initial state
a game State type so now anywhere we
pass that it's going to recognize it so
right here the initial state is of type
game state so if we look here the
structured clone method
is actually similar to local storage
where it's a a browser API and by
default it's not going to type anything
so in this case we're going to cast this
to a game State object because we know
that this state is going to be
represented there
so now where we're pushing to all games
it's going to recognize that current
round games is of type game so you can
start to see how this comes together and
how we are starting to get stronger
types across our code okay so I think
the only thing we have left here is that
red squiggly
not saying that the red squiggles are
your map necessarily you obviously need
to check other things but just given the
fact that we know that this code worked
before and we have strict mode on we can
really use those as a guide for our
refactor to to find areas that we have
not strongly typed things
so let's dig in into this error it says
property includes does not exist on type
number array do you need to change your
target Library try changing the lib
compiler option
to es2016 or later all right so it's
going to say 2016 or later
so this is es7 I believe
so let's target es2016
and then restart the TS server
and now you can see that will go away
because that built-in method on an array
is available in the ecmascript 2016 spec
so we are let me be clear about this we
are using es6 modules which tells us how
we can export and import things from
modules and then we're compiling our
typescript code to this standard of
JavaScript
so that standard of JavaScript has this
method
and at this point we have completed
this file
we've imported our types that we need
and there are no red squiggly lines so
that's a good indication that we're
pretty much done with this file
let's save that and go to the next one
so we are done with the store
let's go to The View
this one will be slightly more difficult
because we're going to have to deal with
um
Dom element types which are a little bit
more confusing
so we've got a bunch of red squiggly
lines here but they're all coming from
this query selector helper method that
we defined
let's go straight down to that
and let's start typing it so the
selector itself is just going to be a
string
that's like the class or you know
selector that we're passing into the
query selector method and then when
we're typing things with typescript
something useful you can do is just
hover over these methods
um it's not going to work because we're
using it on the parent but if we go to
the document there's some built-in types
for the Dom
methods and Global types so document is
of type document and query selector this
will give you a stub giving you the
types that are available here
you can see the selectors are string
that's how I knew to give that a string
and then element is what's going to be
returned from it so we're going to pass
a parent which is of type element
and now we should see that's of element
and then query selector is now available
on that
and we're passing in a string so let's
let's retype this to a number real quick
and you'll see that that's an invalid
thing to pass to a query selector so
that's how we know that string is going
to be the correct thing and then
furthermore we can go to query selector
all and just give that a string type as
well
so these two methods are now strongly
typed and if we come to the top
it's still going to be yelling at us
just a little bit
it's saying it expected two arguments
but it got one so what we have to do is
come down to our methods and in this
case the parent element is totally
optional
so what we can do is pass a question
mark right after that and that will now
make this an element or undefined and
that's okay because we are first
checking with our ternary operator
whether that parent
argument is has a value and if it does
have a value we're going to use it
otherwise we're going to fall back to
the document so if we were to refactor
this a little bit
and intentionally break it if we just
tried to access the parent element and
grab a query selector off of it and then
pass the selector it's going to work
because Visual Studio code already knew
what we were trying to do but if we
remove that right there it's going to
yell at us because it says parent is
possibly undefined and you can't access
a method like this on an undefined
parameter now you'll see that vs code
added this question mark here which is
the optional chaining so let's type that
in optional chaining
this is actually not a typescript
concept this is an operator in newer
versions of JavaScript which we're using
that accesses an object's property or
calls a function
and if it cannot find what it's looking
for if the if the type is undefined or
null as shown here it will short circuit
and evaluate to undefined so the reason
that that works to do this is because
we're first this operator right here is
just checking hey is the parent element
defined if it is let me call this method
otherwise let's turn element to
undefined and then as you can see here
we're checking if element is defined
throwing an error and if it's not or if
it is defined we're returning it so that
technically does work but in this case
we want to use this logic just to be
explicit and say if it exists grab from
the parent otherwise fall back back to
the document and that gives us assurance
that we're going to find that element
so we've fixed all these red squiggly
lines but now we have a problem here and
it says property menu does not exist on
type
object and you can see here we've
defined this as an object
what we really want to do
is retype this
and we're going to use a built-in
typescript utility let me make sure I'm
doing this the same as my example or my
final
so if we go to the documentation for
typescript
let's go back and
find ourselves the utility types so in
the reference there's this utility types
and if you come over here to record
this constructs an object type whose
property keys are keys right here in
whose property values are type right
here so this is actually leveraging
something called generics in typescript
which is kind of beyond the scope of
this video you can look it up and and
read about it but keys and type are
going to be generics and record is going
to be the type that allows us to define
something so in other words this is just
basically defining a basic object
so right here this is where we will type
this so remember dollar sign is just a
property an instance property of the
class you could have named this pretty
much anything
um
so you could have named this element
object store or something like that but
we're just doing this for a shortcut and
if we want to type it we can type record
and then this is where we pass our
generic values so we want to pass a
string because we're defining arbitrary
strings
as the properties of this object and
then the value is all going to be the
same it's going to be a an element type
so if we pass an element now things are
satisfied satisfied here because we are
passing an arbitrary string property
name right here and then the value
is going to return an element which as
you can see down here
we are returning a type of element so
that is satisfied so all these are happy
now
but we need to type the double dollar
sign which is the node list now if you
come down here to query selector all
let's just take a peek at what this
element list is it is typed as a node
list of elements so that is the native
typing that the query selector all
built-in method is returning and you can
see that's defined right here so let's
just copy that because we'll need it
come back to the top and now let's
define this as a record where we can
give it an arbitrary string
so squares is an arbitrary string
property name and then the type that
we're going to give it we'll just paste
that in so it's a node list of elements
and we'll initialize that to an empty
object and now the element list is happy
because query selector all returns that
node list of in squares is that
arbitrary property value so it satisfies
this type so that's just a use of a
built-in utility type in typescript
using some generics I just want to show
you another way that you could have done
this so if you wanted to not use a
utility type what you could do is Define
a custom type so let's say
um element
object
uh
dictionary that's just our type name
that we're giving it and here what we
can do is pass in a key
of string
and this can be an element
value and then we'll pass this element
object dictionary
I'm sorry it should not be of it should
be in
string so what this is basically saying
is I want an object that can have an
arbitrary number of properties in the
key of that property so menu menu button
menu items is a string and then the
value of that property is an element as
assigned here so this type right here is
really the equivalent to what we did
earlier where we said
record string element and then closed it
off and if you really really wanted to
get fancy
you could do this with generics so sorry
I'm going on a little bit of a tangent
here but this is just to give you an
idea of the power of typescript so we
could say custom record utility
so what we're trying to produce here is
the built-in utility record and just
recreating that from scratch
what we can do is pass in a generic so a
key and a value and usually with
generics you're going to put a t in
front of it
that's just kind of a convention that I
use to kind of signify or you know
Express this is a generic and then we'll
use the same syntax so the key is in
t
key
and then the value is T value now we
know in JavaScript the only valid type
of property you can give an object is
really a string you can't just Define an
object
like this and start adding numbers to it
like this is
I guess this might be valid is this
valid JavaScript
oh that's funny I I guess I don't know I
don't think this is valid but let's
let's just try it out because now I'm
curious
I wouldn't be surprised
so we'll say this is a test
and it looks like it is that is
interesting I didn't know that you could
do that I don't know why you would ever
do this other than maybe a map which is
kind of similar to what that does but
anyways
um I guess I'll learn something new
today while making a tutorial about
coding
that's probably not the best thing but
anyways let's just be honest so anyways
we want this to be a string so let's
just say it extends a string type and
now that's going to be fine and then we
can just replace this record with custom
record utility and it's going to work
fine everything's going to be happy
because we've basically just implemented
that built-in utility type that
typescript provides so just a
interesting tidbit that you can kind of
roll over a little bit so let's get rid
of that because that is unnecessarily
complex
you can see at the top here I had
imported the store just for JS doc
typings when we had of the vanilla
JavaScript project so now that we're
using typescript we really don't need to
do that
so we'll get rid of that
so moving down
we can now implement the rest of these
okay so we'll move on to the render
method
um
the render method takes
two State objects and the reason I
originally passed this as two separate
objects is because we were not working
in typescript
now that we are working in typescript I
probably would just pass the entire
State object as one parameter but we'll
we'll stay consistent here so if we look
at our types that we've defined
we have a game type so that one's pretty
easy we'll just type that as a game
and we need to import that but instead
of going to the top of the file
in doing it there I'll show you a little
trick so if you hold down on a Mac or on
a command or on Windows control so
command and then period
in vs code will give you a suggestion
and usually it can find out where it's
looking
now it's looking for types.js
um
not types.ts I'm not quite sure what's
going on there
um why it's saying that
I don't even know if there's a there
isn't a types JS I'm not sure what it
did there but anyways we'll add the type
uh import just so it's not importing
anything but typescript types
and then we can remove that extension
and that should work
so now that's working let's see if it
works on this one so we need to do stats
where we I don't know if we have typed
that yet okay so I've actually
um in my final copy of this that you'll
see on GitHub I've used a slightly
different strategy so we do not have a
type already defined for stats if we go
to store.ts
the object we're looking for is this one
and specifically we're looking for this
return type which has a player with
stats which is an array of players
with this wins property added and then
we have ties which is just a number now
if we hover over stats it will give us
this inferred type which is correct
and furthermore the store class is in
has an inferred type that has all of the
methods on it so something that we can
do is derive types from other types
and in this case since we don't have a
stats type what we can do is go back to
the view and we can import
type store from store
and that will give us the store class
that we had defined
and then here what we can do is say
store and then we can actually access
properties on that so you can scroll
down just like we're accessing you know
properties of an array we can scroll
down and see all the methods and
properties that we can grab from the
store and stats is one of those so now
stats is defined because we derived it
from the store
now someone argued that this is maybe
not the best way to do this and I would
probably recommend
um having stronger types and actually
defining a stats type but for now this
does work and it's a easy way to get
that type without having to define it
we can also grab the game uh getter from
the store which will properly type our
game and that is going to give us the
correct types for the render method and
again I'm using this to demonstrate
something in reality you'd probably want
to Define these as actual types over
here and we do have that for game so we
could use game ready oops
scrolling around we could just use game
right there but actually it will yell at
us because this game is slightly
different this is derived state so this
game is this the state that we're
storing in local storage
and then the game that we're trying to
represent in this method is derive state
so in our store remember we have this
method called game and we are reading
the state the raw State and we are
deriving some useful properties that
we're returning for our game to use
right here at the bottom so obviously
current player is not saved in local
storage and not represented in this type
so I guess that's another reason why
just using the store
game is a good way to do it but yeah
basically I would say that you'd want to
type this function now coming down to
the the bind events all these methods
the Handler is of type any right now but
basically what we're passing to the
Handler is the Callback of add event
listener so if you look at the stub for
this add event listener you'll see it's
got some overloads which is kind of an
advanced typescript concept
but one thing you can do to kind of zoom
in on some types
let's command click on add event
listener and this will take us to
lib.dom.d.ts these are the typings for
the Dom that are basically provided
already
um to us and if we open up this in the
file pane
um I don't even think you're going to
see it because
this is kind of I believe this is built
into vs code just to give you these
typings
um I could be wrong on that
but anyways at event listener it gives
you a couple types that you can deal
with here
and then you can hit command click on
this
and then you just kind of go until you
find the type that you're looking for so
event listener
and now you can see event listener is
actually a type that we can use
so we don't even need to define it
we can just use
event listener which you can see is
populated
and pass that right there
so event listener
it's always best to use built-in types
if you can if they're not defined then
you obviously have to type them yourself
but with something as common as an event
listener Handler like this you can
always expect that there's going to be a
type already defined for you that you
can use
so those are done
update scoreboard I believe these are
all just numbers
say number
number
and number
here it's going to tell us something
inner text does not exist on type
element
I might have used this wrong
in my original actually I think this
should be text content
yeah so that that's actually the right
thing to use I don't know why I was
using inner text it seemed to work
though
so let's update all those
open modal message is just going to be a
string because we're passing a string of
who won
and then we have the same error here
that needs to be changed to text content
coming down to initialize moves this one
is somewhat simple we've already defined
the move type over here so it's going to
be a move but right now it's going to
complain because it cannot find it so
hit command period and we'll update the
import and you can see that that
actually added the move right there and
we're not using game anymore so we can
get rid of that
but now it's going to complain right
here and that's because I've
intentionally messed this type up
we want an array of moves not just a
move so to specify that we can either
say array which is a helper utility of
typescript
or you can just do it shorthand and pass
the brackets at the end of it which
specifies that moves is now a moves
array so now this is valid and you can
see everything's working
just to start demonstrating the value of
typescript let's say that we removed
this plus sign so in the original build
I remembered to do this but it's pretty
easy to forget to cast the ID that you
extract from the the element Target to a
number so what if I got rid of that
now it's going to yell at me because
it's an unintentional
because types number and string have no
overlap and what that's saying is we are
doing a triple equals equality which
types or which checks the type and the
value
and we're looking at a move which has a
square ID of number and then the default
event Target ID is going to be a string
so element.id is going to type to a
string so these will never evaluate to
true
now we can of course remove the triple
equals and that would technically work
because things would be cast but you
always want to use triple equals if you
can so here that's just a very explicit
example of where typescript comes in
handy is it reminds you of these little
details that you might have kind of
glossed over before all right so let's
keep going you can see that it's
complaining here about icon possibly
being null
and this is just a case where
we could do better so remember earlier
in the prior video actually not this
video we Define query selector and this
is like a safe query selector where we
are checking uh whether the element
exists and if it doesn't we're throwing
in error which is kind of the behavior
that we want we don't we don't want to
proceed if we can't find the element so
one solution to this problem is to put a
question mark there because that will be
the
the optional chaining that we talked
about earlier where we're saying hey
let's check the icon and if it's an
element grab the class list and add this
to the class list if it's not an element
and it's null let's just uh evaluate
this to undefined and not throw any
errors now that works you could add that
there and it solves your problems but
this is kind of an anti-pattern a little
bit because you know you throw this in
here and all of a sudden you know your
app is not grabbing this correctly and
you're clicking your toggle menu and
it's not working well how do you find
that error it's better to be explicit
about this kind of thing so let's leave
that and take some Clues from typescript
and refactor this to instead
um let's comment this out and say icon
is equal to this
and we'll use our safe query selector
method in this case we're going to look
for an I tag and the parent is going to
be this dot dollar sign dot menu button
and that is basically how we can safely
select that and now icon is definitely
an element because we're going to throw
an error if it's not so these calls down
here are now valid this is actually a
concept called type narrowing
um that you can read more about in the
typescript documentation
so I wonder if this is actually
somewhere I can show you
okay yeah so narrowing
and this whole page kind of describes
that process of of narrowing the types
that I just explained here same thing
goes right here we can just copy this
down and replace this
let's get rid of this and these two
functions are good
now a couple more the square element
you can see that we are
replacing the children on it so we know
that that should be an element
and then the player
is going to be a player and command
period to update that import at the top
same thing here this is going to be a
player
and then finally we get this fun
delegate method that we really it's
tough to understand in the first place
and now we have to type it
but let's just walk you know
parameter by parameter and get this done
so element
pretty self-explanatory this is going to
be an element
the selector is going to be a string
the event key
is going to be a string
and then the Handler is going to be an
event
uh
what do we call this
we have an example of this right up here
event listener
now we've got a little bit of a tricky
situation so you can see right here
event Target is possibly null so okay
let's put that question mark the
optional chaining but we still have this
problem property matches does not exist
on type event Target so we're going to
use this narrowing concept again to
narrow these types and get rid of these
errors
so this is where typescript is actually
helping us in a way it's kind of making
us more explicitly check things that we
otherwise probably wouldn't
so the first thing that I want to do
let's get rid of this question mark or
no we'll leave it there for now
and we'll say
if
the event dot Target
is an instance of element so this is a
way that we can check if the target is
an element
so if that's an instance of the element
and we actually want to negate this so
if it's not an instance of an element
then we want to throw a new error
and we say event Target not found
so this is just a guard that basically
says Hey the purpose of the delegate
method is
um to delegate an event Target and find
something within it and if we can't find
that in the first place and it's not an
element then the rest of this method is
useless like we can't really proceed
safely so we might as well throw an
error exit early and then the developer
is you know responsible for fixing that
so that solves one of our problems the
matches keyword or function Now does not
complain about anything
now in the Handler it says argument of
type element is not assignable to
parameter of type event
and that is actually because I typed
this incorrectly
in this Handler we're actually passing
the element itself so I have typed this
as if we were passing the event but
really what we're passing is the element
so I need to type it accordingly
so we're just passing a function that is
called with the element as the first
argument and it doesn't return anything
so now there's nothing wrong here and
we're okay but let's remove this
question mark
and see what happens so
looks like we're okay
all right so we're we're good here this
works it's typed okay
I think this whole file is now strongly
typed and we're ready to move on to the
final one
app.ts and we're going to tie it all
together and get it working
now just as a reminder this is this app
really we haven't done anything
structurally to it other than a few
things so it should still be working and
if we open things up
and ran yarn TSC
let's look at the disk directory it
outputs everything
and then if we go to our page
let's inspect the page and go to the end
of the body
and you can see the script is looking in
dist Dash app.js
and if we click things we can play the
game still
so there's really nothing that we've
changed and it's been working this whole
time we're just trying to make our
project more maintainable with
typescript so that if we want to extend
it in the future it's easier to do so
want to debug it easier to debug all
that kind of stuff
okay at this point by fixing those other
files we basically fixed a lot of the
typings here in in these files now it's
always nice to just be pretty explicit
about your typings some would argue that
you want to infer types as much as
possible but
let's just go ahead and add a player
type to this array
and once again it's trying to go to
typestop JS for some reason
so we've got type player and this is a
array of players
now remember the store we've typed that
so you can hover over it and you can see
the storage key should be a string and
the players should be a player array
so this is a player array and this is a
string let's say that we passed in a
number it's not going to be happy with
that it'll say numbers not assignable to
type string so that's kind of the
assurance that we're getting here
now coming down here let's see what it
says property ID does not exist on type
event
so this is actually I think a mistyping
that we had from the bind Player move
event
let's go back to the view
and you can see this is where we're
using our delegate
and then our Handler we've typed that as
an event listener and if you remember
down here I made that same mistake
um where I was incorrectly typing the
Handler so let's copy this handle or
type
and instead of event listener for the
Handler it's just going to pass a
function with the element
that it's selected
so now we come back and these type
errors are fixed so this you know fixing
type error is really about just reading
the error message and being able to you
know respond to it and know what it's
trying to say which comes with time it's
not easy to start and figure that out
when you're first starting with
typescript
all right so at this point everything is
strongly typed and our app is working so
our last step here is to compile things
let's make sure that we're not getting
any errors
so yarn TSC
and there's no errors we're done in a
second
and the disk directory now has our
compiled code
and as you'll see as you read through
this none of it's really minified or
anything like that
um and our Target was es2016 so you'll
actually see all of these
methods that we are using
let's see if we can find the includes
method
here's some interesting stuff this is uh
typescript dealing with like the class
syntax and private fields and properties
it has like a helper method to deal with
that
so
that is kind of interesting
so let me just show you if we
downgraded this to like ES3 a prior spec
of JavaScript as our Target
I just want to show you how that plays
out with the output
it'll be tough to see so let's open up
view.js and just kind of watch the code
as we recompile this to a different
Target
you can see that all of this stuff
changed and if we go back to es 2016
and then recompile and you can also see
we get all these errors because we're
using things we're using language
features that were not available back in
that ES3 spec so the compiler is going
to give errors so now let's go back to
our valid syntax and you'll see like
this will update so
you can see the modules that we're using
but anyways that's just a kind of fun
little tidbit to kind of explain that TS
config a little bit more
but I want to wrap this up by just
walking through
why this was so important to refactor to
typescripts and why someone would go to
the effort to do this
the value in typescript does not really
come as you are you know retyping things
it comes when you're trying to refactor
things or add new features
so if we went to the JS folder and we
went to
let's say
the store
and let's say that we came down and we
wanted to I don't know change the type
that stats uh returned or something like
that
well if we went through here and let's
say
we updated this property wins to like
win count
okay so it's not going to complain at
all right here
but what you'll see is that if we try to
recompile this
so yarn TSC
it's going to give us errors that were
no longer there and the reason being is
in our view on line 59 so let's open The
View
and go to line 59
you'll see that we have this underline
because we are referencing the output of
this stats getter
from another place in the code base and
we are using the original property so we
would need to update that to win count
before it's going to stop complaining
and what typescript has done for us
there is you know as the developer
you're going through and you're changing
a method and this method is dependent on
by other methods in other parts of the
code base and so typescript is smart
enough to know like hey if you change
this and it does not match up with the
rest of the code base we're going to not
compile this code base because it's just
not going to work so otherwise if you
had a vanilla JavaScript code base and
you try to do something like this
nothing would happen you you would just
think oh I I'm okay I changed that
that's fine and then you would find out
that you had errors in your project once
you started playing the game
and it was not working as intended so
that's kind of the benefit of typescript
is you get that proactive checking of
your code and you find out about errors
a lot sooner so rather than pushing a
bunch of code up to GitHub and deploying
it and finding out that something's
broken in your app you just don't it it
just does not get deployed correctly and
it doesn't build correctly if it's not
correct code so that's kind of the the
appeal of typescript I'm going to put
this back to wins now
now like I was saying you would probably
want to type this A Little Bit Stronger
so if you were going back to the stats
getter what you can also do is set a
return type on this so if we wanted to
open up our types.ts file
let's bring that over here to the right
and maybe we wanted to actually annotate
the expected return of this function
which is usually a good idea with
functions it's it's better to be
explicit and I'll show you exactly why
in a second
so let's say this type is called derived
game
state or something like that and you
don't have to Define this here you could
Define it in this file itself and I
would actually say that that's probably
the better place for it because it's
specific to this file
so let's actually get rid of types.ts
and we'll open this same file twice just
so we can edit it in different places
and I'll usually throw types at the top
of the file so derived game state
and that is what
um or actually we don't want to call it
that we'll say
derived stats is what we want to call it
and now I'm going to assign the return
value
of stats to derive stats and as we see
it right now
looks like
nobody's complaining and that's because
we've defined this as an empty object
but let's say that we defined it as a
string now this is going to complain
because our return type does not match
the explicitly annotated return type
that we had assigned it
so now our job is to Define this
and we can see that ties is an easy one
that's going to be a number
so you can see that immediately we get
this feedback where this looks okay but
player with stats does not
so we can come up and say player with
stats
and you could just say any
that satisfies it but what does that get
you it doesn't really help you
throughout your code base because now
anything can be passed here you don't
get that explicit type checking
so what we want to do is say that this
is going to be a player array
now let's see it doesn't seem to be
complaining about that because
this does satisfy player array it also
has this wins property so we need to
document that too
so really what we need to do
is make another type
that is player with wins and that is
going to be an intersection type or a
union type I should say
and we can actually use this and symbol
to add properties so we can say wins
and that will be a number
so now player with wins represents what
we're returning here
and we can pass that in right here now
if we would call this once again
um
win count now it's going to be mad
because we're calling this wins here but
our actual type is Win count
so let's match this back up and now let
me show you why explicitly uh making
these types is advantageous the first
thing is if we go over to The View
dot TS where we had originally
referenced these stats
you can see that we can now import the
derived stats
and we'll import that from the store
so we no longer need this right here
we'll get rid of that entirely and then
we'll add a type annotation so we're
just importing the types
so now stats is derived stats and then
let's also say derived game this has not
been defined yet but we can export that
as derived game
and then we'll import that from the
store
now it's complaining because we're
trying to destructure properties off of
derived game which at the moment is just
an empty object
now we know
looking at the store that what we're
returning from the game method
is going to be the derived game
and if we look at the return type here
it has a array of moves
so we can import that here
it has a current player
so we can assign it a player
and then a status which is an object
that has
we've actually already defined that too
so that is the game
status from our types
so remember if we go to types.ts
we had the move type already defined so
we just use that there we had the player
type right here so we defined it here
and then we had the game status right
here which we passed to status so using
these types we composed a derived game
which is returned
from this game getter method we've
explicitly typed that as well
and you can see winner is not
correct here because I think we have a
mismatch
and I think I pointed this out earlier
but I
I don't know let's see
ah so explicitly typing this actually
um exposed I believe a little problem
here it says player or null is not
assignable to type player
um so we're allowing the winner to be
equal to null
so if we go to our original types
and go to game status this should
actually be player or null it should not
just be player because if it's null that
means we have a tie a tie game
so that was something that we fixed by
being more explicit which is a good
thing and why you should always
explicitly you know Define your types
where where appropriate
so now it's not yelling at us for this
anymore
uh we're looking good let's see if that
broke anything elsewhere
so now we have explicitly typed the
render method to pass in a derived game
and derived stats
and now the benefit of doing this if we
come back to store
and we go back to this game method or
let's say stats
earlier we were looking at Stats and we
changed a property on stats so remember
we previously had no explicit return
type so we just passed win count
just like that and nothing highlighted
here so if I was a developer and this
was a big project and someone else had
written this function
it's not very clear to me
what the contract of this function is
how it's being used outside or anything
like that so I could come in and change
this name to win count and not have any
clue that that affected something in
another file until I compile it so if we
explicitly say derived stats now when we
change it it's going to complain because
it the wins is declared here but we are
calling that win count so if we put that
back to wins
now it's going to be happy and it gives
us the assurance that we didn't break
something elsewhere within our code base
so having done these additional typings
let's close things out
and run TSC
and everything compiled and if we come
back our game is working
just fine so that's kind of the benefit
um kind of bringing this full circle got
the benefits of typescript I've
demonstrated a lot of this but really I
hope that this video has given you a
brief introduction to typescript
um just giving you some practical
examples and kind of a code along
um to to get your feet wet with this and
also to kind of see how we can take a
vanilla project and Port it over to
typescript and get that setup done so if
you like this video give it a like
subscribe to the channel and I will see
you in the next video which is going to
be the same project but we're going to
build it in react so we're going to take
that vanilla JS and make it you know
into a react app and then eventually
we'll actually do another typescript
refactor where we'll take that react app
and do this same process of typing
things so I'll see you in those next
couple videos in this video I'm going to
be rebuilding a vanilla JavaScript
application to a react application and
the purpose of this video is to show you
how you transition from that vanilla to
react and what problems react is
basically solving for you why you would
want to do this in the first place and
just some basic introduction to you know
building with react in general the app
that we're going to be rebuilding is
this tic-tac-toe game and this is
actually a game that I had created in a
prior video and I'd shown you how to go
from complete scratch nothing on paper
to a fully working vanilla HTML CSS in
JavaScript tic-tac-toe game so the first
thing we're going to do is learn how to
set up a react
so what that means we're going to learn
how to take a vanilla react app so just
regular JavaScript and set it up from
scratch so from scratch let me zoom out
a little bit this step right here is
going to take I think it's going to be
like over an hour so if you want to skip
that if you don't care how it's set up I
would highly suggest that you learn this
if you haven't dug into it on your own
but if you already know how this all
works and you know what's going on under
the hood to set up react app you can
skip this the next chapter is going to
be convert from JS to typescript so
we're going to take that react app and
implement it in typescript before we
even write anything and the reason being
is I just want to do this project in
typescript because it's you know just
the best best way to write a react app
in my opinion just that you have strong
type safety and then finally we're going
to take
the vanilla Javascript app
and convert it to a react typescript app
so I'm going to basically show you how
you take the ideas that we put together
in that prior video that you should have
watched or at least gone over we take
that MVC model view controller pattern
and we translate that to the paradigms
that react actually works with so you'll
get to see how that translation looks
and what problems react is trying to
solve for us so that'll be a really fun
conversion that we'll be doing
and I will just highlight that this
conversion is not me walking you through
how to build step-by-step this app it's
really to just recognize those patterns
we're not going to be going through like
okay now we're putting this element in
and styling it adding this event
listener we're going to be doing a lot
of lifting and shifting you know copy
pasting and reorganization so that's
kind of what you should expect for this
video let me be a abundantly clear from
the beginning if you are looking for a
video that is going to hold your hand to
create a react app from scratch this is
not the video to watch you should not be
watching this video
I'll say this a couple times but if you
really want the best introduction to
react go to the new react docs and go to
the tic-tac-toe tutorial no relation
necessarily to the one that we're doing
here and go through this step by step
and build this react app this is going
to be the best and most straightforward
way to learn that there are just a
couple prerequisites to this video
number one and most importantly make
sure you're familiar with the code base
for the tic-tac-toe game and the reason
I say that is because I'm going to be
glossing over a lot of the
implementation details in the logic of
like how the game works
so if you haven't seen the prior videos
which will be in the description as
links
or at least read through the code base
to the point where you understand the
control flow
and understand the goals of what we're
doing with this game right here so you
can play the game you can reset it you
can reset the scoreboard down here with
a new round it's a relatively simple
game but definitely need to understand
what's going on
so that's the first prerequisite then
HTML CSS and JavaScript you need to be
at least a basic Proficiency in them I
have a 21 hour course in the description
that you can go through if you need to
get up to speed with that so go check
that out if you feel behind on those
three
and then finally a basic understanding
of react and understanding what jsx is
in the first place you know the idea of
a functional component those basic
concepts and to do that I would go to
the react documentation and make sure
that you're on the beta react docs not
the old ones because this these
documentation or this documentation is
way better it was completely Rewritten
over the course of like two years
and they did an excellent job with this
so I would actually go to the
tic-tac-toe tutorial this is kind of
funny that this is the example that they
give and this is what we're building I
actually did not mean to do that
but anyways go through this tic-tac-toe
tutorial and just skim through it you
don't need to you know build it all from
scratch but the goal here is to just get
a basic understanding because I'm not
going to be going through all the like
really basic concepts like react props
or component props and passing props
down that kind of stuff we're just going
to kind of jump into things
so that'll be great for you if you've
already kind of gone through the basics
you just need to see a real life example
built live and that way you know you can
just follow along and try to pick things
up as we go and when I say a basic
understanding of react what does that
actually mean well I would expect that
anyone watching this video has can at
least get some sort of react App working
they understand you know what jsx is all
about so let's just write this down
understand what jsx is you should
understand
what a prop
is so this is just a property that you
are passing to a component that that
component reads as part of their render
cycle so
these are some pretty basic Bare Bones
concepts of react and then finally you
should understand what a functional
component is so just at a very basic
level and in the react documentation
make sure that you're on the new beta or
at least at the time of this video it's
in beta but make sure you're on these
docs the new ones they're great they
were Rewritten over the course of two
years and lots of effort was put into to
this and they're just awesome so you can
learn a lot from this and I honestly
part of the reason I'm not making a
beginner level react tutorial is because
of these docs right here I think that
this is the best place to go learn how
to build a react application and
specifically before you start in this
video if you have no react experience I
would go to the Quick Start
and at least skim through the tutorial
on building a tic-tac-toe game this is
actually kind of ironic I did not mean
to replicate the same thing as the react
docs I actually didn't know that this
was the example so that'll be good you
can kind of read through their
implementation and how they approach
this problem and then how I approached
it in this video because I was not
looking at this when
I originally built it so skim through
this build it if you want to can't hurt
and most importantly go to thinking and
react and make sure that you've
understood kind of the ideas here
and then finally this will just help you
along the tutorial that we're doing here
I would go down to managing state or
actually let's see
so adding interactivity and go to the
article or page that's called State a
components memory and just skim through
this just so that you have a basic
understanding of the use State hook
which is linked right here because we
will be using this throughout the video
and it'll be good to just have a basic
understanding of it now I could sit here
and say go read this go read that but
ultimately we're gonna just jump into
some code and the best way to learn is
to just do things so I will be sure to
point out different parts of this
documentation as we approach those
specific Concepts within the build
obviously you're welcome to read through
any of this and I would recommend
reading the entire react docs at some
point because it's just a good learning
experience but with that you don't want
to waste any more time if you meet these
prerequisites we will go ahead and get
started okay so we're going to look at
react here and specifically where do we
start so as a beginner or honestly even
as an intermediate level developer the
question of where do you start when
you're building a react application is
actually more valid than you might think
seems like a silly question but there's
a lot of ways that you can start
building a react application you could
start as simple as just including a
script tag in your HTML and using react
like that you could even include Babel
or Babel however you say that which
takes the jsx and turns it into
JavaScript and you could use that all
within the HTML document so
if we went over to our our refactor here
what I'm talking about is literally just
putting scripts right here and you could
serve react from a CDN and you have
react in your project so that's one
option another option is you could use
like a code sandbox so if we went to
code sandbox and here you can go new
from template and you've got these
templates react typescript or react and
if you click react it will just spin up
react application for you it's working
and you can go ahead go ahead and add
additional things to it so hello again
and you're already programming in react
so this is probably the quickest way now
you could also go to things like as
which is kind of a meta framework
sitting around react you can go to
create react app
I'm not even going to go through all the
possibilities just know that there's a
lot of different options here and the
one that I'm going to choose is actually
not recommended by really any
documentation that you would see if you
go to the react quick start it's going
to give you an idea of where to
start so start a new react project and
if you go down to this section it says
if you're learning react we recommend
create react app now the unfortunate
thing about create react app and you
know other Alternatives that kind of
just spin it up for you is that you
don't get to understand what's happening
behind the scenes you don't really
understand what what react really is at
its core so the approach that I'm going
to take here is actually a lot more
similar to how code sandbox sets this up
so as you can see in code sandbox if you
go to index.js you'll see this file
right here where we're actually creating
a root element in the Dom and then we're
using some react helper methods to
basically render that react application
in the root element that we've specified
for react to use this gets us a lot
closer to what react is doing at its
core and so this is where I'm going to
start now you might notice over here in
the files pane I know this is kind of
small let me make it bigger you're not
going to see any sort of build tools
going on so you're not going to see
webpack or anything like that it just
works and unfortunately this also makes
an abstraction over react that makes you
not really understand what's going on so
not only are we going to start right
here at its most basic level we're also
going to kind of spin up our own to
build tools so that we understand how
we're taking the jsx
converting it to JavaScript bundling it
into one file and then including that in
our index.html again the purpose of this
video is primarily to show you how you
take a vanilla JavaScript application
and Port that over to react and to show
the problems that react is solving for
you and to do that we need to basically
do everything from scratch so consider
this a learning opportunity not so much
hey how do I most quickly get a react
application working furthermore the
approach we're going to take in this
video is not what I would recommend you
use to create a production ready app
that you're gonna you know deploy and
work on with a ton of people this is
kind of the most minimal setup that you
could possibly have and is great for
smaller projects some people would
probably disagree but I think next.js is
probably your best bet in terms of a
production ready react framework this is
basically a react meta framework that
takes a lot of the common things that
you might have to do in react such as
like managing images and routing and all
that kind of stuff different rendering
methods and it just comes out of the box
ready to go so this is what I would
check out if you're wanting to build
something in production anyways not
going to get too distracted there let's
get started building our react app so
the first step with any project is to
set up the initial you know
index.html and get it working in
development development mode so that you
can basically just go over to the
browser and anytime the code changes it
will update the application so that is
the first step and the way that we'll do
that with react is let's go ahead and
create a new folder called live react
refactor and then our folder structure
here is going to be the public folder
which is going to have like public
static assets that will serve
and then we'll also have an SRC or
Source folder this is where our react
application and components are going to
go
so in the public folder this is actually
where the index.html file is going to go
because this is a static file there's
really nothing Dynamic about HTML so we
can just serve that directly so let's go
ahead and just copy that we'll go back
to the vanilla refactor once again you
should be familiar with this before
watching this video so we'll copy
index.html and we will paste it over to
the public directory now with react we
are building things with different
paradigms we are not including all of
this HTML in this index file
we're going to be creating components to
deal with this HTML so therefore we can
actually strip a lot of this stuff out
so let's take pretty much all of the
body content
and delete it the second thing that
we're going to do is change the title
this is going to be the react refactor
and then just for the moment we're going
to comment out the script
and save this we'll put a little text in
here hello world
so this should be a basic HTML document
now you'll see in the bottom right
corner I'm using live server so I talked
about this in Prior videos it's a vs
code extension that you can set up it's
running on Port 5500 and that's actually
what we're looking at here with the
vanilla refactor but if we go back to
the base of this you'll see that we now
can look at the live react refactor
and go to the public directory and now
we have a Hello World document now if we
wanted to connect some styles to this
you can see we have this style sheet
left over from the previous project but
it is referencing the CSS directory
index.css now for this react refactor
I'm going to name this something a
little differently we're going to put a
new file in here called
globals.css and the reason that I call
it globals is because with react we're
able to kind of scope our CSS per
component rather than per the whole
project and so this is just a naming
convention that I'm using to make it
explicit that anything that we put in
global CSS is going to apply to
everything that we use in every
component that we make and that's
because we're putting it in the
index.html to start us out I'm going to
go to the vanilla refactor and just copy
everything from that index.css and paste
it here
and we will eventually move some of this
stuff out of this globals file into
component specific CSS files but for now
it's just going to all be there and now
we have to update our path and this is
going to be
globals.css and if we save this and go
back to the browser you can see that
here's our hello world pretty small
there but then we also have the correct
background color so we know that the CSS
file is connected now if we're just
looking at this document this is not a
react application yet there's nothing
here that tells us that this is react
in order to actually convert this to a
react application we need the JavaScript
to be controlled by react and therefore
we need a script tag
so what we're going to do is create
something called an entry point you
might see this called
index.js or
you know entry point or it could be
named pretty much whatever but in our
source folder I'm going to be very
explicit and just call this
entrypoint.js and in this file this is
where we're going to initialize react
now going back to the code sandbox that
I had shown you a little bit earlier you
can see this pattern right here where
the code sandbox is basically importing
react and importing the react Dom client
and then doing something you can
actually find this in the react
documentation if you go to add react to
a website and then I think at the bottom
run the jss jsx preprocessor let's see
so somewhere right here you can see
where it's you know calling create root
and then root dot render it's not really
called out explicitly which is a little
bit unfortunate but it kind of shows you
how you know you might know to do this
but anyways we're going to write this
out in our file so the first thing that
we'll do is we will import the strict
mode for react and the reason we'll do
this is because it basically parses
through your code and it finds all sorts
of mistakes that you might make when
writing a react application it's just a
good practice to get into to have that
in strict mode
but you might say well how are we
importing from react when we don't even
have that included in our index.html or
node modules and the answer is we're
really not if we tried this it's going
to break so at this point we're going to
install some dependencies for our
project so let's CD into the live react
refactor
then I'm going to run yarn init Dash y
to accept all the defaults
this will save a package Json to our our
folder here
now what I'm going to do is add the
required react dependencies so really
the only things that you need from react
yarn add react and then react Dom
so let's go ahead and add those you'll
see those populate in our dependencies
this is all we need to create a react
application
so now we can go back to our entry point
and this should work okay now we need to
import the create root method
and this will be from react Dom slash
client and now here is where we
basically insert react into our HTML
document remember react is just a bunch
of JavaScript that knows how to
basically manipulate the Dom and render
things
it doesn't actually you know create HTML
files for you
you have to have an index.html to put it
in so what we'll do is we will Define a
root element
and this is going to be a element that
we select from the Dom so if you
remember from our vanilla refactor if we
go to the JS and go to view.js where we
are selecting all of these elements via
the query selector
and then we're in the query selector
we're basically just looking at the
document and selecting an element well
we're going to do the same exact thing
here we're going to say document
dot get element by ID this is the same
as doing query selector with a hashtag
in front to select an ID it's just a
little bit more specific
if you have an ID assigned to an element
so we're going to get an element by ID
and we're going to call this the react
root now where did I get this name well
I made it up and we're going to connect
it here over in the body so what you
need to do is make a div
and then you're going to give it an ID
and call it react root
so what this is doing is it's saying hey
here's a container div now react find
this container div and put all of your
application code right here inside of it
so basically we're giving it a container
to render into
and at this point we've just selected
the root element this is just going to
be an element now we have to create the
react root so we'll call that root and
we will call the create root function
that we imported from the react Dom
client
and we're going to pass in that root
element that we had selected so that is
the react root and then finally we can
now call a react Dom specific method
called render
and what we're going to render is a
strict mode container
so now we're using jsx and we're going
to render strict mode and then we're
going to say hello
World react
and this is just arbitrary jsx code
now what you might notice is that this
is a DOT JS file we could call this dot
jsx because we're using jsx in here and
then we'll get JavaScript react down
here in the vs code language mode so it
will just give us some better syntax
highlight highlighting in addition to
that when we go to basically transpile
these from jsx to JS this file extension
will allow us to kind of Target this
file to do that for so let's save this
entry point
now let's go to index.html we will for
now keep this script out of here and
save this at this point you might say
well okay all right we're done with the
initial setup for react we've got this
react root div and then we've got this
entry point.jsx which is selecting it
and rendering the react application
within it but if we were to go to the
index.html in the browser
so our live refactor and let's inspect
this
if you inspect this it's just going to
show you the react root but there's not
going to be anything within it and this
makes sense if you really think about it
because what's happening when we re
request this right here from like some
server in this case our local computer
is the server that is serving that
index.html file to the browser
but basically what's going to happen is
the browser is going to load some path
and that path is going to make a get
request to some server the server is
going to send back an index.html
document
then what the browser is going to do is
it's going to read through the document
and it's going to parse through all of
the HTML and it's going to also parse
through any script tag that it sees you
can see that we've got a script tag here
but that's just injected by live server
that's not anything to do with the
application that we've built so what's
missing well as you can see in our HTML
document aside from this live server
script we don't have any script so this
code that we wrote in the entry
point.jsx
this is just living in isolation right
now it's not actually imported and run
within our index.html document yet and
so therefore it has no way to select
that route and render anything so your
next option your next guess might be
okay let's just uncomment this script
script and then we'll go to the source
slash entry point
dot jsx all right so we're trying to
import that script but if we go to the
browser that's obviously not going to
work if you go to the console you're
going to get loading module from blah
blah because the mime type was wrong
there's just going to be all sorts of
problems here and the reason is because
a jsx file one that has actual jsx in it
is not going to natively run inside the
browser you might get this stuff to run
we could probably see if that worked so
let's console log the root element looks
like even that's not going to work and I
don't really care to debug that because
we know that this is just not a good
strategy in the first place so pause the
video and just ask yourself if we can't
do this then what can we do how do we
actually get that JavaScript to run
inside the browser in a script tag and
the answer is that we need to transform
the code that we have written the jsx
code into vanilla JavaScript script and
then put that into another file and then
import that other file right here if you
watch the prior video also linked in the
description where we took the vanilla
JavaScript build and we refactored it to
typescript you might remember that we
had some sort of build step where we had
to take the typescript code that was not
valid in the browser and we had to
compile that with the typescript
compiler into valid JavaScript that we
could run in the browser this is no
different what we have to do here is we
have to
not necessarily compile I think the
correct term here is to transpile so
let's actually go look that up so
transpile versus compile
I should know this so compiling is the
process of taking the source code
written in one language and transforming
it to another transpiling is the process
of taking source code written in one
language and transforming it into
another language that has a similar
level of abstraction so in other words
it's not a real huge difference and we
don't need to get hung up on the the
differences there but what I want to
take you to now is a website
some documentation for Babel or Babel I
never know how to say this and on the
home page if we just zoom in a little
bit
what you'll see is that it gives you an
example of how you put in some Next
Generation JavaScript and then you get
browser compatible JavaScript out in
other words Babble I'm just going to go
with Babel is a tool that will take some
sort of JavaScript some a flavor of it
that doesn't work in a browser and make
it work in a browser one of those things
that it can do is jsx so if we come down
to the presets this is just the the
playground you can see that it's using
the react preset so it knows you know
that we can write jsx code and if we
were to write you know something like
just a regular P tag
hello world and then close that P tag
off what you'll see on the right
is that it's using the react library to
create a new element in the Dom and then
render the hello world text within it
we could also wrap this in say a div
so we're just writing what looks like
HTML but really this is jsx
so now we're creating elements and we
could probably I think in this
playground even write a component so
this will be a function component and
instead of just this isolated jsx we
will return that from the function
and oops
format this a little bit better so you
can see that worked and it's returning a
JavaScript function that returns these
create element calls and then we could
even render that so let's make our app
and then we want to return
the component as a jsx component and now
you can see that all of this is going to
be valid JavaScript so this is just a
DOT JS file that we could include in
that index.html file so this right here
is totally valid to put in this script
tag
this right here is not valid and it will
not work now Babel under the hood is
running a bunch of code against this to
get it to this state and therefore we're
going to need some intermediate step to
get it to this point now once again just
like there's many ways to create a react
application there's also many ways to
transpile code and Babel is not your
only option
another option is you could use if
you're writing this in typescript which
hint we are actually going to convert
this to typescript in just a few minutes
you could use the typescript compiler to
do this because the typescript compiler
actually supports jsx you could use
Babel and you could also use something
like webpack which is a build tool so
that's what we're going to do I know
it's not it this is not the latest and
greatest tool chain this is mainly for
educational purposes but if we go to
some more documentation let's go to
webpack docs and now we're dealing with
a bundler so it does more than just
bundle code but the purpose of using
webpack is to take a bunch of different
JavaScript files and squash them into
one Javascript file that we call a
bundle if you really want to understand
why we need a bundler
I've written a post that I've referenced
a couple times at this point throughout
this video series and it's the Scripps
versus common JS UMD AMD es6 modules and
if you come down to the bottom let's see
so the last step module bundlers this is
where I go through and explain why do we
need a module bundler in the first place
so I'd recommend reading this short post
just to get a better understanding there
but our goal is to basically take this
entry point jsx file
and then we're going to have many many
other jsx files that will have all our
different components and instead of
coming to index.html and copying this
down and importing every single script
that's been transpiled from jsx to JS
this is going to get very confusing
our goal is to just do this we're going
to have one file and it's going to come
from the public directory and it's going
to be called
bundle.js and we don't need the type
module anymore because we're using react
code and we don't need to worry about
that but this is our end State and I
actually need to update this because
remember
index.html is actually in the public
directory so we just need to reference
it relatively so the bundle.js will be
output keyword output it's not created
yet into this public folder and will sit
next to globals.css and
index.html so the question becomes how
do we get it there how do we get this
bundle.js to compile into the public
folder the answer is webpack or
something similar once again this has
kind of gone a little bit out of style
but that doesn't matter our purposes
here are educational to understand
what's going on under the hood of react
when we set it up in the first place and
you'll hear all sorts of things like oh
webpacks so outdated but ultimately tons
of projects are still highly dependent
on this and will be for many years to
come so don't get spooked by you know
anyone saying that this is irrelevant
this is very relevant and the concepts
that we'll learn through it are even
more relevant so let's get started
there's a lot to this documentation lots
of different configuration Concepts and
I'm not going to go through these
because you really don't need 90 of this
for our purposes so what I will do is
just start writing the configuration and
we'll come back to the documentation to
point out the individual options that
we're using
so in order to start a webpack a project
we need to initialize it with a
configuration file now if you go to the
documentation there should be something
about the configuration here
so introductory configuration and you
can see it's called
webpack.config.js so let's just copy
this let's copy that default and we will
make in the base of our directory a
webpack.config.js file
and let's just copy that basic example
in there now bear with me a little bit
for the next couple minutes this is
going to get slightly confusing and
you're welcome to skip over this section
if you want I have time for this video
so if you want to skip over these
details and just get started building
the react application you can do so but
I would highly recommend going through
this section it's really a good thing to
understand what's going on here and
we'll serve you for the rest of you know
your developer lifetime just
understanding this stuff you probably
won't have to touch it again but it's
good to just know what's going on under
the hood so let's take this line by line
first off the mode this is in
development and if you go to the
concepts
let's go to environment and right here
it says the mode is an option that can
be development production or none and
this is going to enable certain
optimizations that are done in
production so webpack will do certain
things I believe it's like like
minifying the code and stuff like that
depending on your environment so we are
in development what we can do to make
sure that this runs depending on our
actual environment let's say that we
were deploying this somewhere what we
know is that the
process.env.node EnV is going to equal
production when we deploy it on some
server this is just a default that you
know any deployment site or Cloud host
is going to assign so if there is a
process node EnV we're going to use that
otherwise we're going to use development
so in other words development is our
fallback but we're going to look at the
node EnV to determine
what to use for this mode now this of
course assumes that you're only allowed
to assign development or production to
node EnV if you were you know had like a
staging environment then this wouldn't
work but
most of the time it's either production
or development so this should work now
our entry this is a little
self-explanatory so we don't need to go
to the docs for this this is going to be
the file that webpack will start from it
will start reading that file and then it
will Trace all of the Imports that have
come into that file and kind of just
walk down the code tree to find all the
relevant files that it needs to
basically bundle up so in our case
entrypoint.jsx is going to be that
and we are in the root of our folder so
we need to look in the source folder
entry point jsx so we'll say relative to
source
entrypoint.jsx
that's going to be our entry point and
then output is also somewhat
self-explanatory it's going to Output a
single file we're going to call this
just
bundle.js and it's going to put it into
the dist director now we're going to
just rename this instead of dist which
is stands for distribution and it's a
very common place to Output your your
build output we'll just call this public
and the reason being is we've got this
public folder and what we want is that
bundle.js file to get output to public
now some would argue that you kind of
want to separate these concerns and
maybe you want to Output this to dist
and then copy over your index.html and
CSS to dist so that it's all kind of
isolated into this you know build output
but for our project it's pretty simple
this makes sense and we can just output
this to the public directory so let's
save this we will save entry point and
now the question becomes well how do we
actually use webpack well you could
install webpack globally in your path or
better than that you can install webpack
pin it to a specific version for this
project that's what we're going to do
we're going to say yarn add then we're
going to add a Dash D because this is a
development dependency remember webpack
is just here to look at all of our code
and bundle it up into something that can
actually run in the browser we don't
need it after it has done its job we can
just run the code that output and not
deal with anything else so what we can
do is just add webpack so
go ahead and do that and now what I'm
going to do is go to package Json and
we're going to add some Scripts not
necessary but it's just convenience here
and something that I want to add is a
build script so this will run when we
say yarn build
is it's going to run this script right
here and what I want it to do is look in
the development dependencies and just
run webpack so we'll save that and now
what's going to happen if we run yarn
build
so yarn build it's going to invoke the
webpack binary that we just installed
and webpack automatically knows to look
for the
webpack.config.js file in the root
directory and then this config has
basically told the the binary to look at
this entry point
read through all the code and output it
to this bundle.js but if we were to run
this we really haven't given it any
instructions as to like how to do this
so let's just try to run yarn build and
it's saying that we need to install the
webpack client I guess I had forgotten
to do that so we'll say yes that's going
to actually update our package Json you
can see that here in Dev dependencies
or I'm sorry we're in the final one
there
live react refactor
so now we have webpack and webpack
client
so at this point we run yarn build and
you can see that we're going to get an
air of some sort and it says module
parse failed unexpected token you may
need an appropriate loader to handle
this file type currently no loaders are
configured to process this file
and what it's complaining about is this
jsx that we have written
so if we go to entry point by default
webpack does not know how to deal with
jsx it doesn't know how to transpile
this right here
and this is where Babel will come in so
going back to Babel we talked about how
its job is to take this code and turn it
into this code and so therefore we need
to add something called a loader to
webpack so if we go to the documentation
there it says loaders are
transformations that are applied to the
source code of a module they allow you
to pre-process files as you import or
load them so I'm going to save us quite
a bit of pain here and I'm just going to
show you how to get this working with
react I'll be completely honest this is
confusing stuff I would not spend a
whole lot of time beating your head
against the wall to try to understand it
at a super deep level the overall goal
here is to just understand the process
that our code is going through not
necessarily all of these implementation
details so what we need to do is add a
module property and this module is a
valid on the config
and then we'll say rules and then we
give it an array of rules now each of
these rules is going to basically say
like hey once you see this certain type
of file in you know coming from the
entry point here's how you actually you
know look at it and transpile it and
bundle it so the first rule that we're
going to do is we're going to test so
this is going to be a regular expression
that we're handing it and we're going to
say if you see any file that has a jsx
extension at the end of it then go ahead
and apply this rule
but
if you see anything in node modules
exclude it because we don't want to put
that into our bundle and then finally
here's where we're going to use a
specific loader
and that loader is going to be called
the Babel loader okay so right here
we're importing something that's
external so we need to install that as a
Dev dependency if you go to Babel let's
we're getting
got a lot of tabs open here at this
point let's open one more
so Babble docs and then let's just go
down if you go to presets you can see
there's a preset for react and it gives
you all this really confusing stuff okay
so here we get a list of all the
different loaders that we can use so
let's start with the babble loader so we
click on that
and it says disclaimer it's a
third-party package maintained by
community members
so this will need to be installed and
here's the install command you need to
install the babble loader Babble core
and preset now I also happen to know
that if we go to the preset react we'll
need this as well so we're going to just
kind of combine all this into one
command
so we will
clear the terminal here and then these
are all going to be developer
dependencies remember because we're just
transpiling code
so we need to grab the Babel loader so
that's for webpack then we're going to
grab Babel specific packages so we need
the core module
we need the preset M this is basically
to just kind of normalize all the
different ecmascript versions and
whatnot so that we can run JavaScript in
all browsers
and then finally Babel preset react
so we'll install all of those and we go
to our package Json
you'll see that they're all added right
there and now we can come back to our
webpack config
and this is going to work because we
have that installed
and then we'll give it some options now
this I'm not going to go into a lot of
depth because it's more on the advanced
side and we'll just assume that this is
going to work so what we first need to
give it as a preset is the Babel preset
M and once again this is just to make
sure that you know all the different
versions of ecmascript so ES3 456 2016
blah blah all of those it kind of
normalizes it so that the JS that is
loaded is going to work in all browsers
and then we're going to give it an array
where we give it the Babel or Babel
preset react
and then this is really important we
need to give it a run time of automatic
and the reason that we need that is
because when we come to entry point over
here we are going to need that so that
it automatically infers that react is
part of this application and we don't
have to explicitly import react every
time we want to use it so that's the
loader that we've set up I know that
this whole blob is a a bit confusing but
just zooming out the point of this is
saying like hey anytime you see a jsx
file that came you know as a result of
looking in entry point
so in other words anytime you see a jsx
file in our project go ahead and use the
babble loader and make sure you use the
preset react which is basically what we
were looking at here in this sandbox so
that it takes this and creates this out
of it
so now
we might be able to build our apps so
yarn build remember that's going to run
our webpack script and you can see that
we got no errors so that's a good thing
now we're not 100 sure that this worked
yet but you can see in the public folder
we now have a bundle.js and it's a bunch
of ugly code that has been you know
transpiled and this is not something
that you want to actually read through
before we get any further let's add a
DOT get ignore to our project because
we've added some developer dependencies
and build output and all that stuff does
not belong in source code so first let's
look for node modules and ignore that
and then I'm going to do this but this
is probably not a best practice in any
way we're going to look in the public
directory and ignore anything called
bundle.js and that's just because if you
look at this this is a lot of gibberish
that doesn't not belong in Source
control this is an output of a build
and that includes pretty much the whole
react library in it so we do not want to
put that in our GitHub repository so
we'll ignore that let's make sure that
that is working so we should not see any
bundle.js sorry there's actually some
leftover code from my typescript
refactor from the prior video but the
the main point is there's no bundle.js
and if you look in Visual Studio code
when it's ignored it's actually grayed
out a little bit compared to the other
files and folders so that's just a quick
trick to know whether your your file's
been ignored correct so the ultimate
test is if we visit this index.html
which is importing the bundle.js that we
just output
using entry point as the source does it
work so let's go to the browser we can
close this out I'll leave it open just
so that we have reference to it
and now you can see right here I gotta
zoom in a bunch hello worldreact so
something worked here because if you
look at entry point you can see that
that's where we're rendering the hello
world react and so we know that our
webpack config worked and we are able to
render jsx in our browser
and if we go ahead and inspect this now
you can see in the react root that's
where that P tag has been added but
there is one problem still and that is
if we go back to our code
and we say
by Zach or something like that and then
we save this
entrypoint.jsx well let's refresh the
page and uh oh it's not actually working
and the reason being is because every
time we want to add something we need to
rebuild the application so we need to
run yarn build again
that's going to compile everything and
bundle it up and now you'll see Hello
World by Zach
obviously this is a poor experience as a
developer we do not want this to
you know we don't want to have to come
and say yarn build every time we make a
change
so this is where the webpack dev server
comes in and that is basically going to
look at your webpack config and on any
change to any file that is included
there it's going to rerun this build
step and output it to the bundle which
is then going to be served to index.html
and believe it or not this didn't used
to be this easy but now you can
basically just add one extra command
here
so instead of build we're going to give
a Dev command which is our development
only command and we're going to say
webpacks serve and while we're here I'm
also going to add a build production
script and you know how we talked about
over in the config we've got this
process node EnV if we want to build it
to production we could just pass
something like this so set the
environment variable and then call
webpack
so if we ran yarn build prod it's going
to just apply some optimizations to
everything and if we look at the
bundle.js you'll also see that there's a
license emitted here that would probably
be
good to include so let's let's go ahead
and just say bundle all
and that will include the license as
well but if you look at this now it's
optimized where like everything is
minified it's all you know squashed
together which makes it a smaller bundle
to load over the wire over an HTTP
request so yarn build is going to create
something with lots of spaces and it's
not optimized and then yarn build prod
is going to optimize that but anyways we
want to run this in development mode so
let's run yarn Dev which is going to run
the webpack serve command and this is
going to say for using this command we
need the webpack dev server package so
we'll accept that you'll see that that
was added down here at the bottom and
now you can see that it's a running
process that is just waiting for changes
so we'll go back to our our index.html
you can see Hello World by Zach and then
if we go to the entry point jsx let's
remove that and save it you'll see that
this just refreshed Reloaded
and if we refresh this page it's not
doing anything ah so I am just not
thinking whatsoever and totally totally
messed this up so if we try to go
directly to index.html in the browser
and we are running this over live server
so localhost 5500 we're just going to
get the static contents of the public
directory now if we look at the output
of the webpack dev server it says that
the project is running at localhost
8080. so we can kill the live server at
this point so we'll close that server
now if you reload this page we got it
way zoomed in
but if you reload this page it's going
to say unable to connect but if we go to
localhost 8080
now you'll see here's our hello world
react is working again and then if we go
back and make a change
and save that it's going to hot reload
and update in the browser automatically
so the mistake I made I just I was
trying to look at the static contents
from live server we need to go to a
different port here the next step here
is to replace this content with our app
so we can come over to our files and
next to entry point let's call it
app.jsx
and this is just going to return a basic
application wrapper that we're just
going to consolidate all of that logic
to we can go ahead and use es6 modules
so we'll export a default function
called app
and then this will return some div and
then say my app
now we can import that into the entry
point
so import app from app
and then replace this content with the
jsx element just like that
and we're getting an error I think we
might need to say app.jsx
yep that's all we needed to do it
couldn't resolve that without the
extension and I believe that happens
because our webpack config doesn't know
how to kind of parse through and import
that if we don't have the extension on
it so now
this entry point is basically done we
don't have to look at this anymore
because it's all set up and now we're
going to be working from this app.jsx so
let's go make sure that it works my app
now let's connect some per component
styles
so we're going to use just vanilla CSS
and one way that we can do that is by
using CSS modules so we can say app.css
and let's go ahead and select everything
in this app and make it the color red
so this is not going to work by default
if we just look at our app but all we
have to do is import
and then we just import the app.css now
you'll see that there's some errors down
here and we're not able to compile and
that is because we have not specified a
CSS loader right now we're in we have an
entry point of this which is going to
eventually make it to app.jsx then it's
going to import
app.css but we don't have any rule for
that right now we're only looking for
jsx files so if we go back to the
documentation for webpack right here and
we go back to loaders
you'll see that there's some different
different categories and one of them is
styling so we have the style loader add
exports of a module as style to adopt to
the Dom or css loader load CSS file with
resolved Imports in return CSS code
we're going to need both of these and
these are third-party packages so we'll
have to install them
so let's come down to our terminal open
up another one actually we'll let's just
cut this cut the server for now
and we'll add
this as a developer dependency we'll
call it we got to get the style loader
and the CSS loader
once we've done that we can add another
rule so remember rules is going to be an
array and we can specify a CSS rule so
here we're going to test and look for
any dot CSS files
so that's what we're looking for and if
we find them we're going to use the
style loader and the CSS
loader
so let's save that that's our final rule
that we'll add
and let's run yarn Dev
and now you'll see everything compiled
successfully and if we go back to the
react refactor in refresh we had to
refresh that first time because we had
restarted the server so it's red and now
if we change this
to Green it's going to hot reload and
everything is going to be green
so at this point we have our entire
webpack configuration done we have our
entry point to the react app setup and
our index.html is importing that bundle
that we are you know basically
compiling and bundling together with the
help of webpack and Babel I know we've
spent a solid amount of time just
setting up this react app in the first
place but I hope that it has been
educational and given you a better sense
of what's going on under the hood this
is basically what the create react app
and all of the other you know Frameworks
that lets you set up a react app they're
all doing some version of this under the
hood but that's abstracted away from you
and so oftentimes you don't understand
what react actually is at its core level
so there's one more thing that we're
going to do and I kind of debated this a
little bit but I want to build this
react app with typescript rather than
you know doing a whole another
additional video where we refactor it to
typescript I think using typescript is
really awesome especially with react
apps and across the stack and it's not
going to be too difficult to translate
what we have here to typescript and it
will also give you a better idea of how
we translate vanilla to typescript from
a build step perspective if you're not
interested in this and you just can't
wait to get started once again
timestamps are in this video skip to the
build where we actually start building
out this application and you know
translating it from that vanilla
JavaScript to react so let's cut this
server and I will also add that there is
a typescript branch and then a main
branch for the repository in the
description that follows and basically
has all the final code here this is a
combined video so you can find the
vanilla JavaScript react app in the main
branch and then the one that we're
building in this video will end up in
the typescript branch so I'll leave that
in the description and kind of label it
so that it's clear so if you haven't
watched the prior video where I
converted a vanilla Javascript app to a
basically vanilla typescript app go
watch that because it will cover a lot
of the basic concepts that I'm going to
gloss over in the next few minutes
so I'll leave that in this the
description but the first thing we need
to do is install typescript so we'll add
that as a developer dependency
once we have that then we can run yarn
TSC which is the compiler and we can run
init
this will create a TS config although
I missed something here it's not a knit
it is dash dash init
so that creates a tsconfig DOT Json
file
now there's all these different options
here I'm going to go ahead and just copy
the final one just because it's going to
save us some time okay so this is the
basics
um the things that I'll point out here
this is pretty much the same as that
prior video that we did but just to
point out we're targeting es6 so that's
the version of JavaScript that the build
output will be and there's one thing
that I've left out on purpose here and
that is a property called jsx so let's
go to the typescript documentation
so typescript
and then docs and then go to the
reference for the configuration file so
I'm not really sure where this would be
typescript tooling
reference let's just search it config
writing a configuration file gosh this
is very indirect I want to just go to
the reference for this
let's go typescript config reference
not sure why that's not searchable
easier but maybe I'm doing something
wrong so anyways let's look at the let's
find that jsx property that we had just
talked about so that's down in language
and environment so jsx
and it says controls how jss jsx
construct constructs are emitted in
JavaScript files This only affects
output of JS files that started in TSX
files so we have a couple of options
here we have react react.jsx jsx Dev
preserve and Native this preserve option
would be good if we were wanting to
basically compile our typescript to
JavaScript but leave the jsx as it was
and then use Babel to take jsx and
convert it to JS now for this simple of
a project we don't really need all that
in direction we can just use react jsx
and get all of that to happen for us
so let's give it to the jsx pro property
and we'll pass in react jsx and so now
the typescript compiler is not only
going to look at our typescript and
convert it to JavaScript it's also going
to recognize jsx and convert that to
JavaScript so it's kind of an all-in-one
solution which means that we can remove
all of the Babel stuff that we had just
added that was good to understand you
know how you would do something with a
vanilla application but if you're using
typescript we can remove a lot of this
complexity so instead of using all of
this Babble stuff we're going to use the
TS loader and if we and we're also going
to need to change this to TSX so it only
searches for TSX files finally we'll
need to update all our file extensions
to TSX so that it knows to grab those
we'll come back to these errors in a
second those are type errors that we're
getting let's just save this for now so
now we have all TSX files and let's go
back to this TS loader if we find this
in the loaders
it's right here for transpiling it says
it loads typescript 2.0 like JavaScript
so this is also going to be an external
one I believe so we'll need to install
it so let's open up our terminal here
and look at our package Json right now
we've got all these Dev dependencies we
have Babel core preset M you know all of
these Babel stuff and we don't really
need it anymore because typescript has
taken over the typescript compiler is
taken over and done all of that job in
addition to compiling typescript for us
so we can yarn remove all of that stuff
I'm just gonna take a little shortcut
and just delete all that
we still need the CSS and style loader
and then we of course need webpack
because we're still using that so let me
save that and just yarn install
so that's gonna refresh everything and
then let's go ahead and add a developer
dependency called TS loader
so now we have the CSS style in TS
loaders in our project and that should
work for the webpack config
now if we try to build this
we're going to get some errors oh okay
duh I need to update this to TSX because
we're not able to read the entry point
all right so now we're getting some
errors but it's a much better error it's
looking for type files for everything
for react and all that stuff and so now
we just need to install those you'll see
an entry point it's going to say try npm
save Dev types react so that's all we're
going to do is save the react types and
then I believe we also need the react
Dom types and you can see this goes away
root elements just complaining that it
could possibly be null so one thing we
could do is we could say if there's no
root element then throw new air react to
app configured incorrectly and now
that's going to solve that because we
know that that will exist
I tend to just put a exclamation at the
end to say like hey we know that this
root element is going to be found that's
okay to do in this case I think but yeah
if you wanted to be safe you'd throw an
air or log something or whatever to make
sure that that root element was selected
correctly let's try one more time yarn
build
and now it's successfully built things
into the public bundle.js so that
compiled typescript to JS and jsx to JS
so everything can now run in the browser
and let's make sure that that worked by
going not to localhost 8080
but to the static app that we had so
localhost
5500 we cannot connect to that because
live server is not running
but if we hit go live on live server and
then refresh and go to live react RE
Factor and then the public directory you
can see that we have an app running with
some styled green text
so that means that our our final build
worked okay
and then if we were to go to yarn Dev
and run that Dev server at localhost
8080.
and refresh you'll see that it refreshes
and once again we can go change this to
you know red again and that should hot
reload and change the the CSS of this
app let me close a bunch of stuff out
we'll close all the save files collapse
all this
and I'm going to collapse this terminal
it's just going to be running in the
background and if we run into some
errors we'll we'll pull it up again so
if you remember from the prior video
that we did where we refactored
everything the live TS refactor we
basically took the tic-tac-toe game and
we turned it to a typescript code base
so we've got the app we've got the store
and we've got the view and then we have
our types file this is what we're going
to be referencing and we're going to be
just lifting it over and putting it into
react code while we're doing this I'm
going to run a live server and that's
going to be over here
on this tab
we'll just grab localhost 5500 and I'm
just going to run the vanilla refactor
just so that we have a working final
version of the game so this is just
vanilla JS nothing fancy this was from
the first video this is just our
reference point and we will eventually
reach that same point over here in the
react refactor the first thing I want to
do is bring over our types file so
let's copy this file of our types
and put that in source
and looking at the types we just have a
player a move game status game and game
State the next thing that I want to do
is copy over the HTML
so we had index.html that had all of
this structure for us and we had the
main tag as well as the footer and then
finally a modal that opens when the game
ends I'm going to go ahead and copy all
of this
and just to start us out we're in the
live react refactor again
and we'll go to app.tsx
and instead of my app we're going to
return all of this HTML
so all that HTML is going in there it's
going to yell at you because we need to
put a fragment around this because we
have no parent element to all of these
and then of course we need to update all
of our class attributes to be react
compatible or jsx compatible attributes
which will be class name so let's add
that as a class name so that should fix
a few things then all of our comments
we'll just get rid of them right now
those are not valid jsx and then finally
you'll see that the style needs to be
converted this one will be will be a
little bit annoying to do so let me just
kind of speed through this real quick so
I'm just copy pasting everything from
the final version Okay so we've
converted the HTML to valid jsx
no errors going on here so we should
remember we have this server I'm just I
guess I'll keep it open here just so we
can see a little bit of it so that
should be reloading every time we save
and now you can see in our react
refactor we've got something working we
have red text everywhere because I have
not removed
from our globals
or no not globals it was app.css where
we added this
let's get rid of that because that's
annoying
and you can see now we have all of the
structure and style to our application
but if we try to click anything it's not
going to do much because we don't have
any event listeners or anything hooked
up let me go ahead and just close all
these tabs we don't really need them
anymore so the first thing that you'll
want to do when you convert something
over to a react application or you're
just building a react app from scratch
is look through your structure of your
HTML and find what parts of this will be
best as an individual component
so the first one that's pretty obvious
that I'd like to kind of rebuild is the
footer this could be its own component
and so what I'll do is I'll just start
using this convention let's add a new
folder
called components
and then in components I will just add a
footer.tsx
and then the styles for that footer will
be footer.css
one could argue that you know this
organization is not the best but it'll
work for now so the template that we're
going to work with here is basically
we're going to export the default
function
from each of these component files
and I'm trying to do this in the CSS
file
oops
okay so that looks a little bit better
so we're going to export a default
function and then return some jsx from
that and then we're going to import the
footer.css at the top so it gets all of
the component specific styles
and then here we can just go back to our
app.tsx and let's just copy the footer
entirely and paste it right in here
so this will self-contain the footer and
I don't think there's anything that we
need to modify here so we can just leave
that as is and I don't actually think
that we yes we do have some styles for
that so in our globals.css where we have
all of our Styles right now that applies
to everything we want to come down and
find the footer Styles so right here
this is where all the footer styles are
let's rip those out
and add those to footer.css
and then save both of those
and so now the Styles and the HTML
should be scoped to this one component
and we can finally come back to app.tsx
and remove the footer and replace it
with our footer component
and if you hit command period it will
add that import for us as you can see
right here so it's added the footer and
our webpack is going to hot reload
and you'll see the footer right here
down at the bottom it's working and if
you go to your developer tools let's
actually look at Firefox extensions
and let's look for react
and grab some grab the react developer
tools all right so now we have some
react developer tools and I think if we
refresh this
yep we can now see the components so you
can see that the footer is one of our
components now so this is let's zoom in
a little bit
I guess I can't zoom in unfortunately I
don't think I can zoom on
the developer tools too much it's pretty
small okay the next thing that we can do
is break out the modal itself so this
right here is the modal that we will pop
open when someone wins the game
we can bring this over to the components
and call it modal.tsx with modal.css as
the styles
and I'm just going to use this template
again so export default function
remember to import our
CSS and now what we'll do is we'll grab
all of this right here
and return it from this component
we'll go to globals.css and find all the
modal Styles which we've organized
is another reason to organize your CSS
so that when you refactor
it's pretty easy to know what goes where
so we put the modal CSS here
we'll save Global Styles we'll save that
component and then we will once again
add the modal
oops we need to import that
from our components and you're going to
notice that this is going to mess things
up a little bit so if we come to our
refactor
well actually it doesn't mess anything
up because we still have that hidden
class
so if you'll see the modal hidden class
we're going to now control these sorts
of things with react rather than classes
so I'm going to get rid of that I'm also
going to start removing all these data
IDs because we're no longer having to
select the elements we can just grab
them directly from react so now once we
remove those classes you'll see down
here at the bottom
you get this weird modal happening and
let me see what's going on there so if
we look at these Styles I think what's
happening is we are setting the position
to be fixed but we're not giving it a
reference point of where it should start
so let's give it left to zero and top
zero and now that should work okay
once again you can't click anything
there's no JavaScript functionality
quite yet but that should be styled
correctly and then if we come to app.tsx
now instead of using a hidden class that
will toggle with some in you know
implicit
event listener we can just be more
declarative about this and keep a state
of whether the modal is open or not and
then render it conditionally here so I'm
going to just create a variable right
now you'll see how this comes into play
a little bit later but we'll just make a
static variable called show modal and
we'll set that to false to start once
again you'll see how this changes in the
future so don't get caught up on how I'm
not using State correctly and stuff like
that
so show modal we're just going to wrap
it in this just like that so now we will
be able to conditionally show the modal
and then furthermore what we might want
to do is add some props to modals so we
can pass what we want to show
remember we are going to control this
text right here with JavaScript so it
would be good to add a message as props
and then we can define a
props type up here that has a message of
type string
so right here we're destructuring from
the props object and we're typing it
right here and now instead of player one
wins we can say that is set to the
message that we passed to the modal as
props
now since this is a required message if
we go back it's going to complain
because we haven't given it all of the
props for now we're just going to say
player one wins because we don't have
anything Dynamic to pass quite yet
but now you can see if we were to toggle
this from false to true
it's going to show the modal in pass in
player one wins and just to check we can
look at our components again and now we
have a footer and a modal in our app
so let's put this back to false for now
so that's not going to show and move on
to the next part that we're going to
refactor into components all right so
looking through the rest of this we
could of course make a scoreboard
component but this is not a whole lot of
HTML I think we'll just leave this here
that's really a style preference whether
you'd split that out this right here we
can simplify using some react
conventions so this will be rather
simple to do so we'll just open up some
brackets here and I'm going to make an
array that goes one through nine
and you could of course create this with
some JavaScript but let's just be
expressive about what we're doing it's a
lot easier to follow
and then from here we're just going to
map and we're going to call this the
square ID is what each of those numbers
will represent
and then for each of the square IDs
we're going to one of these div elements
now whenever you map across multiple you
know elements in an array react needs to
know the key that you're giving it and
the reason is so that it has a
predictable order that it can put these
elements in and when it goes to
re-render and figure out whether each
element has changed and it needs to
re-render in the Dom it will look at
that key to tell tell it that so we
don't need this ID anymore we also don't
need this data ID because we're not
using that old vanilla syntax we do need
the key here as I just described and we
can pass it the square ID which is
basically going to be the number on that
square
and then furthermore clean our vanilla
application we were using JavaScript to
render an i element or basically an icon
in this div so if we look back when we
click something or sorry this is the
react app we have if we click something
in the finished app it will put one of
those icons within the Box
so what we can do in react is instead of
implicitly doing this we can be or
imperatively doing this we can be more
declarative and just say let's just put
an i tag in there
give it a class name and we know this is
going to be fa solid now we're going to
have conditional classes based on which
player is currently up we haven't
implemented that quite yet but for now
I'm just going to pass in fax
and then we'll say I think that was
yellow
was X or no I think it was turquoise is
what we had for player one
we will of course come back to this but
if we render this now and then at this
point we can get rid of all of these
so just reducing that amount of code now
you'll see there's an X rendered into
each of those so we'll leave that there
for now we'll come back and make that
Dynamic later scrolling through we've
got the menu this could actually be a
good use case for another component so
we'll make it a menu component
and we'll export the default menu
function oops and then this menu is
going to have some props so we'll
initialize that and then we also want to
import the menu.css which we need to add
over here so there's your menu CSS let
me close a bunch of these
clean this up and we'll just open
oops this is from the final so there's
our menu and our menu CSS
now the first thing we'll do is let's go
over to globals and look for those menu
styles
so it looks like we got them right here
so let's copy all of those I think
that's all that we need
throw those in menu CSS
save globals
and then we'll go to index.html or I'm
sorry not index app.tsx
and at this point we can grab all that
HTML whoops did that wrong
so we'll cut that out of there
and then in our component we'll just
render that div right there
let's clean all of these data IDs up
because once again we don't need that
since we're working in react now but
pretty much anywhere that we have one of
these data IDs means that we're
registering it for a click listener so
we'll have to set up those click
listeners here so what I'm going to do
for this menu is give it an on action
property which is going to have an
action type which will either be a reset
or it's going to be a new round
you could of course do this differently
however you want I'm just simplifying
things so that all we have to do is
check the action type and then we know
which of these buttons was clicked so
we'll come down to the buttons
themselves and we'll say on click
and this one
will be an on action
oops we haven't passed the props yet so
let's initialize these so there's your
on action and then there's your props so
that's grabbing from here and typing it
out
so now we can say on action and this
will be a reset as you can see we get
this typescript support because we have
this Union type
so there's your reset
and then here's another click listener
we'll say this one is going to be the
new round
so once again you could split this into
two it's just stylistic you could
comment this out and say on reset
void and then on new round
void and then replace these
with those two different ones
and then come down here and instead of
passing
the key we'll just say on reset and on
new round and that would be the same so
same thing just a stylistic concern so
I'm going to go back to my original I
like that a little bit so now we can
throw the menu here where we took that
jsx out so there's your menu and then we
of course need the on action we'll fill
that out in a second
so let's import the menu command period
to get vs code to do that for you you
can see it got imported right there
and then the on action for right now
we're going to just put a placeholder in
there
and it's going to pass us an action
because that's what we defined and we're
just going to console log it for right
now
we'll eventually hook that up to
something now if we go to our app when
you click the actions menu you're going
to see in the console it should and
let's refresh oh we're not getting
anything because we set those listeners
on the menu items
but we also need to listen for a click
to the topmost menu so what we're going
to do is put a click listener on the
actions button
and we'll handle this internal to the
menu
so we'll say whether this is menu open
will be a piece of state that we're
going to introduce using the use State
hook
and then what we'll do is we will look
at the
let's see
we've got a function and we're going to
set menu open
and basically we're going to implement
toggle functionality by looking at the
previous state and returning the
opposite of that so it's complaining
about this because we haven't
initialized this to anything so by
giving it a false default State that's
going to type our use State and this is
Boolean
because it's going to use type inference
and it's going to initialize this to be
closed but when we click that actions
button it's going to basically toggle
the menu open and closed we can verify
this by going to the UI and clicking
this and it's not going to do anything
because we're not actually reading this
menu open state
we want to conditionally render this
piece of jsx based on whether the menu
is open
now we have this leftover hidden class
which we need to get rid of because that
will override this Behavior so now let's
open this up click actions and you can
see we can toggle this back and forth
the last thing is we need to look at
this icon and remember in the the
vanilla app we had this flipping
depending on the open state
so we can come down here where we're
rendering that icon and basically say
hey if the menu is open we're going to
render something otherwise we'll render
this
so I'll copy
this to both of them so right now it's
going to be down on both but let's go
ahead and put menu or Chevron up when
the menu is open and Chevron down when
it is closed
so there you can see it flips now
there's a slightly better way to do this
and while we don't necessarily need this
dependency it's something that I use and
it's pretty helpful so we're going to
add something called class names so
we'll say yarn add class names this is
just a utility really just a utility
function is all this represents and if
we use that
we can refactor this code right here
and
in our class name
we can import class names so we'll go to
the top and say
import class names from class names
and you can see this is just a utility a
simple JavaScript utility for
conditionally joining class names
together
pretty common that you'll see this
within react so now what we can do is we
can say we always know it's going to be
f a solid
so that's similar across the two the two
and then depending on whether the menu
is open we will either use the Chevron
up
or the Chevron
down
and delete all this
so now rather than conditionally
rendering the entire element we're just
conditionally rendering the class names
which is similar to our original
implementation so this is a good one for
me to pause on and kind of show you what
react is doing for you versus what you'd
have to do in a vanilla app
so if you remember so this is just the
menu and if you remember in our vanilla
refactor
or actually let's go to the live TS
refactors the latest one we did and we
go to JS and look at the view
and then let's go to the event listeners
where we binded the click on the menu so
this first one is where we're binding
The Click event on the menu button
and that let me let me just do this side
by side so you can see it better
so here's our react on the on the right
and then vanilla is going to be on the
left
so vanilla react and you can see that
let me zoom out just a little bit here's
our actions button and here is our click
listener on that button then here's the
state that controls whether it's open or
closed now that right there is the same
as registering an event listener on the
button over here in The View
and then we're calling the toggle menu
class which is down here somewhere in
the toggle menu class is going to select
the items in the button and toggle some
Styles in a border and then figure out
which icon to throw on that and that is
being implemented right here where we're
deciding which one which icon to put and
then whether to show it as open or
closed then furthermore when we come
down here to the menu being open or
closed here we're conditionally
rendering the menu items based on
whether it's open
and you can see we have to implement
this whole toggle menu and entire close
menu to do that when it's pretty easy to
just say like hey if that state is true
then render it otherwise don't so that's
just kind of how we can simplify our
lives a little bit and then finally we
have the action handlers where we
register something that happens when the
game resets or there's a new round
and you can see that we will register
that on the game reset right here so
that's what we're doing with these on
click listeners so just kind of a before
and after look to see how We're
translating things so at this point we
can come back to our game and we can
open and close the menu and if we click
one of these we'll get something printed
to the console telling us which one was
clicked now we haven't actually handled
those events yet but we will do those
shortly at this point our app.tsx is
pretty much done you could of course
refactor this even a little more and add
more components to clean this up but
this is pretty readable at this point
and I don't really want to try to go any
further because there's no reason to
so now we need to add the concept of
state to our application and if you
remember from the TS refactor we had
this entire store class
which was responsible for
at the very bottom basically saving our
state to local storage and then
dispatching an event that said hey this
state has actually changed and then the
app.ts
was listening for that event here and
when it heard that event it would
re-render The View with the new state
now this whole process is totally native
to react it is in if you think about it
what this is really doing is the view is
reacting to a state change in
re-rendering something so the pattern
that we've used here is a very
simplified oversimplified version of
what react is doing and what the purpose
of react is
we just had to do it in a much more
indirect imperative fashion rather than
the declarative fashion that we're doing
it in by just you know saying like hey
if this state exists like if show modal
is true render the modal we really don't
need to do anything more complex than
that but because we're using react now
just because we're using react does not
mean that our state is going to like
change its shape or anything we're still
tracking the same
fundamental types as defined here so all
we can all we really need to do is
redefine a use State hook that will keep
track of that game state in the main app
and then we'll read that state in our
jsx to conditionally render things and
make things happen and make it
interactive since all of the state works
together and none of it's like isolated
from one another it makes sense that we
would throw this in a single state
variable
so we're going to call it State and then
just use the convention for a use State
hook
and we'll import that to react and we of
course need an initial state that will
pass here if you remember from the
original so let's go back to the store
the initial state that we passed was
this right here so what we can do is
just copy this object
and paste it into the default or
basically the the function parameter is
going to be the default State now
because we're passing this object shape
to the use State hook use state is going
to use typescript generics to infer the
type of state and if you hover over
State it's going to give you that object
shape so we could explicitly Define that
right here
and put it in the generic and Define the
type of state that we're dealing with
but it's just easier to let it infer
that and so now we have a strongly typed
State object now this is where things
get interesting so we have this state
object and if you remember from store we
are just mutating this state or changing
it in a couple of places so when a
player moves we are pushing a move to
the current game moves array
and when we reset the game we are
pushing current round games to the
history and then when we do a new round
we're pushing to all the all games array
so those are really the only places that
we're changing the state and then the
rest of it is going to be something
called derived State and that is
basically where you are constructing a
different or you're constructing a set
of information that you have derived
from that raw State object and two good
examples of this would be our stats
getter
and our game getter and in the previous
refactor that's why I called that
derived stats and derived game is
because we're basically in both of these
we're reading the current raw State and
then we are calculating things and
returning that to our application so
that it can use that information to do
things
so same thing here we're grabbing the
raw State and then calculating all this
stuff we're calculating if there's a
game winner the current player in the
status of everything so this is all
derived State and we can actually you
know what you might be tempted to do is
put you know derived State and then set
derived state in some use State call but
really you don't need to do that there's
no point in doing that because now you
have to keep these two State variables
in sync with each other
if you read through the react
documentation it will kind of explain to
you why that's a bad idea
all we really need to do since this is a
pure function is come down here and
Define our game object and then we need
to make a method to derive that so let's
call it derive game
and then we also need to derive stats
not State we need stats
so these are two empty functions that
we've defined and here we're going to
derive the game
and then stats we're going to derive the
stats now of course we need to pass the
state object into each of these and it's
going to yell at us because we haven't
defined that as a argument
so all we need to do here is say State
and then we need to define the state
shape now this is where we need to start
typing it if we go back to our types.ts
that we had defined at the very
beginning
we have this game State key that we can
use so we can pass that here as game
state
and then import that as a type we'll
also put it right here so state is game
state
and now when we pass the state object
into derived game and derived stats it's
going to accept it and at this point
it's just a copy paste exercise we'll go
back to our store which was again let me
remind you this is from our prior
refactor this is our vanilla application
not our react one all we need to do is
grab from stats we can copy the return
type of stats
and then in our derived stats we'll just
return that and now we're no longer
referencing this dot player that is
going to be we need to Define that so
we'll do that up here so if we go back
to store I think we have a players array
or no this was in our original app is
where we put that
so here's our players config so let's
copy that
to the top of our app.tsx file
so there's our players config and then
now we can just grab that from that
scope the global scope here and map
through it and we have a derived stats
object so before we get any further
let's just console that log this so
console log stats because we've
implemented that function
and if you go to the console here and
refresh you'll see that we have printed
this here twice and the reason that it
gets printed twice is because we are in
strict mode so if you go back to entry
point and see this wrapper right here
when we're in strict mode react is going
to re-render each component two times
and that is to catch bugs that happen
and I'm not going to go too far into
that but that's why we're getting both
of these re-renders not just one
but anyways we get the player with stats
and this derived object where it says
player one has zero wins and player two
has zero wins and there are zero ties
so just with that information we can
start to populate our react application
so if you go down here to the bottom you
can see that we have this static numbers
down here denoting who has what number
of wins so what I'm going to do is grab
the stats array and we know from our
config that player one is the zero index
and player two is the one index of that
array
so all I'm going to do is interpolate a
variable here and we're going to grab
the stats derived state
and we're going to look at the players
with stats and grab the first player and
then we're going to print the number of
wins in that slot right there
then we can also throw the number of
ties so stats dot ties
and then finally
stats.players with stats we'll grab the
first index which is player 2. and pass
in wins right there
so at this point our player one ties and
player 2 are getting dynamically
populated and that part is done so the
last thing that we need to do is
Implement our derived game
function right here and we can do that
by another copy paste so store.ts from
our original project not the react one
we had this getter called game
and that was basically just
recalculating some things and returning
some derived state
so let's paste that in there
we need to reference players from the
global scope here and there you have it
I think that should be pretty much it
we're referencing state right here and
that should work so now if we print the
game so console log game and refresh
here's the game we've got the current
player which is player one
there are no moves yet and the status is
complete is false there's a couple
things we can do now let's get rid of
this console log and let's also get rid
of this show modal static variable so
get rid of that we can grab that from
the game derived State now
so instead of show modal what we can say
is hey is the game dot status
complete
and if the status is complete then we're
going to open up the modal and instead
of a static message we will say game dot
status I think we're going to need to do
this dynamically so if there is a winner
we're going to say
game.status.winner dot name
wins
otherwise it's going to be a tie so you
can see how we're just reading directly
from the state
to get what we need whether we need to
render this and open it up and what the
message should be when it happens but of
course this isn't going to matter if
we're not rendering it within the game
itself
so now what we can do is read the
current state in the current game and
figure out which squares need to be
populated
so right here remember this is where we
are looping through all nine of our
squares on the game board
and rendering an icon if there's a move
in that slot so what we can do is grab
an existing move
so let me show you where this originated
from
so if we go to our original project and
we go to the app.ts
I believe that's here you can see that
when a player moves we are checking for
an existing move and if there's an
existing move we are returning because a
player can't click that twice and then
we are calling Player move furthermore
in The View
to figure out you know which squares
need to have icons we have this
initialize moves method and what it's
doing is it's saying for each Square on
the game board see if there's an
existing move and if there is an
existing move then we're going to
basically simulate a move and populate
that square
so with react all of this logic is way
easier to do so we can basically just
copy that logic right here
and we're not looking at moves we're
looking at we need to look at the
current game
moves and now the square ID is already a
number so we can just replace this
entirely with square ID So within this
map function we're figuring out if
there's an existing move and if there is
an existing move
we're going to render
that icon there now also remember on
each move we are we have the player
object available to us
so let's refactor this right here the
class name on this icon
rather than a Static X that is turquoise
we can use class names so we'll wrap
that
and let's just start over here so it'll
be fa solid no matter what and then
we're going to take the existing move
grab the player and then give it the
color class and then we'll also take the
existing move dot player dot icon class
and that will tell us what color and
what icon to render right here if there
is an existing move so now if we go back
to our game the board is going to be
empty and we still can't click anything
because we haven't listened for that
event so the last thing that we have to
do to make this game interactive is add
a click listener
on this div for this square that we're
listening for so we will attach a
callback function to this
and we'll say if there's an existing
move
we're going to return early
so we're reusing this that we
established up here so if there's an
existing move don't do anything
otherwise we need to handle the player
move and this is going to require all
the logic for handling a Player move so
I'm going to separate this out into a
hand handle Player move function and
then I'm going to pass it the square ID
of the clicked Square
and then I'm going to grab the game dot
current player and then we need to
Define this function now
so we'll come up here
and we'll say function handle Player
move it's going to take a square ID
which is a number
and then it will take the what do we say
the current player
so player is a player
so now what happens is if there's an
existing move return early otherwise
handle the player move and that's going
to be defined in this function right
here so thinking back to our prior game
how did we handle a Player move
well let's go to the view this is our
original game not a react app anymore
and looking at the view this is actually
not what we should be looking at because
this is all handled by react we already
implemented that so we need to look at
the store
so here is the player move Handler
basically what we're doing is we're
getting a copy of State we are pushing a
move to the current game moves and then
we are saving that state so
let's go ahead and just copy that
paste it here and instead of this dot
get state
we will just grab actually let's comment
this out for just a second
when a player moves we know that we need
to set the state so let's call set State
and to get the prior state that we need
to deal with we can pass a callback and
this previous will represent the prior
state from the prior render snapshot
so we can access that here
so if we wanted to now place this logic
in the set State callback and uncomment
it we can do a structured clone of the
previous state right here
then we can push something to the
current game moves and then instead of
saving State we will just return the
state clone from this set State callback
and then the only thing we update here
is we're grabbing this from the argument
so player goes directly here
and then what's it complaining about
this argument is not assignable to
parameter of type never and it's saying
that current game moves is of type never
array and that's because we did not
explicitly type this as a game move
so now we'll come through and actually
type this out a little bit and if we
wanted to what we could do
is just cast this we can say as game
State and game state is from our
types.ts right here
so we can cast that to a game State
object and that's going to fix this
because now it knows that the current
game moves is a move array you could
either do that or a better way to do it
is just say use state is of type game
State and now that will explicitly say
like hey the object I'm assigning here
is of type game state so now if we
handle the player move we should start
to see some interactivity here
so you can see that our app is starting
to work and it detects a player win now
if we click play again it's not going to
do anything and that's because we
haven't set an event listener on the
modal
so if we command click the modal to open
that file
you can see that we're going to need an
on click Handler
and that's going to happen when the user
clicks play again so on click and then
we'll pass it that on click Handler
which is going to be in props so this is
really just a way of us to basically
tell the outside world that's consuming
this modal component hey there's an
event and it's an on click event that
means that the user wants to play again
so now we'll come down here and we'll
say on click and we need to do something
to close the modal and update the state
so in this case we need to reset the
game
so reset game but the problem is we
don't have this implemented yet so
similar to how we implemented the handle
Player move we will also say reset game
oops
and now this is going to be a function
that we'll call when that modal is
clicked so similar to how we are just
calling set State and using the previous
state to find our next state we can do
that here in reset game so set state
will grab the previous state and now we
have to do something with that previous
state and derive something and return
the new state that we want the game to
be in once again we have already
implemented implemented this in our
prior refactor so let's go back to
store.ts which is where we implemented
this and you can see that we have a
reset method and then we have a new
round method we can pretty much combine
these into the same method and just have
like a Boolean check to see whether it's
a reset or new round
so let's first copy over the reset
so we'll paste that in
and instead of get State we're just
going to pass the previous Right Here
and Now what we're going to do is we're
going to read from the game which is our
derived state
and we're going to destructure the
status in the moves from there
and then finally we'll return the state
clone
which will set that new state for us
now like I said in our original we had a
reset in a new round
so all we have to do is conditionally
let's just add a prop or not a prop but
a parameter up here and say is this a
new round
and have that as a Boolean so if we come
down here to this reset game we're going
to say that's false it is not a new
round it's just a game reset and then if
you remember from our menu we have this
on action so
what we can say here is we want to reset
the game and then to detect whether this
is a new round or not we'll just say
does the action equal new Round And if
that evaluates to true then we have
reset the game otherwise it will
evaluate to false and that'll just be a
plain old reset
so we've hooked up this listener we just
have to implement that have to actually
use this variable to figure out what to
do so all we need to do is come down
here after we've reset the current game
moves and we'll say if this is a new
round so is new round
we also want to push to the history so
we'll say State clone dot history
and then all games
and then we'll basically just push and
spread the state clone
dot history dot current round games
and then we will set that
current round games equal to an empty
array so if there's a new round we're
also going to reset that so at this
point we've got the reset game completed
and I think this is the majority of the
logic so let's go try our game out
so it detects a win and if we click play
again it closes things everything resets
and down here player one has one win
let's get player two to win one so
player two wins we play again player two
has one win
let's click a square reset that it seems
to work let's go ahead and reset the
scoreboard down here
and that seems to work as well
so I think we're pretty much done let me
just kind of pause the video here and go
through and see if there's any cleanup
that we need to do and then we'll be on
our way okay so there's actually one big
thing that I forgot to come back to and
that is local storage at the moment
we're not persisting this game across
browser refreshes
so let me let me collapse some things
we'll collapse the players derived game
and derive stats
we will collapse reset game and handle
Player move just to hide them from our
view and you can see with our use State
hook this is where we're storing the
state of the game so if we were to play
a couple moves and then refresh this
browser it's going to basically reset
everything because we're not storing
this to local storage any longer and
then furthermore I realized that this
turn indicator is not implemented so
let's go ahead and do that we'll get rid
of these data IDs because we don't need
those anymore and then this becomes
pretty easy so we just add class names
around this
so fa solid and then we will just figure
out whose turn it is by saying the game
dot currentplayer.color class
game.currentplayer.icon class
save that
and so now this will be dynamic and then
finally we need to just replace this
right here with the game
Dot currentplayer.name
so this should make the color the icon
and the name Dynamic let's make sure
that that's correct
looks like everything's working except
for that part
because we have this as a static style I
think maybe an easier way to do this is
just remove this class name altogether
remove that from there and then
use the entire div to
specify the color so we'll say
game.currentplayer.color class is going
to apply to the entire div which will
style its child elements and then we're
toggling on the icon
so player one player two player one and
seems to be working now
and once again the last thing is local
storage and this is something that I'm
not going to spend a ton of time on the
implementation to but there is a way
that you can extract the local storage
function to a react hook
so we can basically make a replica of
use state but instead of just using
state it will also keep it in sync with
local storage
and in that manner we can use we can
basically have the same interface while
getting that additional functionality so
just so that we're not getting into
crazy detail or anything we already did
we already do that in these videos
I'm going to go into source and make a
hook called uselocalstorage.ts
this is a react hook you can learn more
about this if you are in the react Docs
and go to the beta docs then the new
ones and then you can go to should be
some hooks a hooks reference somewhere
let's go to the reference so you've got
the built-in react hooks
I don't know if it does say anything
about like custom Hooks and how you
would do that
oh here reusing logic with custom hooks
this is a good place to check out what
I'm about to do and understand
why we would do this but I'm just going
to copy paste everything in here to this
file this is a use local storage hook
you know basically what we're doing is
we are adopting the same interface as
the use State except we are also keeping
it in sync with local storage and you'll
see right here this is where we're like
setting a value to local storage this is
where we are getting the value from
local storage and then in the parameters
we'll pass the key that we'll use to
track that in local storage
so I've documented this a little bit you
can read through it on your own time
it's not necessarily super important to
understand all the internals here I'll
also note that I've added this effect
right here that basically keeps track of
other tabs that change
so if you were let me close some things
out and if you went back to our original
implementation app.ts this is not the
react app this is the prior videos
you can see that we're listening for the
state change this has pretty much become
irrelevant now that we're using react
because that is kind of built into the
Paradigm of react but we also have this
where we're listening to the local
storage of another Tab and re-rendering
the view if that changes so I've created
this effect here which does the same
thing and it will update the state
variable every time another tab changes
its state so I will close this
and you'll see how easy this is we'll go
back to our app.tsx and we'll just
comment out this original state and all
we need to do we can name it the same
thing so set state state and set State
and now instead of use State we're going
to use local storage and import that
now it's going to ask us for a key so
we'll say game State key
and then it will ask us for our initial
value which is going to be this right
here the same thing that we passed
earlier so we'll uncomment that so
you're going to see how quick and easy
this is to update so remember if we go
to our react game play some moves and
refresh
not going to work
but all we have to do is replace use
state with use local storage and import
that from our file
and then we need to give it a game State
key that's just the key that will be
used in local storage as that first
argument and then our default value is
the second
and that should do it that will keep the
state in sync with local storage and we
don't even have to think about it so we
can play the game refresh and it will
find the state that we're in after a
refresh you can also duplicate the tab
play something over here and then that's
going to sync up over on this side and
vice versa
so now that we've got it synced up with
a local storage I think we have
replicated that original application in
full so the last part of this is just
going to be some cleanup and making
things easier to kind of find and read
through
so let's go through and look for any
like data IDs we don't need any of these
because that was a paradigm from
the original implementation where we
needed a stable way to select
a Dom element
so we'll get rid of all those let's go
through our components
should be okay there on the menu
no data IDs there and we're good
and then furthermore we can just extract
some of these things out so let's make a
file called
utils.ts this will just be some utility
functions
and if you remember we have this derived
derived game and derived stats and then
we also have the players up here outside
of our component itself
so we can take all of this stuff
you could leave it here there's no
problem with that either but I can throw
all that into a utils file
and then we can export them from it okay
and then we just need to import a few
types from the types file
so we'll import the player and then the
game state
and that should satisfy these functions
so those are now isolated to the utils
file and then we of course need to
import them so command period to import
from utils
do that again here and you can see we've
got that import
and that should work okay so that kind
of cleans up our app file
we no longer need use State because
we're doing the use local storage hook
which uses State under the hood so we'll
expand this out and this is pretty much
the final game once again you can find
all of this code in the repository I've
left in the video description be sure to
look at the typescript branch to find
this exact implementation I just did
there's also a non-typescript version of
the same app so now that we're done we
can close out this develop developer
server the webpack dev server and a good
thing to do is always to just check to
make sure that it builds correctly so we
have these build scripts and let's just
run yarn build
and what this will do is basically check
all your types type checking compile
everything bundle it up and output it to
the public directory with bundle.js
and we can also try the build prod to
make sure that it does its optimizations
okay and it doesn't complain about
anything
so there you go and then finally we've
got live server running on Port 5500
already and since we just built this app
it's totally static and you can actually
view this directly from the public
directory rather than using the webpack
dev server
so you can think of it as webpack came
in did its job compiled everything
transpiled everything and gave us one
nice clean bundle output and now we're
just ready to go we've got what we need
and the browser knows how to load the
app
so let's go back to the browser
and we'll go to localhost 5500 close
everything out and I know we've got a
lot of folders here but let's go to the
live react refactor and then if we click
public it should give us the game and we
should be able to use it just like we
were with the dev server so we can reset
we can get a new round going and just
play the game so just wanted to show you
that's a good thing to do check your
build make sure it works and then you
could really just you could deploy that
this game right here over any CDN
because it's static assets so you could
put it on cloudflare you know whatever
you want and it can be served to your
users thrown on GitHub Pages what have
you
so hopefully this was an educational
video that hopefully you enjoyed seeing
how we can go from a vanilla JavaScript
application and Port that over to react
and kind of see the benefits of using
react it makes a lot of our code a lot
simpler we basically went from let's
just kind of recap we went from this
live TS refactor where we had an app
let's just close all this out you can
just scroll through this is our main app
file where we're registering all the
event listeners controlling everything
this is our state
where we have our store class
and this is our view where we are
handling selecting all the elements up
here
we are rendering here so this basically
what react is doing for us and then
we're binding event listeners got all of
our helper methods here and all of this
stuff it's pretty verbose what we've had
to write here we even have the delegate
method so that we could figure out which
Square was clicked and that was pretty
confusing so we've gone from this
over to our react application which as
you can tell if we go to app.tsx
it's pretty concise what we've got here
we don't have any delegate methods we
can just handle everything
basically right here with some event
handlers we've got a hook that helps us
deal with local storage and then we have
our components split out by their
separate concerns also with their
separate CSS so that's just a much
cleaner way to write an application and
it's a lot easier to extend into the
future let me know what you thought of
this video be sure to give it a like And
subscribe to the channel and I will see
you next time